JavaScript gives us specific
capabilities to perform any website
related task including design the front
end and working on the back end it's
this is just one of the numerous factors
contributing to javascript's appeal in
2022. the research shows that JavaScript
stands among the world's top 10 most
widely used programming languages
if you want to know about the importance
of JavaScript try disabling it on your
browser and your web pages will not work
properly in fact sites like Facebook
Google Netflix and YouTube will not work
without JavaScript so hello everyone and
welcome to the simply on YouTube channel
I hope you guys are doing well today we
will be taking you through the
JavaScript full course we will cover
everything in this video from Basics to
advanced level topics don't worry if you
are a newbie or an advanced level
developer this video will help you in
different aspects so before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple technology videos
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological friends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply
learning so let's go through the agenda
for this tutorial we'll start this video
by understanding what JavaScript is
where we will see how JavaScript came to
existence we'll also go through the
different reasons to learn JavaScript
following that we will cover basic
JavaScript topics like document object
model in JavaScript and vs code
installation
will also create a hello world program
in JavaScript next we will cover the
fundamentals of JavaScript including
JavaScript statements comments variables
data types type conversions and
operators in JavaScript then we will
move on and cover topics like control
statements and Loops in JavaScript
both topics have the outmost importance
when it comes to any programming
language once we are done with the basic
topic we will move ahead and cover the
intermediate level JavaScript topics
like JavaScript functions strings and
arrays
following that we will cover important
topics like objects prototypal
inheritance and many more such topics
once we are done with the basic and
intermediate level topics we will move
on to some advanced level topics like
callback functions promises Arrow
functions regular expression and formal
Edition in JavaScript
will work on certain projects to end
this video we'll create a verbal game
and a functional website it is rightly
said that you can Master a programming
language just by programming in it I
hope you guys are ready to learn
something new
so without any further Ado let's start
the first topic for the day JavaScript
was developed in the year 1995 by a
person named Brendan Ike Brendan was
working for Netscape Communications
while he developed JavaScript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javanus and non-engineers no one ever
knew that this small side scripting
language would have a great future today
more than 90 percent of the websites out
there they are using JavaScript somehow
many of you guys gets confused with Java
and JavaScript let me clear it for you
that both Java and JavaScript they are
different languages they have almost
nothing in common many people say that
JavaScript was named after Java as a
part of a marketing strategy to gain
wider acceptance and recognition in 1995
Java was a buzzword when JavaScript was
developed that's why they renamed
JavaScript after Java let's move on to
what is Javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
Amazon the home page of Amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of JavaScript
in Layman language JavaScript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when JavaScript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
JavaScript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
Android or in iOS but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for Android we have to learn Java
and XML and Swift We have to learn for
iOS but with the help of JavaScript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
Tech giants like Google PayPal Amazon
and YouTube they are using JavaScript
these days the evolution of JavaScript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
Gmail let's suppose so Gmail is a single
page website which looks more like
desktop software than a website so Gmail
is based on angular.js it is a popular
framework by Google which is free of
cost and it is totally based on
JavaScript now let's go over some of the
features of JavaScript these features
are actually why it is considered that
using JavaScript is advantages over
other languages
so let's start some of these points
JavaScript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like C plus plus and Java they
need a compiler to work but with
JavaScript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly next up is
lightweighted Javascript can provide
programming facility to some extent in
JavaScript you don't need to specify any
data type or return type which helps in
making development more quicker that's
why it is known as light weighted
JavaScript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
JavaScript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well there is a way to validate the
user's Data before sending it to the web
server and we can do that with the help
of JavaScript the data will be checked
for correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data JavaScript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
JavaScript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider JavaScript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept it does support
other features of object oriented
programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
JavaScript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions JavaScript differentiates
between capital and lower case letters
we have to keep this in mind while
programming
now I will quickly go over some of the
JavaScript applications where JavaScript
is currently being implemented first one
that comes to every person's mind is web
development it was also the main motive
behind developing JavaScript we have
Technologies like angular we have
node.js we can create beautiful web
pages also JavaScript can be used along
with HTML and CSS to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
JavaScript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
JavaScript can take over traditional
Android and iOS app one of the most
important and unique application of
JavaScript is in smart watches the
bangle.js is an open sourced Smartwatch
powered by JavaScript Gordon Williams
the man who is currently working on this
project it is said that this new open
sourced stack built around JavaScript
will replace the onboard firmware soon
the next application of JavaScript is
client-side validation as we discussed
earlier JavaScript is used to validate
the user data whether the user's input
is correct or Not by cross checking it
with the given condition like the user
wants to enter in your website and you
want it to be a user with at the rate
gmail.com in his email ID so you will
give that condition to JavaScript and it
will cross check it with the user's
information like when the user will try
to enter in your website it will check
that if at the rate gmail.com is there
or not in the user's email ID
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
JavaScript is game development
JavaScript can be used to make fully
fledged 2D or 3D games using different
libraries although most JavaScript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
JavaScript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
JavaScript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use JavaScript the
first one is the basic knowledge of HTML
and CSS to use JavaScript along with
HTML and CSS you first need to know how
HTML and CSS Works see HTML is used to
create the structure of a web page while
CSS is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with JavaScript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn JavaScript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
HTML and CSS it's better to have a web
browser that supports JavaScript like
Google Chrome or Mozilla Firefox or you
can use Safari as well if you are using
a MacBook you will need an operating
system like Windows Linux or Mac
operating system to learn JavaScript a
computer with minimum 512 MB of ram
would be enough for you to start
learning JavaScript but I will recommend
you a computer with 1GB of Ram or 4GB of
RAM for a better experience you can use
any text editor you have notepad which
is free and is already available for
Windows if you don't want to use notepad
you can use other free softwares like
sublime or you can use visual code in
this particular course we will be using
visual code and I'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
JavaScript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
JavaScript let's start this video with
some facts about JavaScript
JavaScript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the Market at that time just
like Java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser JavaScript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of JavaScript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
website's backend JavaScript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
JavaScript means almost every website
out there is using JavaScript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack Overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
Overflow states that JavaScript is the
most popular programming language used
by the Developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
JavaScript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks JavaScript is constantly
growing and is a well-paid job
JavaScript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
JavaScript provides wide range of usage
as well let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
JavaScript has the most powerful
Frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to design a
website like Gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design UI
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful JavaScript
Frameworks next up is constant truth one
of the main reasons behind one should
learn JavaScript JavaScript is one of
the fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
Mobile Market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is Possible only with the help of
JavaScript that's why JavaScript is
continuously growing and there is no way
that JavaScript will go down shortly
the developers working in JavaScript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn JavaScript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
JavaScript jobs section
JavaScript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages like Java Python and PHP
JavaScript provides easy entry points to
the world of programming the best thing
about JavaScript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
JavaScript which means you can start
coding right away JavaScript has the
largest community among all the
programming languages out there
Community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is the more
help you would be likely to get
currently JavaScript has the biggest
stack Overflow Community it has
overtaken Java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
Pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn JavaScript by knowing
JavaScript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
end apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
backend you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with JavaScript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning JavaScript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in USA and in India
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client-side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in India but if you are a full
stack developer in US you can earn up to
hundred thousand dollars per annum which
is a huge amount
front-end developer is the one who deals
with the front end of any website or
application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer but the
amount of money a front-end developer
earns in a year is decent a JavaScript
developer works on the front end and
sometimes backend all
a JavaScript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a JS developer in US
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to Indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a UI is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a UI ux designer earns in India is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to Dom
Dom stands for document object model it
is an API for HTML and XML documents
which helps JavaScript to understand
what is their return inside the HTML
document API stands for application
programming interface to understand API
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what API does it works as a
moderator between JavaScript and the
HTML document Dom defines the whole HTML
document in a hierarchical form to make
it understandable for JavaScript so that
other JavaScript functions can work over
it it represents the entire document in
the form of object and nodes whether it
be elements or text or anything stored
in the document the entire page content
can be accessed or manipulated by
JavaScript
Dom is not used with JavaScript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model every
browser uses Dom to make the web page of
the document accessible by JavaScript
let's move on and see what is document
object model with the help of an example
I believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of HTML and CSS a prerequisite
for this course let's start things off
with a basic HTML example here we have a
code that consists tags like HTML head
body heading tag Etc we have the HTML
tag here the opening HTML tag and the
closing HTML tag inside the HTML tag we
have the head tag which contains the
documents header part inside the
headtech there is a title tag that
contains the title of the web page then
comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with IDs as
div 1 and div2 a div tag defines a
particular section in the HTML document
the ID used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it CSS and JavaScript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it let us first
see the output of this code before going
to the document object model of this
whole document so guys this is the
output of the previous code we just came
through here we can see the title of the
web page as well as heading after it
there were two different div tags used
in the code here is the output of both
the div tags the question here is where
are those ID and class attributes seen
in the output the answer to this
question is there's nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our CSS file or through
JavaScript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the HTML cool but how
JavaScript uses this code is a bit
different that's where Dom comes into
play when the actual HTML document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in HTML document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the doll next starting from the HTML
tag and covering all the other tags like
head title body and few more the same
hierarchy as there was in the HTML
document goes with the document object
model also document to object model is
simply the same HTML document with
different representation the reason
behind this different representation is
that it's easy for JavaScript to
interpret this format JavaScript can't
understand tags but it can understand
these objects JavaScript can easily
manipulate these objects using different
functions which we will see in future
while working on these function for
example if you want to access the text
present inside the heading tag you can
do it by accessing The Heading tag with
JavaScript you can also work on the
style of this text with the help of
JavaScript as well JavaScript uses the
concept of nodes it can access nodes of
the document object model there are many
types of nodes present in the Dom the
basic three types are element node
attribute node and text node the element
node consists of all the tags used in
HTML document like the head tag and the
body tag the attribute node contains the
attributes used in HTML document by now
I hope you have understood the concept
of attributes so JavaScript can access
these attributes as well and the user
can work upon them as per requirements
the text here in the HTML document that
is simply it can also be accessed with
the help of JavaScript it is the value
of that particular element before
installing vs code let's discuss a few
things about what is an IDE
so IDE stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshops makes it easier for us
to edit photos in the same way IDE makes
it easier for a programmer to write code
if you want to write code IDE will help
you write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of Ides present in
the market today we have Sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is a open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
Mac it is available for Linux and
windows as well I think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to Google and
search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from their official website click on
that and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only or if you
want to download it for you according to
your PC's specifications you can click
on the download button present at the
top right corner of your screen here you
can see that vs code is available for
different platforms it is available for
Windows for Linux and for Mac as well
you can download it from here as well so
if you want to download this for Windows
you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
condition you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it this window will open where
you have to select the location you want
your vs code to locate
any ID you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want but for now I'll be
leaving it as it is and I'll click on
next now this will open and you will
click next from here now it will ask you
some questions like if you want to
create a desktop icon or not select all
of them and click on next now click on
install and it will install vs code for
you sit back and relax it will take time
so once you are done with the
installation process click on finish and
the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is Explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder
and just search any folder or you can
take any folder of your choice so here
in my PC I'll go to work and I'll
take JavaScript as my folder I'll select
it and see it will open the folder and I
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and I have a few more programs like this
and this you can open any program from
that folder by using this Explorer
option you can open any program present
in that folder so basically what it does
any program you make in Visual Studio
code you will save it in this folder
only so it will be easy for you to open
any program anytime next up we have the
search button to find any keyword or
word present in your code whatever you
write here it will show you where it is
present in your code or in your document
so let's suppose I write here simply
learn C it will show you simply learn in
your main screen so you have a shortcut
key for this also press Ctrl F from your
keyboard and write anything here like
it's written simply linear press enter
and it will show you the result the
third option here is for Version Control
if you want to use any Version Control
like you want to use git vs code has
very good integration with Git the next
button here is for debug or it will run
your program once you are done with
writing the code click here and run and
debug just open it with chrome you have
a shortcut for this as well press F5
from your keyboard and it will do the
same the next button here is for
extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
Community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is HTML CSS support just click
on the search button write HTML CSS
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few modes you have to
install JavaScript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way I'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
is
close it create a new file we will name
it as new DOT HTML so it's new DOT HTML
here one thing you have to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with DOT HTML extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic HTML code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code Studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as I have
already mentioned you
have a web browser with JavaScript
enabled in it so if you are using Google
Chrome it's quite easy to enable
JavaScript let me take you through open
Google Chrome go to settings and just
write JavaScript in the search option go
to site settings and scroll down you
will find here JavaScript allow it if
it's not allowed in my case it's already
allowed so I'm good to go once you have
downloaded the editor and you are done
with the environment setup and all you
can start writing the program so let's
go to es code we will open a new file
here and save it with the name let's
open a new file and we will save it with
name
first.html make sure to save your file
with DOT HTML extension as it will make
it easy for the computer to understand
that this particular file is an HTML
file so in the last video we installed
an extension named live server let me
tell you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic HTML program or just press
the exclamation key and press enter here
we are with the basic HTML program we
have not done anything yet just edit it
a little bit we'll add a heading tag and
inside the heading tag we will write a
heading let's suppose we are writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
but this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see just use Google Chrome
or whatever browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we'll be
using it side by side now let's suppose
we'll change something here let's add a
word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we'll be using it during our whole code
so now we are done with that let's start
with the program so here we are with a
basic HTML code which has only tags in
it it will print that thing if I remove
this heading tag let me remove and
moment I save it it will print nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these HTML
tags are used to render HTML files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
HTML tags you can use as many tags
according to your requirements in our
first program we will write a single
line statement over the browser for that
we will need the script tag don't worry
if you don't know much about script Tech
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
JavaScript with HTML this is where HTML
and JavaScript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or Point towards the external script
through the SRC attribute we will see
the srci attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
a program so let's start with this first
let's start the scripted
and we are done with it now the script
tag we have to type in attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write it is a
JavaScript method using which you can
print anything on the browser let's see
what document.write can do let's write
here something
document dot right
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to Simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press Ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to Simply code we can Define
JavaScript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will Point towards an
external Javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute SRC and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any Javascript file so
let's create a file burst name it as
crypt.js remember you have to save it
with DOT JS extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong I guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that JavaScript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was
script.js
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here initially it was Hello
World welcome to Simply code but now it
is Hello World welcome to Simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external Javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed JavaScript with
HTML and now let's see some of the
features of document.right so let's
suppose you are you have written this
text here let's erase it and see what
else it can do let's give it a task to
add two numbers let's suppose we have
given you nine plus three let's see if
it works see it will give you the output
directly here document.write 9 plus 3 it
will give you other output as 12.
similarly you will do any mathematical
task any calculation you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by
feet
see you can see here 12 56 Square let's
give it another one 9 multiply 5 minus
let's suppose 3 and save it 3 9 into 5
is 45 and if you minus 3 from 45 you
will get 42 here is the answer for s 42
56 is for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and
12 is for 9 plus 3. so with that we are
done with how to embed with a JavaScript
with HTML let's move on to another
Concept in JavaScript that is
console.log console log is a function in
JavaScript that works the same as
document.write but it will not print
anything in the browser let's give it a
try let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console Dot Lock
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write complete code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browsers console go
to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use Control
Plus shift plus I which I normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles courses Network and many more
but for now let's focus on Console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things we don't always
know what to expect as the output maybe
we expect a particular result but we
might get something else one way of
debugging our code is that we can pass a
value to this function here only and we
can check the result of that value out
of the code let's add two numbers here
so if you don't understand it basically
what we are doing for now we are writing
a small piece of code like the program
is not that big but later on when we are
good with JavaScript and we will use
JavaScript as a primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to check the output of your
code by doing that only so if you are
using any variables or you are using any
functions you can check the output here
only if you have to use that variable in
that way or you have to change something
so you will get it here only that's the
use of console.log let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to 5 and let
these value is 8 suppose okay we are
done with these two numbers and we will
what we'll do we will write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is 13 you can do any
complex calculation here in the console
it will give you the correct answer you
can see here script.js column four the
number after the column is the line in
script dot JS here in our file we can
see that the console.log command is in
line number four so here it is written
that it is line number four here so if
you click on this
you can see the script.js opened in a
very small window and you can edit it
from here as well so this is not a
random line number to prove this let's
go on to our program and let's move this
to another line see now the console.log
is in line 11. save it and here you can
see this also changed to 11 so let's
make this more complex add another
variable C we'll add another variable
here let suppose we add C here we'll
give it a more complex equation let's
suppose let C equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer oh no we are done with the
equation let's change it here also the
value of
C is
let's see if it works or not press Ctrl
s it's saved and the value of C is seven
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27. 27 plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20 27 minus 20. the value of C is
7 say it's correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
control DOT log or you can do something
more interesting with document dot right
so console log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program in the previous video we learned
about a first JavaScript program I
explained you some basic things like if
you want to perform addition if you want
to add two numbers or you want to
perform subtractions and multiplication
and division as well before moving
forward to statements and comments here
to take a note while you are performing
any calculation let me show you see if
you are performing any calculation let's
copy it from here and paste it here
so yeah if you want to perform and let's
add two numbers like we want to add 45
and
we will add let's say 5. we will save it
and here you can see the answer is 50
here right so if you want to perform any
calculation you have to write as it is
you can't write any calculation within
inverted comma or double inverted comma
let's try this if you want to write any
calculation within a single inverted
comma the moment you save it it will
print it as 45 plus 5. what the browser
will do the browser will interpret it as
text and print it as it is so there will
be no change so keep that in mind take a
note of it and we are done with it right
now so let's move on to statements in
JavaScript so guys whenever you use any
programming language you give the
computer
some instruction to perform any task or
activity that's common in all
programming languages present out there
like you are giving computers a few
instructions to do a particular task
these instruction you are giving to the
computer are known as statements you see
the code written over here this
document.write function is an
instructional statement given to the
computer to write something on the
browser like if you are writing hello
world inside this function it will print
it in the browser as it is and same for
addition subtraction multiplication and
whatever you are writing inside it it
will basically print it on browser like
let's suppose if we write here something
else
let's suppose we write here inside
double
inverted comma
welcome to Simply code we save it we are
basically giving it the instruction to
write this on the browser so what it
will do it will write it as it is on the
browser these are the instructions we
are giving to a machine to perform a
basic task or to perform a certain task
so if you are writing a whole program
for designing a website or for anything
you must be using more than one
statement you will use a lot of
statements in a single program
so all these statements are separated by
semicolons like here you can see after
every statement I have written a
semicolon it's necessary let me show you
an example see we'll remove this
statement and we'll copy this line and
paste it in the next line and write
something else here but we can say this
is our first program we will write like
suppose I have written it I'll give it
the semicolon here the moment I'll save
it see you can see here it's written
that hello world the first statement say
statement is interpreted and written
over here then second it come to welcome
to Simply code see here you can see that
I have not written any semicolon but
it's still showing the output
so let me tell you something interesting
so if you remove the semicolon from any
of these statement here it will work
fine which means JavaScript will forgive
you for these small errors you do but
it's always a good practice to put a
semicolon after every statement because
while writing a whole program in future
you will use n number of statements and
let's see what happen if you try to
write more than one statement in a
single line without any semicolon let's
do this thing here write more than one
statement in a single line and I'll save
it see it won't work the moment I put
the semicolon here and save it it will
work fine
so that's why I am saying that it is a
good practice to use semicolon after
each statement
hope you guys are getting this let's
move on to comments so a comment is also
common for almost all programming
languages it's a line in programming
language which do not have any effect on
the output of the program see it stays
there in the code but it does not affect
the output by any means a comment may be
a multi-line comment or a single line
comment as well to write a single line
comment we just use double slash in
front of that statement like here if we
see the output is Hello World welcome to
Simply code this is our first program so
to make this first statement a comment
what we'll do we'll use two forward
slashes in front of it and it will
become a comment so the moment we will
save it this hello world is disappeared
from the output
so this is how to use a single line
comment a comment won't affect your
program by any means let's move on to
multi-line comments to write a
multi-line comment you have to use
forward slash along with the asterisk
sign see if you want to make these two
lines as comments to end a comment we
will use asterisk sign with a forward
slash these two statements are comments
now so the moment you will save it
welcome to Simply code is also
disappeared from the output that's how
comment work they won't affect your
programs out but comments are very
useful in programming it's just a note
for the programmers to remember what
they did at that particular part of the
program suppose you write a program see
here the programs are not that large and
the coding is not that much but in
future when you write a program maybe
the program will be of more than 500
lines or more so suppose you write a
program with more than 500 lines and
come back 20 days later so at that time
you can't go through the whole code this
is where comments will help you in
JavaScript it will help you to remember
what you did at that particular part of
the program so variables are named
storage that a program can manipulate as
the name suggests a variable is a value
that can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
JavaScript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to 15 we will
declare
where B and the value of B will be 6 we
will declare where
C and the value of C would be a plus b
so here we have defined three variables
a b and c a is a variable with value 15
stored inside it and so is B the value
of B is 6 but C is a variable that will
contain the value of a plus b let's try
to print this on browser
document dot right
and we will print the value of C
save it and here you can see the value
of C is 21.
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for a n
will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of C is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of B
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
2015 two more ways were introduced to
declare a variable these are let end
const we shall discuss these two terms
in the later part of this session let me
show you how to declare a variable there
are a few things you have to keep in
mind while declaring a variable name
here we have seen we use three variables
a b and c that was an easy task to do
but giving a variable any name like
something other than a single alphabet
so you have to keep a few things in mind
while naming them start them with the
letter underscore or a dollar sign you
can't use any sign except underscore or
dollar so if you are giving a variable
name you can't use any other sign except
the underscore or the dollar sign you
can use these two signs only you can't
use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in JavaScript JavaScript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
JavaScript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in JavaScript we'll
save it and see here it throws an error
unexpected token class but you can use a
class with capital c let's save it and
here it will work fine
why it works because JavaScript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
Let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital G this
time JavaScript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for JavaScript as
JavaScript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variable let's comment this part as well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bikening where bike name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name we use equals to
operator to assign it a value cosine
let's suppose we'll assign it Yamaha
semicolon and press Ctrl s to save this
and here you can see the output as
Yamaha you can also assign a value to
the variable during declaration as we
have done in the previous examples here
we have assigned the variables value at
the time of Declaration only let's move
on to let end const so we will discuss
let and Cones but first we will compare
let with where let is also used to
declare a variable just like where is
used but there is a limitation to use
let
is not accessible outside the Block in
which it is declared
so we will use let here only let byte
name equals and we will change this
value as well we'll change it to Hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but if we try to put
this code inside a block let's suppose
we put this code inside this block a
pair of curly braces and we will again
try to access document dot right we'll
try to access bike name again from here
from outside the block we try to access
this save it and here you can see bike
name is not defined it is an error in
line 18. so what's happening here
basically you can't access a let
variable outside the scope you can't
access it from here but it will work
with where we try to replace let with
where and save it here you can see it
says hero and hero because first it will
interpret this method and then it will
interpret this as well in case of where
due to its limited scope light variables
are used when there is limited use only
like in for Loop or in while loop we
will learn these Loop in future let will
not allow you to redeclare any variable
let's understand this with an example
here's the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we will try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to TVs Control Plus s it says
hero and TVs so the variable name the
bike name is same in both cases here and
here as well these are same but with
where keyword you can do that let will
not allow you to do this if we use let
here in place of where we'll write let
as here as well and we will change the
value as well we will give it as
Kawasaki
and
let's suppose Suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same light variable
in different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword const is little misleading as it
defines a constant reference to a value
not the constant value we can't change
the Primitive value but we can change
the properties of constant objects let's
write another piece of code for const
keyword
so let's declare a variable const
X is equal to
5.
comma Y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable X and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declare it this time with
const keyword and variable Z which is X
Plus y we printed Z on the browser and
it shows the value as 12 which is X Plus
y 7 plus 5 is equal to 12. now what we
will do const will let you do this but
if you try to update the value of x
let's suppose we try to update the value
of x as x equals to X
Plus 10.
we'll print X this time
document.write
X let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to redeclare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier X has already
been declared this thing you can do with
cons the scope of const is the same as
lead it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential Concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable the type
of variable is holding basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way we discussed earlier that
JavaScript is a lightweight scripting
language because we don't need to
specify any data type in JavaScript
after all all the variables in
JavaScript are Loosely packed or we can
say JavaScript is a dynamically typed
scripting language we shall discuss
these properties later in this video for
now let me tell you about different data
types present in JavaScript
so JavaScript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-premitive data types they are stored
in Heap I don't want you to go deep in
these two terms as if you are new to
programming so we'll leave it just keep
one thing in mind that primitive data
types are base data types whereas
non-primitive data types are objects or
we can say they are derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings Boolean
undefined and null non-primitive data
types or complex data types we can say
on the other hand they are divided into
two parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where X and give it
the value as 16. will declare where Y
and will give it value
hello world we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of JavaScript which I mentioned earlier
JavaScript variables are Loosely packed
and JavaScript is dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables X we
have defined variable X we have defined
variable Y and flag as well the values
for all three variables is different
from one another
see variable X is holding a value that
is 16 variable Y is holding a value
hello world which is a string so 16 is a
number hello world is a string and
variable flag is holding a value that
refers to a Boolean value in place of
true we can also write false here
so what's happening here here you can
see there is no data type if you are
coming from a C plus plus background or
a Java background this will be a little
bit weird for you guys because in C plus
plus and Java we used to do it like we
will define an integer let let me show
you
so how we will Define integer in C plus
plus or Java what we'll say we'll use
int x equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying C plus plus but here in
JavaScript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as Loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in JavaScript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
JavaScript which are number
Boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll Define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable P has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
I'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable P we'll check the type of P so
to use this operator you have to use it
with document dot right now
so we will do document.write and we'll
use two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like we want to
know the type of variable X let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here from X to Y in this line
and from X to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character for variable flag it says
Boolean so it's defined as true or false
and for variable P it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there's a difference between a
null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here's an example for
this C will declare one more variable
here we'll declare where num let's name
this variable num and we will give it
the value as null we will use
document.write type of and we will check
with the help of type of operator that
what type of value the variable num is
holding so let's give here
num
we are good to go press Ctrl s and C
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object we'll talk about the complex
types or composite types in further
videos we'll have separate videos for
each of these types type conversion as
the name suggests conversion of value
from one to another in the previous
video we declared a few variables we
declared numbers strings and Boolean as
well in JavaScript you can change the
data type of any variable from one to
another you can change a number to a
string or a string to a number let's see
an example of type conversion let's
declare a variable here
let's suppose we are using a variable
let's say where num equals to and the
value will be 34 and will print it first
and we'll use type of operator to see
the data type of this variable
save it and see here it shows 34 and a
number I've already told you about the
use of console.log in this topic we'll
use console.log just for a change you
can use document.write as well there is
no problem with any method you are using
let's move ahead and we'll declare a few
more variables we'll declare a string
and a Boolean as well
let's suppose where Str equals to
hello
and we'll print it as well let's copy it
from here and paste it here
and we'll declare one more variable
let's say where Bool equals to
true
let's print these three variables first
see the output is pretty simple we can
see the value and data types as well see
34 is a number hello is a string and
true is a Boolean value
so let's convert this number to a string
first this number 34 this is a number
here right and we'll convert this number
to a string so how to do it that's
pretty simple all you have to do is
write a word here let's write here write
string with a capital s
and put 34 inside a bracket so here we
are done with it save it and see here
you can see 34 which was a number first
and now it's changed to a string
that's how you can change the data type
of any variable let's try to change a
Boolean value to a string now many of
you guys gets confused with Boolean so
Boolean is nothing if something is true
then set it to true and if something is
not true like if it's false then set it
to false see if we talk about a real
life example say if you know how to
drive create a variable drive and set it
to true and if you don't know how to
write set the variable to false that's
pretty simple that's what Boolean is
let's change a Boolean variable to a
string we have to follow the same steps
as we did for numbers what we did we'll
write here string and put true inside
brackets
we are done with it save it and check
the output here you can see the type
changed from Boolean to string like
string function we can also change a
string value to a number
so how to do it let's take a variable
let's say where str1 will take let's say
we are giving it a numeric value let's
say eight nine six eight
and what we'll do we'll write a console
log and will print it basically
str1 and will right here as well
save it and here you can see 8968 is a
string so how to change this string to a
number that's also a simple task all you
have to do is write here number with
capital n and put this value inside
brackets
save it and see here you can see 8968
changed to a number it was a string
earlier and now it's a number so if it's
a number now let's update this number
and we will see if we are adding
something to 8968 the value will change
or not let's update str1 what we'll do
we'll write str1 equals to str1
plus let's add a number say
so the output should be eight nine seven
zero and the type of operator will give
the value as number let's see what's the
output now save it and see here you can
see the output changed to 8970 but if
you add an alphabet or a character in
the value then the output will be
different here we will copy this whole
code
and we'll paste it here
we'll change the value of str1 equals to
str2 and we'll use an alphabet along
with this number let's suppose it's 8968
a so a is in alphabet and what we'll do
we'll comment this line and we'll go
here and change the value str1
here we are done with it save it here
you can see it says n a n it means that
it's not a number it won't treat this
string as a number because it consists
of both numeric value as well as
character
now let's try to convert a Boolean value
to a number in the case of a Boolean
variable the scenario is a bit different
let's try this
let's declare a variable let's say we
are using where Bool 2
and the value will be true
what we'll do we'll print the value here
you can see true and the data type of
true is Boolean so let's try to change
this Boolean value to a number that's
pretty simple task write here number and
put true inside brackets
save it and here you can see it says one
in case of Boolean variable
the value of true is 1 and the value of
false is 0. remember this guys keep this
thing in mind if you are changing a
Boolean variable to a number then the
value of true will be changed to 1 and
the value of false will be changed to
zero
now let's have a look at percent and
parse float as well after which I'll
tell you one more interesting function
let's move on to past tense first here
I'll declare a variable let's suppose I
am declaring a variable let's say where
and we'll name this variable as number
the value will be a string let's suppose
it's 56
we will print it console.log
here you can see that the output is
showing 56 is a string so the data type
here is string because I have used here
single inverted comma so it will take 56
as a string
now let's suppose I want to parse this
as an integer or say I want to change it
to a number I can use percent as well
apart from number if you want to use
number that's fine but apart from number
if you want to use percent you can use
it
let's see what happens if you use
parsint use percent and put 56 inside a
bracket
save it and see here it changed the
string to a number 56 was a string
earlier right and now it's a number just
like percent we have parse float as well
parse float will do the same thing but
what if you are using a decimal number
here let's see if you are using 56.343
save it
but percent will do it will give you
let's change 56 first let's suppose we
are using 65 now save it and see percent
will give you the value as 65 only it
won't show you the value the decimal
value
but if you are using here number or pass
float it will give you the whole numeric
value let's see what happens if you use
number here
number and save it here you can see the
value is
65.343 like number if you are using here
pass float
let's use parse float here
and we'll change the value here as well
let's suppose it's 72 point
543 save it and see here it will give
you the whole numeric value of the
variable I hope this is clear for you
guys
now there is one more function you can
use in numbers which is dot 2 fixed so
this function has by default zero value
let's suppose I am using here we have to
use it here only let's see what happens
if I'm using number Dot
to fixed
so inside bracket we are giving it a
value by default the value is 0 Let's
suppose we are giving it the value as 2.
now save it and what will happen it will
give you the value as
72.54 similarly if you are using here
some other number let's suppose seven
you can see we have only three digits
here after the decimal we have three
digits only that is five four and three
what happens if we run this program now
let's save it and see it says five four
three zero zero zero zero so it will
show you the value up to seven decimal
points it doesn't matter if there are
available numbers after decimal point
but it will show you the value instead
of 7 you can also give here 30 let's
save it and see it says 6366 and so on
hope this is clear for you guys in any
programming language an operator is a
symbol that makes the computer
understand that it needs to do some
specific tasks like if you want to
perform an addition between two numbers
let's say we want to perform addition
between four and five so guys if you see
the plus sign here this is known as the
operator and the two terms which are
four and five these two numbers these
are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have Plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well so there are many more
operators present in almost every
programming language which is present
out there like it operators are present
in Java they are present in C plus plus
in C almost every programming language
out there has the concept of operators
it's essential for you to know how and
where to use any operator despite of the
language you are working on one needs to
understand which operators are available
right so in this particular video I'll
take you through the basic types of
operator present in JavaScript I'll let
you know the types and we'll learn about
how to use them and of course I'll take
you through the different categories of
operators present in JavaScript so in
JavaScript there are basically eight
categories into which operators are
divided which are we have arithmetic
operators we have assignment we have
string we have conditional we have
logical bitwise comparison and type of
operator we'll discuss the first three
types in this video that is we'll
discuss the arithmetic operators we'll
discuss the assignment and the string
operators rest we'll talk about in the
following video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic right
so arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well so
here are the few operators you can see
on your screen the plus operator minus
asterisk division we have modulus we
have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys I want to
mention one more thing here I want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators you will create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics
we'll cover in future from today so I
want you to create a separate file
because you know in future if you want
to access these topics it will be easy
for you to access those files instead if
you are using a single file for all the
topics it will be quite confusing so
let's start with the arithmetic
operators first let's take two variables
we are in the Javascript file let's take
two variables let's say where x equal
equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication I have
commented the division because I have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's six plus four
similarly for subtraction and
multiplication it is 6 minus 4 and it's
6 multiplied by 4.
for division I have left division
because I hope you guys know the
difference between Division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll comment these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll paste this here and
we'll use the modulus here so now let's
check the output what it says for
division and modulus
see we have divided 6 by 4 division it
says it's 1.5 6 divided by 4 that is 1.5
it will show the quotient here for
modulus it's saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in division it gives you the
quotient as the answer so keep this
thing in mind guys keep this in mind
always take a note of it so we are done
with division and modulus next up we
have the increment and The decrement
Operators let me show them to you real
quick so what we'll do we'll declare
another variable let's say where Z
equals to 5.
and we'll use the increment operator
here we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus plus whatever variable you have
used so we'll use plus plus Z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens let me give
some space in between them so that you
won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
says 5. so you can see here the
functioning of decrement and increment
operator the increment operator will
increase the value of Z by 1 and the
decrement operator will do the opposite
of this L decrease the value by 1. so we
are done with the arithmetic operators
next up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different JavaScript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators here here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals to
and we have multiplied equals to we have
divide equals to modulus equals to and a
few more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every single operator out
there which is present in your screen so
let's move on and see let's move on to
the programming part so here we are guys
let's declare a few variables let's say
we are declaring a variable a and we are
giving it the value as 10 suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where B and give it the value 5.
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator mean we have used
here the equal to sign right we have
used a equals to 10. this means whatever
value present on the right side of the
operator like here it is 10 it will be
assigned to the variable a
I hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind so we have the value 10 and
we are assigning this value to the
variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10. and similarly the value of B
is 5. so let's do one more thing we'll
assign the value of a to B how to do
this let's change the value here only
let's suppose we are using the value of
where a is 13 okay and the value of
where we will be providing as let's say
a
so now let's try to print the value of B
here we'll change
will print the value of B only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of B is 13. because we
have assigned B the value present at
variable a which is 13. that's why it is
showing the value of b as 13. this is
what assignment operator is let's try
other assignment operators as well
let's take another variable
so let's say where even
equals to let's say 51.
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of A1 first so
how to do this let's say A1 equals to no
it's a 1 plus equals to 9.
and we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of A1 is 60. here
we have given that A1 plus equals to 9
see even plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here A1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to A1
Plus 9. both of these lines are same
both these statements means the same
they are performing the same task so A1
equals to A1 Plus 9 is same as a 1 plus
equals to 9. that's what I want you to
understand with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals to you can do it as well
so let's say A1 minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of A1 so in the
first statement when we try to print A1
here the initial value was 51 then this
statement was performed and the value
was updated to 60. then after that one
more statement this statement is also
performed and the value updated to 69
it's 51 plus 9 plus 9 and the value we
have here is 69. now what happens if we
are using the minus equals to operator
what it will do it will decrease the
value of A1 by 5. it means that A1
equals to A1 minus 5 the value of A1 is
69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of A1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this so we
have so many operators we have so many
of them like let's try a few more so we
have multiply equals to we have division
equals to we have modulus equals to so
I'll write these and then we'll see the
output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for A3 A4 and A5 you can see
for A3 we have used multiply equals to
for A4 we have used divide equals to and
for A5 we have used modulus equals to
let's check the output here
save it and see it says the value of
a350
it here we have taken a3s5 it's 10 into
5 because A3 equals to A3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of A4 is 3.75
because we have used your food so
instead of 4 let's try to use 3 and save
it see here you can see it divides it
and gives you the quotient and the value
of A4 divided by 3 is 5.
so similarly for A5 it shows the value
of A5 is 6.
because we have used the modulus
operator here N20 divided by 7 we have
6s remainder
so I hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in JavaScript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for Strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is wood so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world but there is no space
between hello end World keep this point
in mind guys so if you are adding two
strings just like this there will be no
space between the two strings so if you
want to add any space between these two
what you have to do you have to mention
it here separately
and this this is the syntax if you want
to add space between your strings so now
let's save it now and see here you can
see there is a space between hello and
world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as whereas tr3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do we'll use the plus
equal to operator here str3 plus equals
to
let's say
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now see here you can see it says
hello world for the first str1 plus str2
it says hello world for str3 it says
welcome to Simply code see here the
space is already given so it will show
this in the output but between welcome
and two if you want to add space you
have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here as well
plus sign yes save it now and see here
you can see it says welcome to Simply
code with proper space now we will cover
the rest of the operators now we are
left with five more these are the first
three operators now we are left with
conditional operators logical operators
we have bitwise operator and we have
comparison and finally we have the type
of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today before we start
with the operators let us first discuss
associativity talking about
associativity it refers to the direction
in which the entire expression is
evaluated for example if you have any
expression let's say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see I have taken three
variables I have taken variable a and I
have assigned it value as 12. I have
taken variable B and the value assigned
to B is 8 and finally I have a variable
result which stores the value of a plus
b
lastly what I'm doing is I'm printing
out the result variable inside the H1
tag here you can see I have used the H1
tags and I have used the plus operator
to concatenate the strings right I have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result so the plus operator here is
doing two different tasks right here you
can see it is performing the addition of
two numbers right and here you can see
it is used to concatenate two strings so
now let's talk about associativity
because I guess you guys are clear with
string operator till now we have
discussed them in the previous video
right so let's talk about associativity
now so certain operators have right to
left associativity and certain operators
have left to right associativity so when
I say right to left associativity in
this case the value present at the right
side of the operator see if you are
using any operator for example here you
we have used the assignment operator
right we have discussed the assignment
operator earlier so here you can see the
value present at the right hand side
side of the operator will be assigned to
the variable which is present at the
left hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable C
and we are giving it the value as
5 and what we'll do we'll update result
as well let me first show you the output
of this particular program see the
output will be value of result is 20 and
high there high there is concatenated
with the string value of result is N20
is the actual answer the 20 is the value
of result so let's add one more variable
here let's say we are adding a variable
C and the value of C will be 5. what we
will do now we will update result as
well here you can see I have done a plus
b plus c
so
save it and here you can see the value
updated to 25 the value of result is
updated right so the plus operator has
associativity from left to right till
now we have talked about right to left
as for assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of C will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25 we
know that JavaScript is a Loosely typed
programming language right which means
that we don't have to specify data types
every time like we are using if we are
using any data type we don't need to
specify it every time like let's do one
thing let's add a string here so what
we'll do we'll add a string light
suppose I'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
Plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the sensitivity of the plus operator is
from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello 12 8 and
5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting as string
here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do we'll remove this string from
here and we'll add it somewhere else
let's say we are adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable D and the value will be 10.
and what we'll do we'll perform a plus b
before the string and then we'll perform
C plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it it says 20 hello 510 so when it
reached out the first variable it finds
out that the first variable is a number
so it added the first two numbers right
it added 12 and 8 the answer is 20 then
it came across this string hello and
then finally it assumed that everything
ahead of this will be a string so that's
the output 20 is the addition of a plus
b and then the string hello and finally
we have the value of c and d as string
so we have the value 5 and 10 not 15
right I hope you guys get this
so let's move on to conditional
operators the conditional operators
assign a value to a variable based on a
certain condition like it contains a
condition and you know for every
condition like there exists only two
possibilities either it can be true or
it can be false there is nothing else
you can do with a conditional operator
so it works the same as if Health
statements which we'll cover in further
videos the only difference between if
else and conditional operators that it
takes less time or we can say its usage
is pretty easy
so here is the Syntax for conditional
operators so it seems pretty
straightforward right so here you can
see we have a variable name we have a
condition depending upon the condition
we have two values
here's the example as well C you can see
we have a variable voter next up we have
a condition if age is less than 18 so it
will check for the condition that if the
value of age is actually less than 18
let's suppose the value of age is 15. so
it will check if 15 is less than 18 it's
true then it will print 2m or if the
value of H is greater than 80 then it
will print false or you can say it will
print old in a few
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 30. what we'll do in variable y I
have given it a condition so it will
check for X which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equals to 50.
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if you update the value of axial let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right also if you want to write
a message here only you can do it write
it here as so we'll copy it from here
we'll copy document.write
and we'll paste it here
let's remove this document.write and we
what we'll do we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write value of
so
and now what we'll do will
save it
see it says value of true so or you can
write any other message here as well you
can write value of x is greater than or
you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now see here it says value is
greater value of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a condition like here it is
it's a it has a condition and it has two
values right it has true or false so
that's why it is also known as ternary
operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables or values we can say we use
logical operators to check whether
multiple conditions are true or false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in JavaScript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or note are the three
operators present in JavaScript
the and operator here you can see it it
is holding two values right it it has X
less than 10 and y greater than 1. so
the end operator will return true only
if both the conditions are true like X
has to be less than 10 and Y has to be
greater than one so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and Y equals to
4. so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why the output of the and
operator will be true for our operator
the case is a bit different so if any
one of these Square two conditions like
we have two conditions if any one of
these two is true then the output will
be true and if both are false then only
the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to Y if the
value X is holding is equals to that of
Y if the value is not equal then it will
return true
I hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value X and Y
holding if they are not equal then it
will return true if they are equal then
it will return false
right
we'll understand the programming concept
of logical operators in further videos
when we learn about control statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen these
are the different types of comparison
operators present in JavaScript we have
equals to we have not equals to we have
equal value and data type we have
greater than less than and we have a few
more so I hope you guys must remember
from the previous video that a single
equals two operator is an assignment
operator so if we are using a single
equals to then it will be considered as
an assignment operator for comparison we
have to use double equal to keep this
thing in mind whenever you are using any
operator in JavaScript or especially the
equals to operator so if you want to
compare two values you have to use
double equals to because single equals 2
is used to assign values this is an
assignment operator so let's move on to
the programming part now
so guys here you can see I have taken a
variable X and the value assigned to X
is 10. this code seems a little bit
longer to you but that's a simple piece
of code like I have used almost every
comparison operator we came across in
the previous slide I have used each one
of them and I've used the document dot
right after every comparison operator to
put some spaces in between so that you
guys don't confuse between them so let's
check the output now see you as you can
see I have used the double equals to the
triple equals to I have used X not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with 8. and 10 and 8 are not
equals to so the output will be false as
similar for 10 and we have used the
triple equals to operator which means
equal value and data type so both 10 and
8 have equal data type they both have
the same data type that is number but
the values are different so it will
print false
for X not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for X not equals to equals to it it will
check that both the values are not equal
but the data types are equal right so it
will print true for this as well for X
greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater than 8
so it will print true similarly for it
will check for X smaller than 8 and it
will check for X greater than equals to
it and also for X less than equals to it
so by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you put to the right of it like if
you are using any data type and you want
to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say so you can
use the type of operator it will tell
you the actual data type of any variable
so in JavaScript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
Boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see I have used four
different variables which are I've used
variable X variable Y and variable flag
and variable P so the values are
different the x is holding 17 why is
holding header and flag has the value as
false and I have defined P but I have
not assigned it any value till now so
what I'll do I have used the type of
operator to find out the type of every
variable like here I have used it for X
for y for flag and for p
let's check the output now
save it and see it says number string
Boolean and undefined see here we have
given X the value as 17. so 17 is a
number then it says it is a number for
hey there it says it is a string for
false it says it is a Boolean value like
in Boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable P it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to any variable like you are using
the variable as it is like here we have
not given it any value so if you are
doing this the type of operator will
return undefined so let's take an
example of null as well let's declare
another variable let's say where ABC
and will give it the value as null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable ABC is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost 7
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers if you
know the numbers are stored in binary
format bitwise operators work on 32-bit
numbers and we have decimal numbers like
we understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then convert it back to a JavaScript
number
so
here you can see on your screen we have
four different bitwise operators we have
the and operator we have or we have not
and we have zor or we can say exclusive
or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see we have used the
and operator before as well while we
were in logical operators but the syntax
was different and
here you can see we have a single
Ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have X as 5
here you can see X is first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work let's take an example of
bitwise operators
so here you can see I have taken two
variables I have taken variable X and
the value of variable X is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then I have used all the four
bitwise operators like I have used X and
Y I have used X or Y I have used not X
and I have used the xor operator between
X and Y so let's check the output now
here you can see if we talk about the
output see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and
4 so for X and Y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for and
operators it will return 1 if both the
values are 1. if any one of the two
values are 0 then it will return 0. so
what it will return here it will return
0 for 0 0 for 1 0 it will also return 0.
similarly for 0 0 it will also return 0
and for 1 1 it will return 1 which is
the binary equivalent of 1. so the
answer here is 1.
for x or y it will return 1 if any one
of the two values are 1. see if both are
0 it will return 0. if any one of the
two values is 1 it will return 1.
it will return 0 again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and 0 1 0 1 is the binary equivalent of
5. that's why the output here is 5.
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
C minus x minus 1 will be minus 5 minus
1 which is minus 6 so this is a bit
different here the not operator here is
a bit different for xor operator or we
can say exclusive or it will return four
why it will return 4 it will return 1
when any one of the two values is one if
both are one then also it will return
false it will return 1 only in one
condition if any one of the two values
is one then only it will return one
that's why the output here
the output here will be 0 1 0 0 that's
why it's written as 4 which is the
binary equivalent of 0 1 0 0. so let's
take a look at control statements with
the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that is n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement 1 till statement n and it will
execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu every time
for example let's suppose you are in
line 5 and you want to print this line
10 times so what should you do you can
write this line 10 times or you can copy
paste it right okay let's forget about
10 times let's suppose you have to use
this code or we can say let's suppose
you have to print this statement 100
times doing this like copy pasting it
for 100 times or writing this statement
for 100 times that's useless and
unnecessary right so that's where
control statements comes into picture
we'll discuss them in a while let's
assume another situation this time you
want to make a choice based on certain
conditions you can use conditional
operators but then it has limitations
right to tackle this problem we have
control statements in JavaScript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity like if we
want to perform a certain activity n
number of times or if you want to make a
certain decision making kind of
scenarios in your program that's where
we need control statements in JavaScript
in JavaScript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's where we use conditional
statements we have two different types
of conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch keys
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe a number of times instead of
writing them again and again
we use Loops so Loops are basically
statements we use Loops to perform any
activity n number of times with specific
conditions
so in JavaScript we have four different
type of Loops we have for Loop while
loop do while loop and foreign Loop
so the for Loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages but this
foreign Loop this is a new type of loop
present in JavaScript we use foreign
loop with objects we'll go through
objects in upcoming videos and of course
we'll be looking at each of these
control statements in detail
will have a particular video for each of
these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements the break is used to
exit a switch statement or Loop like
when used in a loop it breaks the loop
and continues executing the code after
it
and on the other hand the continue
statement breaks a single iteration when
used in a loop when we use continuous
statement in a loop it breaks a single
iteration and it breaks the iteration
only if the specified condition occurs
and then it will continue with the next
titration in the loop so the if else
conditional statement is used whenever
we work with condition it can be either
a single condition or maybe more than
one condition or multiple conditions we
can work with
so let's try to write a basic program
with a single condition so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
elsif statement so we'll create a new
file today so I hope you guys know the
importance of creating a separate file
for every topic you know it will be easy
for you to work to find out that
separate file later if you want to
revise that topic so here is the program
where we have taken a variable X and the
value of x is 10. so what we are doing
in this program is we are checking if
the value the variable X is holding that
is value 10 and if the value is less
than
10 or if the value is greater than 10.
so we have only two conditions either
the value can be less than 10 or the
value can be greater than 10 or equals
to 10 is
so here in this program what we'll do
we'll first we'll update this value as 8
so the variable X is holding the value
8. so to check the output let's save it
and here you can see it says the value
of x is less than 10. of course the
value 8 is always less than 10 right so
for 8 that's fine it will say the value
is less than 10 and similarly if we do
the same for let's say 11 save it now
and see it says the value of x is
greater than 10. so that's quite simple
right but what if we are giving the
value as 10. we know 10 is equals to 10
so save it now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
10.
this is happening because what we did we
as we told The Interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10. so it will
check for only X is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10 so here
what it is doing it is checking if the
value is less than 10 so that it says
okay let's print this statement if the
value is less than 10 or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals 2 or greater than 10
it will print the value of x is greater
than 10. to avoid this type of
misunderstanding we use an elsif
statement so the concept of else if
statement is the same as if statement
but we are doing we are using multiple
conditions right we are giving it more
than one condition so how to use else if
it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an else if so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value X is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10.
and what we'll do we'll update it as
so let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to time right so I hope you
guys are getting this the execution flow
for this program will be like it will
check for the first condition if x is
less than 10 if yes it will print the
value of x is less than 10. if no it
will move on the to the following
condition like under the else if
statement it finds a condition that if x
is equals to 10 it will check for it if
yes if x is equals to 10 then it will
print the value of x is equals to 10.
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that if x
is less than 10 or if x is equals to 10.
now we'll take a look at some basic
programs other than this one we'll take
a look at a few more basic programs
so here's the another program what we
are doing here is we are taking a
variable X and the value of x is 5. so
what we are doing is we are checking if
the number is an even number or an odd
number the thing you have to keep in
mind is the logic to find whether a
number is even or an odd number so to
check uh whether a number is even you
what we do we'll divide that number with
two right but basically we want is we
want the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written X mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the reminder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even and odd number
so here we are with another program here
it says we have a variable Y and the
value of y is
let's say
eat and what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero so we have three
different conditions either number can
be positive or it can be a negative
number Any number greater than 0 is a
positive number right and any number
less than zero is a negative number and
the third one is a number zero it's
neither positive non-negative so let's
check for the number eight save it and
see here you can see it is a positive
number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0. so these two
programs are quite simple guys right the
conditions are pretty simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two so what we'll
do in our next program is we'll check if
a number is positive or negative and at
the same time we'll check for even an
odd also
if you are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether a number is positive or
negative and odd or even
so the two methods we'll discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement so this one here
you can see right in front of your
screen is
the nested if method so here you can see
we have used the if statement we have
given one more condition inside another
if statement so first it will check
whether a number is positive or not for
X greater than 0 it will check if the
number X is greater than 0 then if yes
if it will find it that yes this number
is greater than 0 then it will move on
to the nested if and it will check for
odd or even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number is
positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so here
you can see the difference what The
Interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd so if it finds that the
number is even it will print negative
and even otherwise it will print
negative and odd and the last condition
is for the number 0. let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as 8. so save it now here it says the
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well let's update the
value of x is minus 5. save it now it
says negative and odd number minus 5 is
a negative odd number right so that's
how it will check for positive
or negative end odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program we have an alternate method as
well here you can see on your screen we
have written a program and here we have
taken a variable X the functioning of
both the programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and odd or even
so here you can see I have taken a
variable X let's say the value of x is
7. it will check for X greater than 0
and x mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so
we have four different conditions right
a number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
and odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is 0. okay we have five
conditions and we have to specify these
four conditions here so here we you can
see we are using the logical and
operator this means it will print this
statement let's suppose for this
statement it will print this only if
both the conditions are true right if
the number if the value X is holding is
both greater than 0 and an even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and out
so the number seven is greater than zero
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is positive and odd the
switch case is another conditional
control statement and just like the if
else control statement there is a
difference between the usage of if else
and switch case statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use which case over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user for an input
between 50 and 100 a numeric input
basically and in the output we have to
print the textual form of that number
suppose if the user enters 75 right the
output will be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else or we can say
else if control statement but the
program will be so lengthy and not so
clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option we'll get to know why in a
bit so let's move on to the programming
part and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number so we have 12 months in a
year for example if we enter 4 then the
output will be April and if we enter 8
then the output will be August because
August is the eighth month of the year
right so I hope you guys are clear with
the question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using IF else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario so let's create a
variable first let's say we are creating
a variable where month and
you can give any value to this variable
from 1 to 12. you can provide it with
any initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and the value we are providing it
one as the hardcore initial value for
Simplicity again we are not taking the
input from the user or from the browser
to do so we have to first go through the
Dom manipulations and we'll go through
it in later videos so let's start with
the switch case now
the Syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as one for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so next up we have an open and a curly
braces for the body of the switch case
we have to test for 12 different
conditions inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value month variable might
hold like 1 2 3 and so on followed by a
colon right so we have to write the
value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a column
keep this thing in mind guys and below
that we are going to write what we want
when the value is 1 like what the output
we want when the value is 1 so we have
to write document
dot right
and
whatever you want as the output like for
when the first month is January so we
are writing here
January and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is 1 you
will get the output as January save it
and here you can see the output is
January
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
January right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is once
we are done with the output we get our
output right once we are done with case
1 we get our output as January this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case so let's say we are writing a one
most cases
case two
and the output will be
document dot right
the second month is February right
and February we can write so
we'll include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says January
so if we don't include this break
statement here when The Interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is 1 right
so it will print January
but it will print other statements as
well so for example if we remove this
break statement and save it now see you
can see here the output as January and
February January and February both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here see
the value is 1 and if we include break
statement here the moment The
Interpreter finds the answer the correct
answer as January it will come out of
the switch keys
so I hope you guys are getting this
similarly we'll write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be June if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
October and so on and so forth
now the question here is what if we try
to write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that if we try
to write any value other than these 12
values from 1 to 12 if if we leave these
values then if we try to write another
value like if we write here 13. so what
will be the output now let's save it and
see there is no output and there might
be no error for this as well so if you
try to check for an error go to inspect
and check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here default
with a colon and right
document
dot right and let's suppose we are
writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press Ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right analysis
statement we don't need to specify any
particular condition any condition other
than the if condition or else if
condition will fall inside the else
statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so you must include this default case in
your program every time while using
switch gears because it's quite useful
you know okay so this is the complete
program to find out the month by
accepting its number
so if you try
six
and save it now it will say June if you
try 10 save it it will say October if we
try 12 save it it will say December so I
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because the switch case in
JavaScript Works differently from other
languages like switch cases also present
in C plus plus and Java but in
JavaScript it is a bit different so in
JavaScript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and Boolean values as
well now let's have a look at how the
switch case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is June right and you can see
use this string in case as well so here
you have to give the case as a string
value right because we are using switch
case statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be June the output should
be sixth month and when the value is
July the output will be seventh month so
let's check it out if this is working or
not let's save this program and see for
June it says sixth month and similarly
we can check it for July as well let's
check for July
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to it will be similar like
there's no difference for default case
let me show you how
will write here wrong input
save it and now let's try to change the
value here let's say we are using May
save it and see it says wrong input what
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well it will give you the
output when the value is either June or
July
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for Boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for Boolean values so what you
have to do instead of 2 you have to give
here a Boolean value let's suppose you
are writing here true and for true you
have to change the case as well for true
you have to change the output as let's
say for true it the output will be 1.
okay and similarly for false
the output should be 0.
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now and
see here for true it says one the output
you can see here is one and if you try
to do the same for false like let's
write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says 0.
you can see the output is correct right
so we will discuss uh our first
iterative control statement that is the
for Loop in JavaScript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements we'll make a
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for Loop which is the first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that we use for Loop when
we are clear with the number of
iterations in advance so let's start
with the first program in this program
we will print the multiplication table
of 10 from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10.
let's start with coding
first we write the four keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally we have the increment or
decrement
so this is the Syntax for for Loop next
up we have the open and the closed curly
braces for the body of for Loop
we'll change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one so we'll what
we'll do we'll leave it here only we'll
change it from here so in the
initialization part what we are going to
do is we'll create a variable let's say
we are creating a variable where a and
the value of and the initial value of a
will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for Loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use because sometimes what
happens is the loop runs forever because
of a wrong condition which will
ultimately crash our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for Loop should execute here in
this case we want to print the table of
10 right we want to have 10 iteration
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to n and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10.
it will start from a equals to 1 and it
will go till a less than or equals to
10. and next up we'll use the increment
operator we want to increment the value
of a by 1 every time right so we'll use
increment operator a plus plus or we can
say a equals to A plus 1 both are the
same things right so here the condition
will be like this for variable a equals
to 1 a less than equals to 10 and a plus
plus
so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will will be
increased by 1 every time because we
have used the increment operator right
next up the body of for Loop will go
like so what we want to print if we want
to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot right and inside document.red we'll
use the H1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so we'll
multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser so we'll close
the H1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100. so
what is happening is firstly the for
Loop is also known as the entry control
Loop it means that the condition is
checked initially the first time the for
Loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value is stored at variable a
is 1. initially the value is 1 next up
it will check for a less than equals to
10 is a which is 1 is 1 less than equals
to 10 then true the control will be
shifted to document.write and it will
print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2. now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10. now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11.
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10. no we
know that 11 is not less than equal to
10 right then it comes out of the loop
and it will print nothing after that so
this is the basic working of the for
Loop we'll go through one more program
wherein we'll print the odd numbers
between 1 and 10. so what are odd
numbers odd numbers are those numbers
which are not divisible by 2 right so we
have the odd number says 1 3 5 7 9 and
we want to print them so the difference
between each number is of 2 the 1 plus 2
plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right so what we
have to do is we have to write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2. and instead of writing
here 10 into a because this time we
don't want to print any multiplication
table we want to print a number only
right so we'll use a only
save it and check the output it says
13579 so these are the odd numbers
present between 1 and 10.
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for Loop while loop is also an entry
control Loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for Loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for Loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times we'll start with the
programming partner and then we will
discuss more about when to use while
loop over for Loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number let's
say we want to print all the odd numbers
up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right
we came across the same program in the
previous video as well but this time we
will use the while loop instead of for
Loop so the Syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use the code goes
like we start with the while keyword
then opening and closing round round
brackets and finally the body of while
loop in curly braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we use the for Loop we had
three different parts right we had the
initialization we had conditions and the
increment decrement part here we have
only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable X and the value
of x will be 1.
we used a 1 because 1 is the very first
odd number right after that inside the
condition what we want to do is we want
to print the odd numbers up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
X less than equals to 50.
so the loop will go till X is less than
or equals to 50. or we can say x less
than 15 that depends on us if we want to
check for 50 or not so the odd numbers
will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to 50. so the last odd
number will be 49 so inside the while
loop we will print the value of x so
here we will print the value of x let's
print it
document dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the H1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite Loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for Loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well then we had
the condition we have a condition here
as well and then finally it has an
increment or decrement part right so
here we don't have that same increment
or decrement part we have to do it
separately so we'll increment the value
of x here only so here we will write X
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as x equals to X plus 2 you guys
are aware of it right so the reason is
simple because we want to go from 1 to 3
to 5 and so on that's why we use X plus
equals to 2. we incremented the value of
x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says one three
five seven nine and so on and so forth
till 49 so 49 is the last odd number
before 50 because we are checking
between 1 and 50 right so 49 is the last
odd number
let me show you how the program goes
into an infinite Loop so for that what
we have to do we will comment this whole
line here let's check the output now
save it and here you can see it is
refreshing forever and this is basically
how a program in an infinite Loop looks
like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to open a new tab and
then again we have to run the program
with correct increment part so here you
can see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
1 up to 50 and the last one is 49.
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for Loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for Loop so where to use while loop
over for Loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is y we want
to do something let's say we want to
print something on the screen or if the
input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the Dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do while loop in
JavaScript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for Loop and the
while loop are entry control Loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control Loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the loops
body thus an exit control loop executes
at least once even if the test condition
fails or we can say the condition is
wrong the loop will execute once using
the do while loop is relatively easy it
seems like we are giving the system a
command to do something while the
condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we'll write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the do while
loop the do part and the while part or
we can say the condition part while part
is the part where we write the condition
so let's Define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable X and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while X
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5. or if the value of x is
smaller than or equal to 5 it will come
out of the loop in the do part we will
write what we want to do let's say we
want to print a single sentence here we
write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first titration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always so if
we try to save this program and let's
try to run this here you can see the
output is welcome to Simply code
a single line is printed what is
happening here is although the condition
we used was wrong but the condition will
be checked only after the first
iteration when the Dual Loop will
perform this particular statement when
the document.write will be performed
after that it will check for the
condition if x is greater than 5 or not
if we use a 6 instead of 5. let's try to
write here 6 instead of 5 and if we run
this program now it will go into an
infinite Loop because we are not
performing the increment decrement
operator here right as we have discussed
in the previous videos the importance of
increment decrement part so we need to
do it here after the document.write part
so what we'll do here we'll write x
minus minus today we are using x minus
minus and for the other two Loops we use
the plus increment operator right so the
x minus minus is the same as x equals to
x minus 1. let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to Simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition and it
will print here welcome to Simply code
for the first time when the loop will
start executing it will first perform
this statement and it will write here
welcome to Simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1. so when
the value of x is 5 then it will check
for the condition if x is greater than 5
or not so here we can see clearly X is
not greater than 5 because x equals to 5
and it is equals to 5 right so it will
come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x and we'll use a
space so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the BR tag and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simplicode every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do I Loop when we
want the code to Output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
Dual Loop this video is just a syntax
demonstration we'll go through the
examples of all the three Loops present
in JavaScript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate Loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each Loop
we'll go through so let's start this
session with the first problem statement
so the first problem statement goes like
this so here we have to write a program
to check whether a number is prime or
not I hope you guys are aware of what
prime numbers are right so a prime
number is a positive number that is only
divisible by 1 and itself for example 2
3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right if we take
an example let's say we are taking an
example of 7 so 7 is a number which is
divisible by 1 and 7 only no other
number can divide 7 right so here in
this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first so we have a
variable number and the value of
variable number can be any random value
like any number you want to check if the
number is prime number or not you can
give that value to the variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime whose value is a
Boolean value right it can be true for a
prime number or it can be false for a
non-prime number
so we have used comments in this program
to make it easier for you guys to
understand so here we have used the if
statement to check if the number is 1
because we know that 1 is neither a
prime number nor a composite number
right so we have to check if the user
enters the value one or if we are giving
the value 1 we have to check for it so
if user enters the value 1 it will print
this statement that 1 is neither prime
nor composite
here in elseif we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for Loop present inside the elsif
statement right here you can see we have
the for Loop here the control will be
shifted to this for Loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable I
and the initial value is set to 2 that's
because any prime number is divisible by
1 as well right so it won't make any
sense to include one here will start
from 2 and we'll check until the value
of I becomes half of the value of number
so if we take an example of 10 we'll
check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now I hope you guys are aware of
how to use for Loop and why we are using
for Loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for Loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
Loop so then we have the I plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of I by 1 after every iteration until
the value of I becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent I equals
to equals to 0. so here is the main
condition to check if the number is
divisible by I or not so the execution
will be like if we are taking here a
number 10 it will start from 2 and it
will check if the remainder is 0 or not
so if the remainder is 0 then the value
of is prime will be changed to false and
it will come out of the loop
next it will check for the value of is
prime if the value of S Prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print n or we
can say then it will print that the
number is a prime number else it will
print that the number is not a prime
number if the value of is prime is false
for example when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of S Prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0 or
we can say the remainder will be 0 so
the value of S Prime will be changed to
false and for false it will print number
is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than one if the number entered
by the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take here minus 5. so
it will print the number is not a prime
number
Because by the usual definition of prime
numbers any negative number cannot be a
prime number that's a usual definition
right so we have to keep this thing in
mind and here in this else Loop we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and the output says 83 is a prime number
as 83 is not divisible by any number
except 1 and 83. for example if we take
here any number which is divisible by so
let's say we are taking 75 save it now
and see it says 75 is not a prime number
okay here's a spelling mistake it says
75 is a not prime number so here we'll
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically so
let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking minus 7.
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now so
it says the number is not a prime number
or if we want to try for one as well
let's take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that one
is neither a prime nor a composite
number
you can try this program with the help
of other Loops as well so let's move on
to the second problem statement but
before that let me take you through the
same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the file
Loop for the same instead of for Loop
here you can see we have used while I
less than a number by 2 and we have
given the increment condition here and
we have initialized the value of I
at the start of the program so if we try
to run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in JavaScript to
check whether a number is an Armstrong
number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program before proceeding
to the coding part let's have a look at
what is an Armstrong number so an
Armstrong number of three digits is in
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself
so for example 153 is in Armstrong
number since 1 into 1 into 1 it means
the cube of the digit 1 plus the cube of
5 that is 5 into 5 into 5 which is equal
to 125 and the cube of 3 which is three
threes are Nine and Nine threes are 27
so it will go like 125
plus 27 plus 1 so which is equal to 153
so an Armstrong number of three digits
is an integer such that the sum of the
cubes of its digits is equal to the
number itself so here we have the code
for the same this is the code to check
whether the number is an Armstrong
number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an Armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an Armstrong number next up we have
taken a variable sum and the initial
value of sum is 0. we have used the
variable sum to store the value of the
cubes and next up we have a temporary
variable so that we can break a three
digit number and we need the number
after all this all this program all
these loops and all will need the number
we'll need the original number to
compare it with the sum of the cubes
which will be hold in sum so but we need
to break the number as well right so we
need a temporary variable to break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than zero so the initial
value of temp will be 153 here in this
particular case the initial value will
be 153 and the loop will run until the
value of 153 is greater than 0. next up
we have a variable remainder that stores
the last digits value as we are dividing
153 by 10. so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value save that variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen when we are updating the value of
sum and the MU value of sum will be 0
plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are Nine
and Nine threes are 27 so the updated
value of sum will be 27 next up we are
removing the last digit from the number
so for example we have here one five
three and if we divide 1 5 3 by 10 the
answer will be 1 5.3 that's why we are
using here percent because what percent
will do it will convert the float value
into an integer so if we try to perform
a simple divide in JavaScript like if we
try to divide 153 by 10 it will give us
15.3 it will give us a float value but
we want an integer value right so
percent will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be one
five then again this Loop will be
executed and for this time the variable
reminder will hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5 which is 27 plus 125 right so the
new value of sum will be 152. and then
again it will go to the temp and it will
divide 15 by 10 and it will change the
value to an integer so 1.5 will be
changed to 1 and next up the final value
of temp is 1 which is greater than 0
right so it will divide 10 by 1 and the
reminder will be 1.
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10 using the percent
but this time the value will be 0
because there is no remainder right
next up we'll compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 1 5 3 is an Armstrong
number or if we use any other number
instead of one five three let's suppose
we are using 121 so it will print 121 is
not an Armstrong number let's check out
the output ones let's save it and see
the output is 153 is an Armstrong number
so if we change the value of one five
three two
one two one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an Armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the answer here will be 10 because the
cube of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8
and the cube of the final one is 1 so 8
plus 1 plus 1 is equals to 10. so that's
why one two one is not an Armstrong
number
let's move on to our last problem
statement where we'll use the do I Loop
to find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number so factorial
of an integer is the product of an
integer and all the integers below it or
we can say before it till 1 so if we
take an example of 5. so the factorial
of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be 5
into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1. or if we
don't include one that's totally fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two video
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable I which is
initialized as one then we have a
variable n which is 5 and then we have a
variable F whose value is 1 F is for
factorial and n is for number we want to
check the factorial of and I is for
checking the condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where if we for example if we are taking
5 then the loop will go from 1 into 2
into 3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that
number it's not like if we are using
from 5 towards one but we are going from
1 towards five the answer will be same
right because we are multiplying all the
numbers in both the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable F and the value of f
is also one as you know so here we are
using the do while loop for the first
iteration it will perform this so the
value of f for the first iteration will
be f equals to F into I which means f
equals to 1 into 1 which is 1 so the
value of I will be increased and it will
become 2 and now it will check for while
2 is less than equals to n yes 2 is less
than n so it will again go up and it
will update the value of F and the new
value of of f will be 1 into 2 that is 2
then again the value will be increased
and it will become 3 and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of I will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5 and then it will multiply 4 with
6 because the value of f for 6 right so
4 into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of I will be 5 and it
will check if the value of I is less
than or equals to 5 right while I is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of I will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of a number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120. because
see here we have used the factorial of
n n is 5 and the factorial is 120 so if
we try to give any other number here
other than 5 let's say we are using here
10 save it it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
or it's 36 let 28 800. so if you try to
multiply 10 into 9 into 8 into 7 so
until 2 or we can say 1 the answer will
be this you can check it you can Google
it or you can go through it in your
calculator the typical definition of
function states that to work in a proper
or in a particular way similarly
functions in JavaScript are a block of
code that is used to perform a specific
task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions so a function has a particular
name and we can reuse that block of code
again and again in our entire program
for example let's suppose that we have
to add two numbers in a program that's a
basic program right sum of two numbers
so let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable X and the value
of x will be 10. and then again we are
going to take a variable Y and the value
of y will be 5. lastly we are going to
take a variable total and the value of
total will be X Plus y
so the last thing we are going to do is
we are going to print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15. so
what is happening is
the value of x plus Y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right now
consider a scenario where we have to do
this addition for n number of times at
different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again I'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts we'll go through each of
them a function has function declaration
then it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function so let's move on and see how
the function looks like how the syntax
of function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function this is the way to write a
function next up we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the function so
this is the basic syntax of how a
function looks like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
JavaScript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming Convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out phone any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program this is happening
because we haven't called the function
yet right so to call the function we
have to write a single word just write
sum with opening and closing round
brackets and save it now now you can see
the output here is 15. so this is known
as function calling the program already
knows that there is a function by the
name sum it will go and check for the
same if the function is there or not if
the program finds it it will execute the
function next up a function can also
have parameters what do I mean by
parameters is we don't have to declare
these variables variable X and variable
y here instead of declaring them here we
can pass these values to the function
let's say we are passing X and Y here or
we can pass A and B any variable you
want to pass you can pass it here
now we can remove these variable X and
variable y we have to write here where
because we still need the variable total
and next up we have to pass the value
for these variables when we call the
function so we have to pass the values
here let's say we are passing the values
as 4 and
3.
so let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as 7.
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome to
and instead of 3
will pass simply code right now let's
save this program and see the output it
says welcome to Simply code we don't
have to worry about the data type we'll
use here because JavaScript is a Loosely
typed language right so the function
will automatically adapt to the data
type according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable X holds the value welcome to
and the variable Y is having simplicode
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as parameter passing in
functions let's move on and discuss the
return types in functions so a function
can also return a value right now we can
see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there is nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and Global variable
we'll discuss this concept in upcoming
video so here you can see it says total
is not defined right so now what we have
to do is we have to write here return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to end simply code
right
so these parameters will go as X and Y
and we are getting the concatenation of
Welcome to Simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function the value of this
total variable will be given out of the
function so there has to be a particular
variable to hold the value returned by
the function
will use a variable here let's say we
are using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the LHS and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this that whenever we are
using an assignment operator the
assignment will be done from right
towards the left so whatever value the
function will return upon calling will
be assigned to the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of Simply code we'll use a
15. and we are going to print here
output on the browser because the
variable output is holding the value
returned by the function right so let's
save it now and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in JavaScript
with a quick small program that
JavaScript is a Loosely typed scripting
language right that means we don't need
to specify the data types every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in JavaScript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in JavaScript local
variables and Global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable a variable may have two
different types of scope so let's have a
look at these two different types of
variables with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable where a and the value of a will
be 5. so we have created a variable here
and let's print the value of this
variable in the browser so what we'll do
we'll print this value in the browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5. so we can
print the value of this variable anytime
and anywhere in our program right so if
we try to copy this line from here and
we'll paste it somewhere else in a
program let's say we are pasting it here
so if we try to save it now see here you
can see that we have two values of a
because we have printed a twice here
right once we have used this a here then
we have used this a here so here you can
see we have two values of a five and
five so this variable a is a global
variable which means its life is
available throughout the entire program
or the entire script we can see and when
we declare a variable inside a function
that variable is known as a local
variable for that function so let's try
to do it as well we already know what
functions are as we saw in the previous
video right so what we'll do we'll make
a function here let's say we are
creating a function
function my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where X and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
what we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable X which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now the
same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a JavaScript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for Global
variables so Global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the programs
running
or we can say until the tab is open the
next exciting thing about global
variables is that we can access Global
variables from inside the function so
what we will do
let's
cut this line from here and we'll paste
it here so now what we will do we'll
declare a variable here let's say we are
declaring a variable where Y and the
value of y will be 15.
so copy this line
and paste it again now what we will do
we'll try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15. 10 is the
value of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared X inside the function whereas
variable Y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what Global variables are one more
exciting thing I want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in JavaScript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
where one okay we have not used any
where keyword so what we are doing is we
are declaring a variable and the value
of where 1 is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
value variable inside this function
without using the where keyboard so
let's try to access this variable let's
try to access let's declare it inside
the function okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and we'll comment this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
but we'll do is
we'll write here where one
save this
and see if we don't understand it let me
change the value of where one let's
change this value to 20 save it now and
see the output here is 10 and 20. so
where one is a variable which is
declared without using the where keyword
right so we can access this variable
from outside the function as well any
variable which is declared without using
where keyword is a global variable keep
this thing in mind guys we came across
the different types of data types
present in JavaScript in the previous
video where we came across the types of
primitive data types in JavaScript we
discussed number string and we had
Boolean null and undefined right so
these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
JavaScript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where X and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have high there as the
value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and will print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable X so I
hope you guys are aware of that if you
are not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
JavaScript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable X and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right I hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and here we'll use
type of x
so let's
save it and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable X so strings are
helpful for holding data that can be
represented in textual form so let's
move on to our first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in JavaScript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of HTML
tags in JavaScript right for example we
use the heading tag so often like when
we are using the document.write to print
anything on the browser we use heading
tag quite a lot right so the thing to
notice here is that these tags behaves
as HTML tags right we use them inside
the double inverted commas just like
strings but they still act like HTML
tags so let's understand this with the
help of an example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write and we'll write here hi
there and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic HTML tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the braid tag I
hope you all are aware of the brake tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we tried to
print a sentence and we are using the BR
tag right so let's print it on the
browser
so we are using the Break Tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to Simply code
so we use this Break Tag in a string
right so the output what we were
expecting was hi there and the BR should
be returning
string but there's a difference in the
output right the BR tag is actually
functioning as an HTML tag
so here the Break Tag works the same as
it did for HTML so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
HTML tag inside the JavaScript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of Escape characters present
in JavaScript
so let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we'll remove this brake tag and suppose
we want to print this on screen so we
want this on our screen and we want the
welcome to be inside the double inverted
comma in output as well so if we try to
run this program now there will be
nothing in the browser let's try to
check if it gets any error so here it
says uncut syntaxel it says missing
after the argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome so if
we try to run this program as it is it's
not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash Escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma the syntax is we
have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if you want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we'll print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted command now we will
write s
the output will be it's all right
so we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
JavaScript let's save this and see if we
try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it in similar way
without using the backslash Escape
character lastly if we want to put a
backslash in our string if we want to
put a backslash we want to show it in
the browser so the Syntax for that will
go like
we have the document dot right right so
here we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes is called
backslash
so let's try to print this so here one
thing you can note is only a single
backslash is printed on the browser the
first one is used as a backslash Escape
character and the second one which we
have used will be printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in JavaScript like the backslash
and or we can say new line we don't use
them quite often I'll let you know if we
use them in future so for now it's
enough for escape sequences present in
JavaScript let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars let's create a small list
here for a few different car companies
let's say we have a variable where
carbon
and the value of carbon will be let's
say
Honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say Car 2 and the value of Car 2
will be Kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3 and the value of car 3 will be
let's say food so here we have taken
three different car manufacturers we
have Honda we have Kia and we have food
and we have three different variables
right so if we want to print all three
of them what we have to do is we have to
use the document.write method right so
we have to use the document dot right
again and again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot right and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was Honda we have Honda here we
have Kia and we have Ford as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right that's where arrays come into play
what we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to Define an array here first
so the Syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
We'll declare a array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use Honda Kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as Honda the next one we
have is Kia
and the last one we have is
food right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have Honda we have Kia and we
have food so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of 100 car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
array so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here paste
it here and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes and now let's
save this program and see here you can
see we have all the three elements of
the array we have Honda we have Kia and
we have Ford as well
so an array is a non primitive data type
or composite data type with one single
name and can hold multiple values here
the array name is car and it stores
three similar values right here we have
three string values we have Honda Kia
and food so this array can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array so what if we want to print a
single value from these three values we
have we have Honda here and four right
so if we want to print Kia let's suppose
so it's easy to print this on a browser
all we need to know is the index number
of that value so the index number in the
case of arrays starts from 0 and goes
further so we have three values here as
we can see so the index value for these
variables will be so for Honda the index
value will be 0 and for key are the
index value will be 1 and for 4 then the
x value will be 2. so the index value
starts from 0 and goes on further so one
thing to keep in mind guys whatever
number of values and array is holding
the last index value will always be 1
less than the number of values so as
here you can see we have three values
right so the index number of the last
value will be 1 less than 3. it means
the index number will be 2 because the
index number starts from 0.
let's try to access the element present
at index 1. so we have Kia here right
all we have to do is we have to put
square brackets here in the document dot
right here we have to put square
brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of this square bracket so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have Kia only
it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
Kia
we can also Loop through this array
using the index values let's say we want
to print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here I hope you guys are aware of the
for Loop by now will right here so will
we have declared an array so we will use
the for Loop here and we will print here
for we'll take a variable I and the
value of I will be initial value will be
0 and then we'll give the condition the
condition will be I Less Than 3 because
we know there are three values only and
it will go till 2 only because it's
going for the index value and the final
condition will be I plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces because this is the
Syntax for for Loop and the I value will
iterate through the array and print all
the values present at indexes till the
index 2. so the same thing goes for 100
elements as well we can use the for Loop
to access all the hundred elements in
separate lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing Kia Kia and Kia because
we have particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here I
and if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the I
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for Loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array we can
use the same iteration concept for doing
so so guys there's another way to
represent an array in JavaScript it goes
like this we have a let's say we have a
variable this time we'll take the
variable as well fruits so the syntax
will be like new we have to use the new
keyword and then we will use new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay and we can access the elements of
these array with the help of a for Loop
we can use the similar for Loop here so
if we copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll keep the value as I
because we want to iterate the variable
I through each index so we have once
again the index value as 0 for apple one
for banana and two for mango let's
comment this program as well so that it
will be easy for you guys to understand
let's save this program now and see we
have the list of all the elements
present at array fruits so we have apple
we have banana and we have mango printed
on our browser so this way of array
representation or Declaration is less
recommended because the other way which
we discussed earlier like when we
discussed the car manufacturers so that
way is a bit easier to use so I'll
recommend that way only because this way
is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys arrays in
JavaScript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like Java and C plus plus so arrays in
JavaScript have Dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime just like we saw the
string Methods in the previous video for
arrays also we have a few methods like
if we want to add elements into an array
or if we want to delete an element from
an array we have the push and pop
methods available to do such tasks to
add an element into an array we use the
push method and the Syntax for pushing
elements into an array goes like so
we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array right we'll
write here the variable name dot we use
the push method and we'll push whatever
value we want to push let's say we are
adding another car manufacturer let's
say we are adding Nissan we have to
change the value here as well because
what will happen we have used the
condition I Less Than 3 so it will check
for indexes still index 2 only it won't
check for index 3. so if we write here I
less than 4 it will check for Nissan now
let's save this and see a new value is
pushed into the array which is Nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in Array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove Nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the pop option now if we use
car.pop and let's run this program and
see it says undefined this is happening
because as you can see we have pushed
the value Nissan into array so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular element now
if we pop out that particular element so
if we try to use cars.op once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element fold as well so let's try to
push one more value in this particular
scenario let's say we are pushing a
value as
Hyundai
and now let's run this so you can see
here it has inserted Hyundai in place of
food because we have used the pop method
to put Ford out of our array
so I hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
arrays in JavaScript which are already
predefined to do some specific tasks
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in JavaScript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length properties used to find
the length of the array so if we use it
in the for Loop in place of this I less
than 4 so
here you can see we have used I less
than 4. now if we write here array dot
length so if we write here car
dot length so now we don't have to
change this value again and again so if
we are inserting any value or if we are
removing any value from this for Loop so
if we are removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is let's
say we have the length here 3 right so
it will check for the length and it will
be 1 less than the length of the array
so if we run this program now it will
work fine I hope you guys understood the
concept of array methods present in
JavaScript the other main difference
array has in JavaScript which makes it
different from C plus plus or Java is we
can add elements with other data types
in JavaScript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we'll push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push a
numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20.
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car so we can use any data type
inside the array in JavaScript so let's
take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be Audi a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from order is Q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car and the price
will be
let's say 50 000 US Dollars all right
next up we have a function let's say we
are using a function that is all wheel
drive
so we are having a function all-wheel
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all-wheel drive function we are using
document.write and here what we will
write
we'll write let's suppose
this car comes with
Quattro all-wheel drive Quattro I hope
you guys are aware of this word Quattro
it means that four wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here's the data about a particular
car from a particular brand Audi right
so the car model is Q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 US dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of General front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive so this
function is the behavior of the car
right it shows that the car is four
wheel drive things are pretty sorted
here right we have the data about the
car and a function associated with it so
let's save this and we can see the
output here the car comes with Quattro
all-wheel drive so this is a basic piece
of code right we have been through
functions we know how to use functions
we know how to call them so that's quite
easy for now right the problem occurs
when we have a list of cars let's say
that we have to maintain 100 different
cars with all the data of car
manufacturer we have car model price and
then we have different behaviors for
different cars not all cars have the
all-wheel drive property so what we will
do in such a case where we have to use
the same property again and again for
100 different cars or 100 different
entities we can copy paste this same
piece of code repeatedly and we have to
change the value every time we copy
paste it so we have to change the
variable name the car manufacturer the
car model and the price as well imagine
we are doing this for a list of cars
then it goes on and on so this is the
most inefficient way of tackling this
problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play these objects help us to
bundle all these properties and
attributes about one particular entity
if we talk about this particular example
of a car we can put all these properties
and many other properties like car
weight we have car color and so on
together under one name and make it an
object
let's move on to the Syntax for objects
in JavaScript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use objects now let's go
ahead and have a look at the Syntax for
objects so before we start there are few
ways in which we can create objects in
JavaScript we are going to discuss two
different ways of doing so the first one
is the literal way also known as the
literal object way
so the Syntax for literal object way
goes like this let's say we are
declaring a variable where car and curly
braces so these curly braces represent
that this car variable is actually an
object inside this
we will Define all the car's properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's use them here so we
have
car manufacturer and the car
manufacturer is
Audi
right
next up we have car model
car model is
Q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000
dollars
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all-wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the Syntax for
that will be we have to write here all
wheel drive
and we'll use the column then it is a
function so we will write here function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here so we want this
function to return this value so we'll
write here return instead of
document dot right now this function
will return this string that this cars
comes with a Quattro all-wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
use this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this so this is
what an object looks like our object is
entirely ready what we did here is we
bundled all these things and coupled
them we bundled all these things we
bundled all the three variables we
bundle this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model Etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to use document.write
so it is quite simple so after this
object we'll write here document
dot right
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the object name
with the dot operator and the property
name so if we want to Let's suppose
we'll use here car dot and property name
will be car underscore manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite easy you can see here we have used
the car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says OD
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if you want to access this
all-wheel drive function we can do it
simply by writing here car dot and we'll
write here instead of this we'll write a
all-wheel drive and we are good to go so
if we save this now so here you can see
it says this car comes with four wheel
drive so it is quite easy to access
these properties of an object so we can
do it by using this now suppose we call
this function normally with the document
dot right inside the function in place
of return so if we write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write a document dot
right inside this function and we can
call this function by the normal method
like if you are calling this function
from outside what we will do we'll write
here car dot and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't used any H1
tag or h2 tag so you can spot the
difference right so that's how you can
call a method of an object from outside
this is the normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture in which we use something
different known as object Constructor
that's a bit different from other object
oriented programming languages so don't
worry if you don't know about it also in
the newer versions JavaScript supports
the concept of classes and object so
what we used to say earlier is
Javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed JavaScript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference so
we'll comment this that's why we are not
removing it but we can remove this piece
of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object now we will create multiple
objects using a single template which is
known as a Constructor function let's
have a look at the Syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only now
inside a function these parameters are
known as arguments so if we talk about
the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically so
what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
Constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values so all these values will
be present at the rhs so let me write
this first let's say we are using this
Dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will right here car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and Method as well so let's
use the other two properties which were
this Dot car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this Dot price
right here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the Constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this we'll use this
dot all-wheel drive
and this is a function so we'll write
here function with the opening and
closing round brackets and then we have
the body of the function inside the body
of this function we will write whatever
we have written in the previous program
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it here
right so this is a complete Constructor
function Now using this Constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this Constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
C plus plus and Java so let's create an
object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable C1 now
we'll use the new keyword and along with
the
Constructor function so we'll use your
cards and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have the car manufacturer is Audi and
next up we have the
model as
Q7 and the prices
50 000. okay so we have created a
variable we have passed the values for
the properties and now if you want to
access this function if you want to
access this all-wheel drive function we
can access this as well we have to write
here C1 dot all wheel drives and this is
how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here H2 Tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where C2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cars and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
BMW
and next up we have the model as
X7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 USD so if we want to
access any particular property of any
object like if we want to access the car
model or if we want to access the car
manufacturer so we can do it the same
way as we did previously as we did in
the literal object way so
to do so we have to write a
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name Dot and
whatever we want to print let's say we
are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here X7 is
printed on the browser because X7 is the
value of object C2 and let's suppose if
we want to
Frontier car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have BMW as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000 so this
is how we can create multiple objects in
JavaScript we'll continue with the
previous program we made so today we
will use the literal object way because
this method of creating objects is a bit
easier than the other one we discussed
which was the Constructor function
method so here we created the car object
which has three properties car
manufacturer car model and the price of
the car we have a method here as
all-wheel drive when we use this method
here we use this method with the dot
operator and we called that function we
called that method with the help of the
object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video if we talk
about objects in JavaScript a lot of
things we know about in JavaScript are
basically objects like the Boolean
values numbers strings and a few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we Define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we Define
them with the new keyword so we have a
few predefined objects as well we have
the math object the date object and the
regular expression are also considered
objects in JavaScript a lot of things
are objects in JavaScript we'll use
objects in Dom manipulation which we
will go through in further videos so
that's why it is pretty essential to
understand the whole concept of objects
right so next next up let's look at how
we can use different data types as
objects in JavaScript
so the Syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in JavaScript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so Stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in JavaScript I
feel right here str1 and we'll use the
dot operator so here we can see we have
the object methods as well right so I
hope you guys are aware of the methods
present in JavaScript like we had the
string and array methods right we have
methods for object as well like the
index of method we have seen the use of
index of method when we went through the
string Methods in JavaScript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in JavaScript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type so the easiest way to do so is to
use the type of operator so let's use it
here and check the type of variable str1
we'll write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the H1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we write here any
string let's suppose we are using a
string here let's say we are using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a Stringer layer but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string and this is the basic syntax
of how to define the primitive data type
as an object so if we save it now here
you can see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and the other
predefined objects we talked about like
the date object and the math object will
go through each of them in separate
videos so moving on let's go back to our
car object after we declared the whole
object we defined all the three
properties and the method also somewhere
in the program we realized that we had
missed a particular property and we
realized it after we have written 150
lines of code after this car object so
here you can say we have written here
150 line of code so
I'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in JavaScript we can add a particular
property to an object outside the
definition also we can add a property to
an object anywhere in a program the
Syntax for that goes like this will
write the object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say black right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we'll write here
document dot right
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on our browser so we have used a
car dot car color let's save this
program now and see here you can see the
output is black so this is the property
of the object car now and if we comment
this line let's say if we are commenting
this line let's save this now and see
here you can see it says undefined we
can add more properties similarly like
if we want to add another property here
we can go like car dot and the property
name whatever property we want to add
let's say we want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll see it will go like
car dot let's say we are adding a new
function
let's say we are adding the function new
fun equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
edit
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so I hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object so it's pretty easy to
do so in JavaScript we can use the
delete keyword object name and the
property name after the dot operator
let's suppose we want to delete car
model here we want to delete this
particular property of the object car so
we what we'll do we'll delete this car
model so the Syntax for it is quite
simple so we'll remove this for now and
we'll delete a property let's say we are
using the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here car
model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so we'll write here
car dot current underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is Q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know JavaScript is a Loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write so we
have to write here car dot
price
and update the value here let's say we
are using 70 000 and we have to put a
semicolon it's the same thing we do to
update the value of a particular
variable right so if we try to print the
value of price now we'll get the output
as seventy thousand let's try to print
it on the browser so we'll cut it from
here we'll paste it here and we'll print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property what we can do is we can use
the type of operator so we'll use the
type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string earlier it
was a number but now it is a string so
all these things can be done dynamically
in a program wherever we want to do them
so that's the benefit of having objects
in JavaScript today we are going to take
input from the user with the help of a
text box in JavaScript what we'll do is
we'll create a text box and any value
the user will write inside the text box
will be stored in a variable and then we
will print that variable in a message
using the alert method or in the control
so whatever we want to do we can do it
so let's create a small login page with
no styling because we'll be focusing
more on the HTML and the JavaScript
parts so for that we have to go to our
HTML file so here's our HTML file and
we'll write here
input
and then we'll write a type is equals to
name and then we'll write here
placeholder is equals to let's say enter
name
this placeholder is an attribute that
gives a slight hint whatever value we
write here will be printed inside the
box so this enter name will be printed
inside this particular text box
so save it and here you can see on the
browser we have a text box here here you
can see how this value is written inside
the text box you can see here enter name
is written inside a text box indicating
the user to write the name here so let's
create another textbook here for the
password so we are creating a login page
right so we'll be needing name and
password so we'll use the BR tag here
and then we'll write here
input type is equals to
password
and then we'll
use a placeholder here and we'll write
here
enter
password this type attribute here plays
a vital role on this input element
because we have different types of
values we can use inside a text box like
we have numbers strings week time email
password and many more
so here we are using password
so save it and you can see here we have
two text boxes over here in the browser
so we have a text box for name and we
have a text box for password
next up we need a button to perform a
task right so we'll use the on click
method along with this button we can
either use the button tag or we can use
the input tag along with type is equals
to button so we'll write here input
type is equals to button and the value
will be
say submit
or we can write here login essay save it
and here you can see we have a button
over here named as submit so we are done
with the login setup here we have a text
box for the name and one for the
password so we'll write any name here
you can see let's write here question
and then we'll write the password here
let's say any random password and
nothing will happen if we click on the
submit button so let's add some
functionality to this submit button here
so we'll go back to HTML file and we'll
write here
on click we will write here a function
name
print fine
we'll create this print function now so
we'll go to our JavaScript file and
we'll create a function here so let's
say function name is print and then we
have the body of the function now this
function will be called whenever we
click on this button so whenever we
click on the submit button this print
function will be called now we want this
button to do something right we want it
to perform a certain task what we want
to do is we want the user to write their
name and password and we will print this
name and password in the pop-up with the
help of alert method so we'll use the
document.getelement by ID method for
this task let's give those elements
their IDs so we'll give these two input
tags their IDs so we'll write here
ID is equals to let's say you name or
username and then we have the password
for password we'll give the ID as you
pass fine save it and then we'll go back
to our JavaScript file now both these
elements have their own IDs we'll use
them in the Javascript file so we want
to use the values given by the user
right for that we'll create two
variables here inside the function print
to hold the reference of original value
so for that we'll write here where X is
equals to
document dot get element by ID and then
we have the IDS you name for the
username and then we'll write here Dot
when next up we'll take another variable
let's say where Y and then we'll write
here
document dot get Elements by ID again
then we have the IDS
you pass
we'll write here dot value now what we
did here is we use the IDS to get the
reference of those values which the user
will input you might have noticed here
that we have used the value property
here after the IDS so this value
property Returns the value attribute of
any text box
so now we have the values here present
inside variables X and variable y the
next thing we want to do is we want to
print these values right so for that
we'll use the alert method so it's quite
easy to use we'll write here alert and
then we'll write here
the name is and then we'll print
X so because variable X is holding the
value of name then we'll
use slash n and after that we'll write
here
the password is and then we'll print the
value of Awesome
so we are done with it we have printed
the values of X and Y here now save it
and now we'll enter the values here
let's say the name is
caution and the password is
Simply Good
the moment we click on this submit
button there will be a pop-up with a
message you can see it here the name is
kaushal and the password is simply code
we printed these variables here along
with the alert method
so this is how we can take input from
the user in JavaScript so we already
discussed that we want to create a login
form here with a specific name or
password right let's say we want the
user to be allowed only if the password
is simply cool otherwise the user should
be restricted from entering the web page
so this is a simple task all we have to
do here is we have to use the if else
control statements so for that we'll
write here after this statement we'll
write here if and then we'll write here
let's say pass we are doing it for
password right so we'll write a y is
equal to is equals to
simply code then we have the body of if
we'll write here alert
login successfully
and then we'll write here else this the
statement will be alert
wrong password
so we'll keep this line here so what
will happen is the moment we'll press
the submit button it will go to the FL
statement and it will check if the
password entered by the user matches the
correct password or not so if the
password matches it will print login
successful otherwise it will print the
wrong password and then finally it will
print the name entered by the user and
the password as well so let's save it
and we'll write here the name as let's
say caution
and the password let's say the password
will be different this time we'll write
here simply learn
so this password does not matches the
original password right the original
password is simply code so what we are
expecting is it will return wrong
password here so let's save it the
moment we press the submit button you
can see here we have a pop-up with
message wrong password because the
password we entered is simply learn so
if we press OK here in the next message
you can see the name is kaushal and the
password is simply learn fine so let's
do it again this time we'll enter the
correct password we'll write here simply
code
and we'll change the name as well so
let's say the name is
Rahul
submit it and here you can see we have
the message as login successful
we'll press OK and here you can see the
name is Rahul and the password is simply
code in this tutorial we will see how we
can use radio buttons to take input from
users now HTML radio buttons are created
with the help of input text and the type
for creating radio buttons is Radio we
can use radio buttons on multiple
occasions for example we can create a
quiz question using a radio button at
one time only a single radio button will
be selected and we can use it to find
the correct answer so today we will use
radio buttons along with the ID
attribute and then we will create a
JavaScript function to find the correct
answer for a quiz so without wasting any
time let's move on to the programming
part
so first we will see how to add radio
buttons to our HTML document
in the HTML file we will write here
input
type is equals to radio
and then we have
value is equals to let's say option one
because we are using multiple options
right we have multiple options for a
single question or we have multiple
options here so we'll write value as
option one and then we'll write here the
value we want to print so we'll write
your option
one
fine save it and we have a radio button
over here you can see we can check it
and it has no functionality till now
so let's add another button first so
what we'll do we'll copy this line from
here and
we'll paste it and then we'll change the
option as option 2 and the value also as
option 2.
right save it again and here you can see
we have two radio buttons now let's add
a submit button here first so we'll
right here
input type is equals to
button and then we have value is equal
to submit save it and here you can see
we have a submit Button as well one
thing you might notice here is we can
check both the text boxes right we can
check option one and option 2 both at
the same time so if we want to select
only one checkbox at a time we have to
group them so we'll use the name
attribute and the same name for these
two radio buttons so the name will
remain the same for both of these radio
buttons so we'll write a name is equals
to let's say
G1 and then we'll write here as well
we'll write here name is equals to G1
now these two radio buttons belong to
the same group
save it and now if you try to check both
these boxes you can see we can't do it
now because we have grouped them and now
we can select only one radio button at a
time right
now the next thing we are going to do is
we'll move to a JavaScript file and
we'll create a function there so we'll
move to a Javascript file so here's our
Javascript file and we'll create a
function here so let's do it first so
we'll write here
function
let's say the function name is
fun one fine and then we have the body
of this function so inside this function
we'll write here we'll take two
variables again for both elements so
we'll write here where X and then we'll
write a document Dot
get element by ID then we'll write here
the ID
so let's provide the ID to those
elements as well so we'll write here
before name will provide the ID so let's
say the ID for the first radio button is
red one and the ID for the second one
will be
let's say Red Two Fine save
and we'll go back to our Javascript file
we'll write here red one
and then we'll take another variable
we'll write here where Y is equals to
document dot get element by ID method
and then we'll write here the ID so the
ID for the second radio button is
red 2. fine we don't need the value
property here next up we have to use the
if else statement to print something
right so we'll write here we'll use the
if else statement we'll write a if
and then we have
x dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return something right so
we have a condition here as if x dot
checked is equal to is equals to true
this particular statement will check if
the radio button whose reference is
available at variable X is selected or
not this dot checked is the property for
a HTML element if the radio button is
checked the output will be something so
let's add the output here as well so the
output will be if the radio button is
checked
will be like we'll write a alert then
we'll write here the
option
selected
is
then we will write here
x dot
value so it will print the value of x as
well
now we have another condition here
we'll write here if white or checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return the options
selected is we'll write here plus y dot
value we are doing this because we have
three different conditions here right if
we select option one or if we select
option two or if we are not selecting
any of these options right so we have a
else condition for that and then we'll
write here else so here we have to write
else if
and then we'll write here else
and else part will print
alert no option
selected save it and let's do one thing
first we'll call this function with the
help of on click method so we'll go back
to HTML file and we'll write here in
this element we'll write here on click
and we'll call this function on click
so we'll write your fun one and we have
this function here save it and here we
are good to go
so if we move back to our JavaScript
file you can see here we have three
conditions either X is checked or Y is
checked or none of these are checked so
let's
check the output now we'll select Option
1 first we'll submit it and here you can
see we have the output as the option
selected is option one fine
press ok then we'll refresh this page
and we'll select option 2 and now we'll
press the submit button so here you can
see on selecting option two we have the
output here as the option selected is
option two right so what if we are not
selecting any of these two radio buttons
so
click the submit button here and you can
see we have the output as no option
selected so I hope you guys got it now
the syntax will remain the same if we
want to create a quiz so next up what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a quiz
so here is the code if you want to
create a quiz on your own so we have a
question here we have a question as
JavaScript was developed in the year and
then we have two options for it we have
1998 as first option so if we go here
you can see we have the first option is
1998 and then we have another option is
1995. obviously we know the answer for
it as 1995 will change the function name
here as
fun one and save it the Javascript file
for this code will look like this so we
have three conditions here again if x is
checked then the output will be wrong
answer and the correct answer is y and
then we have another condition for y if
Y is checked or we can say if 1995 is
checked we'll have the output as right
answer and then we have another
condition if none of these radio buttons
are checked we have the output as no
option selected so let's see if the code
works fine so save it and we'll go to
the browser so we'll select option one
first so we'll select this 1998 submit
it and here you can see we have the
output as wrong answer the correct
answer is 1995 right we have the value
of y here the value variable Y is
holding is 1995 so we printed it over
here and we have the output as y dot
value which is 1990
so if we refresh it and if we select
1995 here then we'll press the submit
button and here you can see we have the
output as right answer fine press OK and
we are going to do it again so this time
we won't be selecting any of these
options we'll just click on the submit
button and we have the output as no
option selected fine I hope you guys
understood it in the last few videos we
discussed the same thing right we saw
how we could take input using text boxes
and then we saw how we can take input
using radio buttons today we are going
to grab users input with the help of a
select box in JavaScript so without
wasting any time let's move on to the
programming part directly first we'll
see how to create a select box in HTML
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part so let's move on to HTML and we'll
create a select box here if you guys
remember we use the input tag in the
previous few videos for text boxes and
radio buttons but for the select box the
scenario is a bit different we have to
use the select element in HTML so we'll
write here
select
so we have the select element here we
have to use this for select box in
JavaScript or in HTML so this select box
is used to create drop down list of some
elements so we can add as many elements
as we want to that list so we'll use the
option tag for each component we are
going to use
so the code goes like this will
start with the select tag and let's save
this and see if it makes any changes to
a browser so you can see it on the
browser that we have a button over here
now we'll add options to this drop down
list for that we'll use the option tag
we'll write here option
and let's say we have three options we
have three car manufacturers name so
let's say the first name is BMW then
we'll copy this
statement and
we'll paste it again and again and then
we'll change the name of Manufacturers
so let's say another manufacturer is
Audi and the last one is
food fine we have three manufacturers
now save it and you can see it over here
we have a drop down list of three
different elements we have BMW or dn4
here next up we'll add a button so a
submit Button as we did in the previous
few videos for that we will write here
input type is equals to button and then
we have value
is equals to
submit fine
save it and we'll use a br tag here
save it now and here you can see we have
a drop down list here we have a select
box here and then we have a submit
button over here
fine now we want to print the option we
selected by clicking this submit button
for that we have to add functionality to
our HTML document right so we'll follow
the same steps as we did in the last
video wherein we used the radio buttons
and the text boxes so we'll write here
inside this input tag we'll write here
on click so what we want to do is we
want to call a function on clicking a
submit button right so we will write
here a function name so let's say the
function name is
selected
and we have to use the ID attribute in
the select element right so we'll use
the ID attribute here we are not going
to use our ID attribute inside the
option text but we are going to use the
ID attribute inside the select text so
we'll write here ID
is equals to let's say
1. fine
so we have an ID here now we have to use
the value property here as well so I
hope you guys remember the value
property which we discussed in previous
videos so the value property is used to
access these values right so we'll write
here
value is equals to
BMW and then for Audi the value will be
OD and then for Ford the value will be
food fine save it and here we are done
with the HTML document so next up we'll
create a function in the Javascript file
so let's move on to the Javascript file
and we'll create a function over here
so we'll write here
function and the function name is
selected
then we have the body of this function
right so we are going to repeat the same
steps we are going to take a variable X
which will hold the reference of Select
statement so we'll write here document
Dot
get element by ID and then we'll write
here the ID so the ID is one
so now we have a variable X which holds
the reference value of Select element
right
now we have used the document.getelement
by ID method to get the reference of the
selected value next up we'll use some
properties for select element while
printing the value with alert method so
if you guys remember in the previous
video wherein we use the dot checked
property for radio buttons so similarly
we have some more properties here for
the select boxes as well so let's have a
look at them
so we'll write here
alert
and then we have a property which will
go like this we'll write here x dot
options
and then we have
this brackets and Dot value
so this options property here is a
collection of all the options we have in
a select tag
we have multiple options right this
property works on arrays so we have an
array of all the elements and we can
access any of them for that we will
write here the index value right so
let's say the index value is 0 we want
to print the element present at number
one so we'll save it and the moment we
press submit button you can see here we
have the output as BMW now one thing to
notice here is
it doesn't matter which option the user
chooses the output will remain BMW for
all those cases because we are using the
first element of the array so no matter
which option the user is selecting the
message will be there with the value
present at index 0.
so we can say now that we can't use
static values right we can't use 0 1 or
2 here because we want
to provide the value dynamically because
we have three different values here and
we want to print the value which the
user selected not the one present at
index is 0 1 or 2. so for that we have
another property here we have to write a
x dot
select
did index
and one thing you have to remember is we
have to write here x dot selected index
or any variable we are using here so we
are good to go now save it and if we
press submit now while
clicking on BMW so our first option is
BMW let's press the submit button and
here you can see we have the output as
BMW
and next up we'll be selecting OD and
we'll press submit so here you can see
we have the output as Audi now
and finally we have forward as well so
let's check it as well so press the
submit button and here you can see we
have the output is food
so this is how we can take inputs in
JavaScript from drop down lists next up
we'll go through a simple program as we
did in the last video wherein we'll
Create a quiz question and we'll check
if the option selected by the user is
correct or not so this is the code for
that so we have the question here is
Javascript was developed by we are using
another question different from the one
we used in the last video so we know who
developed JavaScript right so we have a
question here JavaScript was developed
by and then we have two options for the
same question the first one is Brendan
Ike and the second one is guidoven
Rossum
so then we have the ideas one for the
select element and the values are also
the same then we have a button over here
which will call function one on clicking
and if we move to a Javascript file we
can see here we have a function fun one
and then we have a variable X which
holds the reference of value
returned by
document.getelement by ID method and
then we use this value so we have used a
x dot option so what we are doing is we
are basically checking that if the
selected value is equals to Brendan Ike
or not if the value is equal to Brandon
I then the output will be the answer is
correct else the output will be the
answer is wrong
so let's save it and we'll move back to
HTML file and we'll save this file as
well so now here you can see we have a
question over here and we have a select
box which has two options Brendan I can
guide you in Rossum right so let's
select Brendan Ike first press the
submit button and here you can see it
says the answer is correct fine next up
we are going to use gaido and Rossum and
we are going to press submit button so
here you can see the answer is wrong
we have been using the
document.getelement by ID method for the
past few videos right we know it is used
to access an HTML element with the help
of an ID which is uniquely provided to
each element
so we used that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then with
select boxes as well so today we are
going to use a method that is somewhat
similar to document.getelement by ID
method so we'll be using the
document.getelements by tag name method
in JavaScript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same type so we have tag name
in our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
tags style we can do it with the help of
this method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between ID and tag name method so let's
move on to the programming part directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use CSS for that but in JavaScript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are writing it
this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the JavaScript
part
so we'll write here let's use the BR tag
and we'll write here input tag again
we'll write a input type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say our function name is
fun to
and then we have the
value of this button is let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button so next up what we are
going to do is we are going to add
functionality to this submit button for
that we have to move to our Javascript
file and we have to create a function
over there
so we'll write here
in the Javascript file we'll write here
function
and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do here is we'll take a variable X
and then we'll write here document Dot
get Elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so in
this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in our HTML document we can
access paragraph tags we can access
anchor text and any tag we want to
basically
so save it and here now we have a
variable X that holds an HTML collection
of all the div text present inside the
HTML file this means that we have an
array of references of all the div tags
here inside this variable X
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
Index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one or this particular
syntax will access the
first div tag of HTML document because
we know arrays start from 0. and at 0
the first element will be present so
this div tag will be present at number
0. and then we are going to use the
style property so we know that X here is
not a variable only actually X here acts
as an object and we know that different
objects have certain properties in
JavaScript so style is one of those
properties and next up we'll write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the CSS part with properties
present in JavaScript so let's say we
are changing our font to
Courier new
fine so this is a font name and we can
use any font name over here so save it
what will happen now is on clicking the
submit button the font of this
particular section the font of div 1
will change to Korean so let's try if
it's happening or not on clicking the
submit button you can see over here the
change between this line and other three
div tags clearly the font has changed
the new font is Courier new and what we
did here is we changed the font family
of this particular div tag so similarly
we can make more styling changes to
other div tags as well so let's do it
here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a HTML file so let's say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and the index number will
be 2. so then again we'll use the style
property and then let's say we are
writing here
font style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for x
for the uh repeats so let's say for the
last div tag we are using the background
color
fine and we'll write here the color name
is
red so we are good to go now save it and
we have four different properties over
here for section four we are changing
the
background color so three will be the
index number of the last array variable
so save it and on pressing the submit
button you can see the change over here
so for section one the font is changed
to Courier new for section two the font
color is blue let me Zoom it out a bit
to show you guys you can see over here
the color is blue and then we have
italic text in section three and finally
for section 4 we have the background
color as four right so you can see how
we are accessing any particular element
of the array now why we are using these
properties separately for each array
element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in JavaScript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable X is holding an array of all
the div text present in a HTML file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
Elements by tag name method to overcome
this problem we have a solution as well
so the solution for this problem is we
have to use the for Loop View so how
this for Loop works so we'll write here
and then we'll take a local variable I
and the initial value will be 0. then
we'll write a i
less than x dot length because we want
to Traverse the whole array right and
then we'll write here the condition I
plus plus
so we are going to go then we have this
body of for Loop and inside here we'll
write X and the index number will be I
because it will keep on changing and we
are in a loop so we'll write here dot
style and then let's say the style we
want to do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font Boulder fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me Zoom this and if we
click on this submit button you can see
the font is more bold right so if we are
using another property here let's say
the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div tags for all the
four section is changed to Yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once now what we
did is we started a loop and traversed
every element in the array and applied
the same property to each element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of tag name method in JavaScript
now what if we have hundreds of similar
elements like div tag present in our
website and all of them are present at
different locations so let's try to do
it and what we'll do is we'll insert
certain different elements in between
these div tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags so here you can see we
have inserted two three more elements in
between these div tags so save it and
you can see after each section we have
something else here we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and age and then we have a submit Button
as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two then after
section two we have radio button and the
value is a then we have another radio
button B and in between we have all the
dev text present so basically what we
want to do is we want to change the
style for each of the div tags right so
we will change the background color here
so let's say we'll write here red and
what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section one
two three and four will change to red so
let's try to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as red so this is
working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of ID attribute for each element so we
are saying this for a long time that the
ID for each element should be unique
wise although we saw in the past videos
that we can use the same ID for two
different elements when we did the same
for accessing a CSS styling property
using the ID attribute but if we try to
do the same thing with JavaScript we'll
get an error for example if we try to
access the value of any particular
element with the ID attribute but we
have two elements in a HTML file with
the same ID so it will throw an error in
that case basically and this is the
reason why we use the tag name method in
JavaScript so that if we want to access
multiple elements of the same name we
can do it with this method because it's
not possible to use the ID method
separately for each element present in
the HTML document right because we have
certain same HTML tags present within an
HTML document like we have the div tags
here similarly a website is long enough
to have multiple similar elements
present within it so that's why we use
the document.getelements by tag name
method in JavaScript so guys in the past
few videos we use two different methods
of accessing an element from an HTML
file using JavaScript properties so we
know the difference between the ID
method and the tag name method right
today we will use another method to
access a particular element in
JavaScript that is the class name method
or we can say the get Elements by class
name method in JavaScript so before
discussing the class name method in
JavaScript let's look at why accessing
an element is important in JavaScript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change add or delete
HTML elements we saw earlier that we
could change HTML elements or the CSS
style of any element in the document
with the help of JavaScript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the ID method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in JavaScript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the ID attribute used in HTML we
know that ID has to be unique for each
element but we know that many elements
in an HTML document can have the same
class right so we used Class to access
specific CSS properties in the previous
videos and that is the only benefit of
using classes in JavaScript so we can
say that a single class can be used by
many elements within an HTML document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so will write here in the
HTML file will add five different
elements so let's say we are writing
here
diff and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one we'll copy this
we will paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
P tag we'll write this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four in
five so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph tags in
between the div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in a HTML
document three of them are the div text
section one two and five are div text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph text so now let's suppose we
want to change the style of three of
these elements let's say one four and
five so we can do it in two ways right
either we can use the ID method or we
can use the class method however we can
use the tag name method as well but we
have to use two different variables for
that right that will be a lengthy
process why two different variables
because we have two different tags
present here right we have to create
separate variable for the div tag and
separate one for the paragraph tag so
that will be a lengthy process so we'll
consider ID method and the class name
method for here so considering the ID
method the document.getelement by ID
method we have to provide unique ID to
each element so we have to provide
unique ID to this div tag then we have
to provide to each and every element
here right so because we need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the ID to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an HTML file so we'll use
the class attribute in each element we
want to access
so let's say we want to access section
one two and five so we'll write a class
let's say the class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing 1 2 and 4 because 1 2 and 5
are the div text so we can access these
with the help of tag name method as well
so we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here next up we'll create a button and
then we'll add functionality to a HTML
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it and here you can see in the
browser we have five sections over here
we have section one two three four and
five then we have a submit button which
will call the function on clicking so we
haven't added functionality till now so
let's move ahead to our Javascript file
and we'll add functionality to a
HTML document
so inside this JavaScript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
funkmon then we have the body of this
function so the syntax remains a bit
same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
HTML file
so we'll write here
where X is equals to
document Dot
get Elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
X in the form of an HTML collection so
now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section one that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0. then we'll write Dot
tile
and this style is a property dot then
let's say we want
to change the font style so we'll write
here
font style
font style will be
italic save it so this piece of code
will change the font style of the
element present at index 0. save it and
on clicking the submit button here on
the browser we can see the change in
this section right so if it's not
visible so let me Zoom it a bit for you
here you can see guys the font at
Section 1 is changed to italic right so
in this case we have all the three
elements present in a array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index one now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it 2 and we'll write here 1.
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we will change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bold
so we'll write here Boulder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the font readers Bolder so you can see
the change over here so this is how we
can make change to each element
separately and we can also make changes
in all the elements at once as well so
for that we have to use the for Loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right so for that we'll write here so
let's come in these three statements
first
and then we'll write here
four and
we'll take a local variable here we'll
write you where I is equals to 0 I will
start from index 0 and I will go till
x dot length
and then we have the condition as I plus
plus
so inside the body of for Loop we'll
write here X and
instead of index number we'll write here
I because we want to Traverse the whole
array then we'll write Here style Dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for Loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on a browser the
background color for all the three
sections that is one two and four is
changed to Yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelements by class name
method to access all the elements
present in an HTML file with a
particular class next up let's discuss
the difference between the ID method tag
name method and the class name method so
we'll discuss when to use which method
so let's start with the ID method so the
ID method is used when we want to access
a single element and we have to provide
a unique ID to that element in order to
access it so the ID method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods we can either use the class name
method or the tag name method for more
than one element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name we can access all
the similar tags present within an HTML
document with the help of tag name
method the only problem is we can access
similar types of tags only at one time
we can't access two different types of
tags with this method so this is where
the class name method comes into play we
can access more than one element with
this method and the elements can be
different just like we did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so the
section 1 2 and 5 are from div tags and
the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
JavaScript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the HTML file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so by now I hope you guys
understood the concept of all the three
methods which we have discussed the ID
method the tag name method and the class
name method in JavaScript we can use any
of these methods according to our needs
so guys we have been discussing specific
methods of accessing an element for the
past few videos now today we are going
to discuss something different before
going deep into this topic let's recall
events in JavaScript so the simple
definition of an event states that
something that happens so when we
manipulate an HTML document in
JavaScript we try to do something on the
web page right so several events take
place on a website like the user hovers
over a specific element or clicks on an
element or pressing a key in the website
can also refer to events or we can say
submitting a form or playing a video
also refers to the same thing so we are
using the on click event for the past
few videos wherein we discuss that a
specific task would be performed on
clicking a particular button what we did
was we were just calling a function by
clicking a button in HTML so clicking a
button is also an event right and the
function that will be called upon
clicking the button is known as event
handler because that function is
basically asking the computer to perform
a particular task on clicking the button
so like the on click event we have some
more exciting events present in HTML
which helps us make a web page more
interactive and responsive as well so we
can do it with the help of JavaScript so
we'll go through two such events today
the on Mouse over event and the on Mouse
out event so the on Mouse over event
will perform a task when the user takes
the mouse cursor on that element
similarly the on Mouse out event also
performs a task when the user takes the
mouse cursor away from that element so
for example let's suppose we have an
image present in our web page and we
want to change the size of that image
when the user takes the mouse cursor
over that image and the image should get
back to its previous size when the user
takes away the crystal so what's
basically happening is when the user is
taking its Mouse over the image or
picture the picture size will increase
and on taking the mouse cursor away from
the image the size will get back to its
default size so let's do it once and
we'll see how these events work within
an HTML document so first of all let's
add an image to the HTML file we'll use
the IMG tag for that and we'll have to
provide the path for the image right so
we'll write here
in a HTML file will add an image here so
we'll write here IMG and then we have to
provide the source and the images are
stored inside the images folder in this
system so we'll write here the image
name so we have provided the path here
next up what we'll do is we'll use the
alt attribute so we'll write here in the
alt we'll write a simply code
fine
save it
and here you can see we have an image
over a browser but the image size is
quite large right so we'll limit the
size of this image using the width
property so what we'll do is we'll write
here width
and let's say the width of the image
will be 250 pixel
save it and now you can see we have an
image over here the image is in its
normal size so this is the image so we
have this image over here and next thing
what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the size of this picture on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
so what will happen is when we take our
mouse cursor here the picture size will
increase so for that we have to use the
on Mouse over property or we can see the
on Mouse over event so what we'll do is
we'll write here on Mouse
over and we'll call a function on taking
the mouse cursor over this image so
we'll write here change size
so we'll declare it in a JavaScript file
and we'll call this function on taking
the mouse cursor over this picture
so next thing we are going to do is
we are going to move to our JavaScript
file and we'll Define this change size
function there
so let's
go to the JavaScript part we'll go to a
JS file and we'll write here we'll
declare a function first so we'll write
a function change size
and then we have the body of this
function so we can do it without taking
any variable like in the previous videos
we were taking a variable to store the
reference of the ID attribute so this
time we are going to use the
document.getelementbyid but we are not
going to use a separate variable for
storing the reference so we'll write
here
document dot get element by ID and we
haven't provided the ID yet so let's do
one thing let's move back to a HTML file
and we'll use the ID attribute here as
well inside the IMG tag we'll write a ID
let's say the ID is
I am G1 fine save it and we'll
right here inside the JS file will give
the ID here as well so we have the IDS
IMG one
save it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the style
property with this document.getelement
by ID method so we'll write here Dot
style and then we'll write a DOT width
and then we'll specify the width so
we'll write here the width as let's say
500 pixel the default width is
250 pixels right so save it and let's
see if it's working fine or not so here
is the image on the browser and we'll
take the mouse cursor over the image and
you can see the change in the size of
this picture so JavaScript makes it easy
to do such tasks now you might have
noticed that the image's size Remains
the Same once the user takes the mouse
cursor away from the image right so the
image size is changed let me zoom out a
little bit so it will be easy for you
guys so what we'll do is we'll refresh
this page and here you can see on taking
the mouse cursor over this image the
change in the size of this particular
picture
so now the MSI is 500 pixel now the
image size is not getting back to its
original size like what we did was we
use the on Mouse over event and the
image size is changing and that's
working totally fine so the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
use the on Mouse out event and what will
happen is the image size will get back
to its default size like which is the
250 pixel so we'll for that we'll use
another function so first we have to use
the on Mouse out event here
so we'll write here on Mouse out and we
have to create another function so we'll
write a change size 2 so this will be a
function name save it
and here we have to create another
function in the JavaScript file so we'll
write here function change size and the
function name is change size to then we
have the body of this function and we'll
use the document Dot get element by ID
method
the ID is same which is IMG one and then
we are going to use the style property
again and this time we'll specify the
width as
250 pixel so this is the default size of
our image save it so what we did is we
created a function that will be called
when the user takes away the mouse
cursor from the picture and the image
size will be changed to 250 pixels which
was the initial size of the image
so save it
and now you can see here on the browser
the image size is changing on taking the
mouse cursor over the image the image
size is 500 pixel now and on taking the
mouse cursor away from the image the
image is getting back to its default
size right so you can see the change
here so this is how we can use these
events to make a web page more
interactive and attractive as well next
up we'll go through another example
wherein we will change the image on the
mouse over event and the default image
will be shown on taking the cursor away
from the image so this image will change
on taking the mouse cursor over it and
again it will get back to the default
image on taking the mouse cursor away
from the image so guys here's the code
for the same and what will happen is the
image will change on taking the mouse
cursor over it and gets back to the
default on taking the cursor away so
guys the HTML part will remain the same
wherein we use the IMG tag to add an
image and then we have two functions one
for the on Mouse over and another for
the on Mouse out event so in the
JavaScript file we defined the two
functions here so you can see the
function one is change image and the
function 2 is change image 2. so what's
happening is we are using the get
element by ID method again and this time
we are using the SRC attribute and what
we are doing is we are changing the
source of image like we are using here
the simply learn.png so this is our
image saved in the particular folder
inside the images folder and in the next
function what we are doing is we are
again changing the image to the default
image so we have used the simply
code.png image here so what will happen
is the default image will be replaced by
this image when this function is called
and the other function here will again
replace the new image with the default
one so let's take a look at the output
and save it so here you can see on
taking mouse cursor over this image you
can see the change so this is the image
we want to change so on taking the Mouse
cuts are away from this image you can
see the image gets back to the default
one you can see the image is changing
and it's quite responsive and attractive
guys inheritance is an essential Concept
in any object oriented programming
language inheritance refers to the
procedure through which one class or one
Constructor inherits the properties and
methods of another Constructor in simple
terms let's suppose we have a
Constructor named as vehicle and we know
we have different types of vehicles
present like we have cars and we have
bikes as well so all these types share a
few things in common right now if we
want to create a Constructor let's say
we want to create a Constructor bike and
we want it to have a few of the same
properties and methods as of the
vehicles Constructor
so in that case we are left with two
options either we can copy the
properties from vehicle Constructor and
paste them inside the bike Constructor
or we can simply use inheritance to
inherit those properties from the
vehicle Constructor to the by
Constructor in this case the vehicle
class will be known as a base class and
the bike Constructor or class will be
known as derived Constructor because we
derived a few properties from the
vehicle Constructor right
don't worry guys I know the concept of
classes might be new for you and the
concept of inheritance might seem a bit
different from other languages like if
you are coming from a C plus plus
background you may notice that there we
use classes for the concept of
inheritance but in JavaScript before the
introduction of es6 that is ecmascript
6. the concept of inheritance was based
on Constructors and prototypes so with
the introduction of ecmascript 6 the
idea of classes was also introduced in
JavaScript and the usage of inheritance
was also changed we'll discuss classes
and inheritance in the next video today
we are going to discuss the traditional
way of using prototypes for inheritance
so don't be stressed guys if you are not
clear with the syntax of inheritance by
the end of this video in the next video
you will understand the concept and
syntax of inheritance without any
confusion so we'll now talk about a few
things so let's start with the
programming part
so guys whenever we create an object
with a method like we can create an
object with the help of object literal
method or we can do the same with the
help of Constructor function method as
well right then we have a prototype
every time you might have noticed it we
have been through it in the past few
videos so every time we create an object
we notice that it has a prototype now
what we will do here is we'll create a
prototype so the syntax will be like so
we'll write here const we are using
const in place of variable I hope you
guys are aware of cons to wear and let
keywords so today we are using here
const so let's say the prototype name is
employee
we'll write equals 2 and then we have
the body of the Prototype let's do one
thing now we'll use a method let's say
the method name is post post of the
employee
and we'll write here
function and then we have the body of
the function so let's say this function
returns a string so we'll write here
return and let's say the function
returns a
software developer and then we have
another function named as change name
and we'll write your function will pass
a parameter
and then we have the body of this method
so we'll write here this dot name
is equal to name and we are good to go
right
so what we did here is we created a
prototype of the name employee and it
has two functions one is the employees
post and the other one is to change the
name so let's save this program and
check it in the console if it has any
errors so let's save it now and we'll go
here and
check on the console
so here you can see everything is fine
so till now we created a prototype now
let's create an object as well so what
we'll do
we'll create an object here we'll write
here let's say where and let's say the
object name is even
so we'll create an object with the help
of
object Dot
create method
okay so we have to write here Dot
so we have to pass the prototype name so
we'll write here employee and then what
we'll do we'll print this on a console
so we'll write a console.log
and we'll write here even let's say so
we created an object even with the help
of object.create method let's save it
and check it on the console if we see
here we don't have anything else other
than a single prototype right we have a
single prototype here we have no method
mentioned so if we open it we have the
two methods of course we have post and
we have changed name but if we write
here let's say we are writing here even
dot name
and then value of name will be let's say
kaushal
and then we'll assign a rule as well
let's say these are the two new
properties we'll write here even dot
role and let's say the
role of causal is
writer
fine and if we save it and check it
again on the console
now what we did is we changed the name
and Rule right so these are the two
properties we have both name as kaushal
and Rule as writer now let's see if we
can use the methods here as well
so we'll write here let's say we are
using the method even Dot
change name what we'll do here is we'll
change the name from kaushal to
something else let's say we are going to
change the name as
Ram
so if we save this now so here you can
see the name is changed to Ram initially
the name was kaushal and when we use the
change name method now you can see here
the name is changed to Ram so this means
that the methods we Define inside the
Prototype are working right now let's
say we want to create another object
here we created an object even till now
we assign some properties to it and we
changed the name and printed it on the
console now let me tell you guys an
alternate way to do so
so what we'll do is we'll copy this line
from here because the syntax of that
method also looks a bit same
so the syntax will remain the same till
here so we'll paste it here what we'll
do next is
we'll pass a few arguments here
so let's pass the arguments first then
I'll explain it to you guys so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
curly braces for arguments
and we are going to write here
it's a name and the value of name will
be we are going to write here value
and we'll pass the value as let's say
kaushal 2 right
so we'll use a comma here then we'll use
role and
will pass the value of rule as well so
let's say the value of rule is
programmer now
right put a comma here now I know the
syntax is a bit complicated but this is
the reason why classes were introduced
in es6 so this is the reason we will be
using classes in future but going
through this syntax will make the next
one easier for you guys so we have
created an object here with the
object.create method and we passed few
arguments here so we have name and the
value of name we want it to be causal 2
and the value of role we want it to be
programmer so if we copy this from here
or let's say if we copy these two lines
from here if we cut these two lines from
here and we'll paste it here
so if you see here we have two objects
of the same name we have where even and
here also we have variable now both
these syntaxes are doing the same thing
that is creating an object of the same
name suppose if we comment this first
object let's say we are commenting this
one and we'll also comment this line if
we save this now and if we see on our
console so here you can see we have the
name as causal 2 and Rule as programmer
so these two syntaxes are doing exactly
the same thing the only thing to notice
here is if we use this line with this
syntax if we use even dot change name
and if we save this now you can see it
is not working in this case right so if
we want to do it we have to write
some more code so what we have to do is
we have to write here
writeable
and we have to
pass the value as true
so what we are doing is we are allowing
this method to change the name from
causal 2 to ROM so if we save it now
here you can see the name is Ram now
earlier it was causal 2 and now this is
working totally fine right
so both the syntaxes are doing the same
things as we can see here the reason
behind going through this is we need the
syntax of creating objects later in this
video so I hope you guys understood it
now moving ahead let's take a look at
prototypal inheritance so what we are
going to do is we are going to comment
this code
so we are going to comment all this and
we are going to write a new one for
prototypal inheritance
let's say we have a Constructor function
so let's create a Constructor function
first so what we are going to do is we
are going to write here let's say we are
going to create the same function we'll
take the same example of employee right
so we'll write a function employee and
we'll pass the properties here let's say
we are writing a name and another one is
ID and the last properties
salary of the employer right so next up
we have the body of the Constructor so
we'll write inside here this dot name
is equal to name
then we have this dot ID equals to ID
and then we have this Dot
salary equals to
salary
right
so we know this already right we'll now
add a method to the Prototype of the
employee so we'll write here we'll write
outside this Constructor will write here
employee
dot prototype Dot
post let's say the name of the method is
post so what we are going to do is we
are going to write your function
and then we have the body of the
function so let's say this Returns the
post of the employee what we'll do is
we'll write here return
and
it will return the name plus post of the
employee right so we'll write here this
dot name
Plus
bit of space and then again
will write here
is a content creator let's say right so
we are done with the method here
as you can see what we did here is we
created a Constructor employee and added
a function that returns this string upon
calling so we haven't done anything
extra till now let's create an object
now so we'll write here let's say we are
creating an object
and what we'll do is we'll write a new
underscore employee
and we'll pass the values here so let's
say the values are causal and the ID is
four let's say this is the ID 3 4 3 2 or
whatever it is and the salary let's say
is 10 000 okay so the next thing is
we'll write here console.log
and we'll print the value of question on
a console so let's save it now and here
you can see we have all the properties
here we have IDs 3432 name is kaushal
and salary as 10 000. here if you see
inside Proto you can see here we have a
method here name is post and we have
Constructor as employee and then we have
object as well now if we call the
Prototype post with this object so what
we have to do is we have to write here
in console we'll write a causal Dot
post
and here you can see we have the output
as causal is a content creator
till now it's fine right we did small
things which we learned in the previous
few videos so let's suppose we have
another employee named Arun and let's
assume he is also a content creator but
he's a master in JavaScript as well so
we want to mention it here along with
all these properties we have Name ID and
salary which we will inherit from this
employee Constructor and apart from that
we'll add another property which is the
subject or which is the language
property
so we have to create a new Constructor
here for it so what we'll do is we'll
write here
function and then we'll write the name
of this Constructor so let's say
the name is function programmer
so we'll write here name
will pass all the properties we'll write
a Name ID salary
and finally we have the language right
then we have the body of the Constructor
the first three properties will remain
the same right only subject or language
we have added languages so only language
will be added now we'll inherit these
properties from employee before the
concept of class was introduced
inheritance was based on prototypes only
so we'll see the concept of classes in
the upcoming video so
here what we are going to do is we are
going to call this employee Constructor
so we'll write here
employee Dot
call and will pass the properties which
we want to inherit so we'll write here
first this and first we have to write
the this keyword and then we have to
write other properties so we'll write a
Name ID salary
what we did is we called the function
employee and asked it to provide all the
three mentioned properties to the
function program
we'll set the value of language by ursul
we'll write here
this dot language
equals to
language now if we create an object for
the Constructor program what it will do
is it will take all the properties from
the employee and language will be added
to those properties let's do it first so
we will
create an object here we'll write here
where let's say the object name is Arun
and we'll write a new
programmer
and we'll pass the values let's say the
name is Arun
ID is four three two one
and salary is let's say 12 000
and finally we have to add the subject
here as well or we can say language so
let's say the language is
JavaScript
next thing we are going to do is we we
are going to print this on Console so
we'll write a console.log
and we'll print a rune
right let's save it and see here we have
all the properties available with the
provided values we have name as Arun we
have IDs four three two one salary is
twelve thousand and language is
Javascript so this is how we can inherit
the properties in the derived
Constructor from the base Constructor
the base Constructor is the employee and
the derived is a programmer so coming
back to the console we can see here we
have all the four properties right
three of them are inherited and the last
one was assigned by us but I don't know
if you guys noticed here that we have
the properties only of the Constructor
so we don't have any method here right
so if we see here we don't have any
method of Constructor employee because
here you can see we have a method as
post and if we see here we don't have
any method so
if we write here let's say if we write
here in a console we are writing here
let's say Arun dot post
and will
run it so here you can see it says
around dot post is not a function
right this is because the Prototype post
is not assigned to the Constructor
programmer for that we have to write
some extra code we have to write here
so we have to write here
programmer dot prototype equals to
object Dot
create and we have to mention the
employee prototype
so we'll write here employee Dot
prototype right so save it now and here
you can see now if you go to underscore
underscore Proto we have post as a
method here
so if we write here
Arun dot post now
so here you can see it says Arun is a
content creator so we have to provide
the prototypes manually as well
let me show you guys one more thing now
see here it is not showing the
Constructor if we click here on the
Proto we don't have any Constructor here
named as programmer
so we have to set the Constructor as
well we have to set it manually and to
set the Constructor manually we have to
write here after this line we have to
write here programmer dot prototype
Dot
Constructor
equals to programmer if we save this
program now and if we go back to our
console and if we check here here you
can see we have a Constructor named as
programmer now
so you guys might be thinking that we
have to work a lot for all this
inheritance right the fact is we
actually had to do it before es6 was
introduced now if you want to do the
same with the help of classes the syntax
will be so easy
class is nothing but a template used for
creating objects in JavaScript just like
the Constructor function we can also use
classes for creating object in
JavaScript we can include properties and
behaviors in our class creating a class
is a pretty easy job to do the syntax is
somewhat the same as that of a
Constructor function so let's move on to
the programming part if you guys are
coming from any other object oriented
programming language like we have C plus
plus Java PHP and many more object
oriented programming language right so
you may have an idea about classes the
Syntax for classes in JavaScript is also
not so different from other languages
don't worry if you are going through
classes for the first time well have a
look at classes so let's move on to the
syntax
and to declare a class we use the class
keyword followed by the name of the
class and the body of the class so we'll
write a class so this is the keyword we
use for the Declaration of a class then
we have the name of the class so let's
say we have the name as student here and
then we use curly braces for the body of
the class so this is an empty class
named as student we know that this
student has a name age roll number and
many more properties right so the next
thing we are going to do is we can
define the properties here only in fact
the Syntax for defining properties is
also the same as we had in the
Constructor function so let's define the
properties first so let's say we have
three properties here name agent roll
number so we'll write here this dot name
is equals to name
and then we have this dot h is equals to
H
and the last property is this Dot
roll number so let's say we are writing
a rule so equals to role
so we have all the three properties of
student we have name age and roll number
so we have to create a Constructor here
which will be executed while we create
an object or we can say an instance of
this class so the Syntax for creating a
Constructor will go like we have to
write a Constructor and we have to pass
all these three arguments here we have
to pass name
then we have age and then we have a roll
number so all these three arguments we
have to pass here and also these
properties will be kept inside
the body of this Constructor
so this is the basic syntax of how we
are going to create a class in
JavaScript so we have all the three
properties here we have name we have H
and we have roll number if you guys
notice here the Syntax for the
Constructor function looks a bit similar
to the syntax of the Constructor
function method which we came across in
the previous few videos right
so what we are doing is we created a
class first with the name student then
we defined all the properties of this
class inside the Constructor so by now
things are going easy right that's
because the Syntax for classes is
relatively easy to use compared to other
methods
also we don't have to write code
manually for different things we will
understand it much better while working
on inheritance so let's move on and we
will add some methods to this class now
the Syntax for adding a method is super
simple guys we don't have to write here
a function name followed by a colon and
then we have the function keyword no
we'll just write here the function name
and parenthesis so to add a method here
we'll write here let's say we are adding
a method organization so let's say we
have a method org okay so we have to
write org and
a pair of round brackets that's all this
is the Syntax for defining a method in
classes so let's say we want this
function to return a string along with
the name of the student so let's say we
are writing a return
and let's say we want it to return
I am dot name from
simply code okay
so let's say we are passing a value here
as kaushal and we want this function to
return I am causal from Simply code so
similarly We'll add another function
here
which is for the date of birth of
student
so let's see we'll write here DOB
and then we have the body of the
function so we want this function to
return the date of birth of a student
right so let's say we are in the year
2020 what we want to do is we have the
age of student let's say the age is 21
and what we are going to do next is we
are going to subtract the age from
current year so 2020 minus this dot each
will return the date of birth of student
right so we'll write here
return let's say we wanted to return a
string as well let's say the date of
birth
of
this dot name
Is 2020 minus this dot h
fine so here we are done with a string
so we want it to return the date of
birth of kaushal is
let's say 1999 if we are providing the
value as 21 then it will return 1999
right let's move ahead and create an
object first so let's say we have an
object named as
kaushal and what we are going to do is
we are going to write here new
and we are going to call the class so
we'll write here
student
and then we'll pass the values here so
let's say the name is kaushal the age is
and we have roll number is 45 so we have
all the three properties here right next
up we are going to print this on a
console so we'll write a console.log
and will print caution
so let's say if it's working or not save
it and here you can see on a console we
have a student class we have all the
three values we have ages 21 name as
kaushal and roll number as 45. if we go
inside this underscore underscore Pro 2
we can see here we have both the methods
here we have org and dub so let's try to
call these methods first so what we are
going to do is we are going to write on
our console
causal Dot dub
so here you can see we have the output
as the date of birth of kaushal is 1999.
similarly if we try to call function
causal Dot
org
so you can see here we have the output
as I am kaushal from Simply code right
so here you can see both the methods are
working fine we have both the outputs
here
the first one says the date of birth of
kaushal is 1999 and the next one gives
us the organization name so moving ahead
let me guys tell you about another
Concept in classes we'll now discuss
static functions in classes
we have to use the static keyword to
define a static method followed by the
method name so if we want to define a
static method what we have to do is we
have to use the
static keyword so the static keyword is
always followed by the name of the
method so let's say we are creating a
method here let's say for adding two
numbers so we'll write here the method
name is ADD
and then we have the body of this method
so what we want to do is we want to add
two numbers right so we have to pass
here two parameters as well we'll write
here a comma B
and then we want it to return the sum
right so we'll write a return
a
plus b
this looks fine right
notice here guys we don't have to use
anything from the class or the object
like in the previous two methods we used
the name and the H property right so
here we use this dot name and then we
used this dot age as well but here this
method is not related to object at any
cost the best part about the static
method is we can use static methods
without creating the instances of a
class so if we want to access this
particular method here we can do it with
the help of class name followed by the
dot operator and the method name so
let's try to access this method once
what we are going to do is we are going
to write console.log
and we are going to access this method
with the class name so we'll write here
student dot add and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are passing
10 and
45 fine so let's see if it works or not
so save it and here you can see we have
the output as 55 so this is how we can
create or use static methods in classes
let's move on now and we will discuss
inheritance with the help of classes in
JavaScript by now we are clear with the
meaning of inheritance right guys we
discussed in the last video that
inheritance is the procedure through
which one class inherits the properties
and methods of another class so today we
are going to see how we can Implement
inheritance with classes in JavaScript
although the concept will remain the
same we will create another class here
and will inherit the properties of this
existing class with some more properties
of the derived class I hope you guys
know the difference between Base Class
and derived class so the class we are
going to create now will be the derived
class so let's move ahead and create a
class let's say we are creating a class
here so let's save
for creating a class we have to write
class let's say the class name is
student
two
and if we want to inherit the properties
of the above class which is student one
we have to use a particular syntax so we
have to write the
extents keyword here so this is a
keyword extensor is a keyword which is
used for inheritance and then we will
write the name of the class which we
want to inherit so we'll write here
student
and then we have the body of the class
here we have a class student one that
inherits the properties of class student
next up we'll create a Constructor
function here and we'll pass all the
properties we want to be there for the
class student one so we'll pass the
Constructor function similarly like we
did in the previous class so we'll write
here Constructor and we'll pass all the
properties we want to be there for class
student one so we have the first three
properties are name which we are going
to inherit from the above class then we
have H and then we have
rule number right so let's add two more
properties here let's say the true
properties are language and then we have
section as well fine
so then we have the body of the
Constructor
so you can see here we have five
properties three of these five are
inherited from class
student and the rest two are those
properties that we want to add for class
students one exclusively the Syntax for
inheritance in classes is not a tough
one though still we have to keep a few
things in mind mainly the next statement
we are going to write here is an
important one it goes like we use the
super keyword
and then we'll
pass all the properties which we want to
inherit from the class in this
particular case we want to inherit these
three properties here right so we'll
copy this from here and we'll paste it
you remember one thing guys we'll write
only those properties which we want to
inherit from other class
actually this super keyword we used here
refers to the parent class we use it to
call the parent classes Constructor or
we can also call particular properties
and methods with the help of super
keyword
next up we'll Define the two new
properties the language and the section
now
so the syntax will remain the same we'll
write here this dot language is equals
to language
and then we'll write this Dot
section
is equal to section
we are good to go now we'll create an
object for this class as well
which is student one so let's say we are
creating an object again
let's say the name of this object is
let's remove it first so let's say we
are creating an object for this class
now let's say the name of this object is
Arun and we are going to write a new
then we have the class name which is
student one and then we'll pass the
values here so let's say the name is
Arun then we have the age is 35 and then
we have roll number as three or two
and then we have the language so let's
say the language is Javascript and then
we finally have the section as well so
let's say the section is
a fine so we have all the five values
here we have around 35 to JavaScript and
a right so let's print this on our
console
we'll write a console.log and we'll
print a rune
let's save it now and here you can see
we have a student one with all the
properties and values we have age is 35
language JavaScript name is Arun roll
number S2 and section is e if we click
here on underscore underscore Pro 2 you
can see here we have a Constructor
student when along with that we have all
the methods of the previous class of the
base class we have org we have dob as
well right so this is how inheritance
work in JavaScript the key benefit of
using inheritance with classes is that
if we remember from the previous video
if we want to access any Base Class
method then traditionally we had to
manually provide the Constructor right
but in classes we don't have to do any
such thing once we are done with
inheriting the properties and all we can
directly access the methods as well
let's try to do it here on a console so
we'll write here
Arun dot let's suppose we are using org
so we'll write a arun.org and here you
can see we have the output as I am Arun
from Simply code
next up let's use the other method as
well so we'll write here
Arun and then we'll use
dub so here you can see we have the date
of birth of arunis 1985 because we have
provided the value as 35 so 20 20 minus
35 is 1985.
here we have the output as expected now
let's see if we can access the static
method or Not by using the derived class
so we'll try to access the static method
with the help of student one so let's
try to do it we'll write here
console.log and then we'll write here
student
one dot add and will pass the values
let's say the values are
65 and 8.
right
so we want the output as
73 now so let's see if it's working or
not so we'll save it and here you can
see we have the output as 73. so this is
a basic example of how inheritance works
with classes in JavaScript functions in
JavaScript are a block of code that is
used to perform a specific task we use
functions for different purposes right
whether it be a button click or we want
to zoom out our image by taking the
mouse cursor over it we use functions
for all these tasks in JavaScript we can
use functions as objects at the same
time we can pass objects to functions as
parameters right so similarly we can
also pass a function inside another
function if I take you through the
programming part of this concept the
syntax will be like we'll go to a
Javascript file and the syntax will be
like will
declare a function let's say the
function is function ABC then here we'll
pass a parameter let's say we are
passing call as parameter for this
function ABC next up what we'll do is
we'll call this function inside this
function ABC Now what we did here is
really simple we created a function ABC
right next up we pass the function call
as a parameter to this function and then
we also call this function inside the
function ABC so this syntax is valid in
JavaScript and also this particular code
Here is known as the Callback function
in JavaScript so if we talk about the
definition of callback function it
states that a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function as an argument and that
particular function will get executed
later in the program
now you guys might have heard in the
previous videos that JavaScript is a
single threaded language or JavaScript
works over a single statement at a time
or we can say JavaScript Works in a
particular top to bottom order so if we
talk about the sequence in which
JavaScript actually works while coding
so let's take an example for this and
we'll see the sequence in which
JavaScript will work so what we'll do is
we'll comment this code and we'll start
writing our new code here so let's
suppose we have three functions in a
single program so let's say we have a
function as Function One and then we
have two more functions so let's say the
second function is function two
and then we have
function
3 as well
now if we write something inside these
functions so we will execute the program
and what will happen is all the three
functions will be executed sequentially
so let's try to do it first
so what we'll do is we'll
right here inside the body of function
one so let's say we are using console
Dot Lock and inside this will print
function 1 on calling this particular
function
so we'll do the same for other two
functions as well so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it here and here as well so
for function 2 it will print function
and for function 3 it will print
function 3. so let's save it and before
checking the output so what we'll do is
we'll call these functions as well so
let's say we are calling function 1 then
function 2
and then finally function
right everything we have done till now
is quite understandable and we have
three functions here and all the three
functions will get executed in the
sequence in which we call them so here
in this case we have called Function One
first followed by function 2 and
function three so let's check the output
save it and we'll open the console in
the browser so we'll right click here go
to inspect elements and here you can see
we have a console here so here you can
see we have the output as function 1
function 2 and function three so we have
the output in sequence we call Function
One first so we have the output as
function one but if we call function 3
before function 2. so we'll cut this
from here and we'll paste function 2
after function 3.
save it and here you can see we have the
output as function 1 then function 3 and
then function 2. 2 so JavaScript will
execute these functions in the order in
which we call them right now what if we
use the set timeout function with
function one so let's try to do it first
so instead of calling function 1 alone
here we'll write here set timeout
then we have to pass two parameters here
one is the function name so one is the
function name here and we'll write here
the time so time here will be in
milliseconds so 2000 milliseconds here
represents two seconds this means that
the function will be called after two
seconds
wait so this set timeout function will
call function when after a specific
period of time that is in this case two
seconds
what will happen is Javascript will
start executing all the functions and
the system will find out that there is a
timer with function one so in this case
the system will leave this particular
function on execution and will move
ahead and execute other function so
function 1 will be executed
automatically after two seconds so let's
check the output
save it and you can see here we have
function 3 and 2 over here and function
1 will be executed after some time so I
hope you guys got this and here we have
used the set timeout method and function
1 will be executed after two seconds
now let's consider a scenario where we
have only two functions let's say we
have function 1 and function 2. so let's
remove this function 3
and we are left with only two functions
so let's say we have function 1 and
function 2 now
now what we want is we want to execute
these two functions but we have certain
conditions so the first condition is
function 1 will use the set timeout
method and it will be executed after
three seconds
and the second condition is function 2
will get executed only after function 1
executes so till now what we have seen
is if we are using these two functions
and if we are using the set timeout
method with function1 what is happening
is Javascript will keep this function on
execution and it will execute this
function till then so what we want is we
want to execute function 2 only after
the execution of function 1. this is
where the concept of callback functions
comes into play so we have to ask the
computer to execute function 2 only
after function 1 is done
so let me write this same code in
another way we'll use the set timeout
method within function1 so what we have
to do is we have to change it here to
one will call function one from here and
inside this function one what we'll do
is we'll write here set timeout then
we'll pass the first argument as
function and then inside the body of
this function we'll write this console
log
fine and we have to pass two parameters
here right so the next parameter will be
in the time so time here will be
3000 seconds so here we are and we are
done with our set timeout function now
this is another way of using the set
timeout method in JavaScript so what we
did here is we have passed the function
here as an argument and then we have the
body of function 1 inside the set
timeout function
what we want to do next is we want to
execute function 2 once function 1 is
completed so before that let's do one
thing let's check if it is working fine
or not so we'll save it
and here you can see we have function 2
executed before function1 right so it's
working totally fine now what we want to
do is we want function 2 to execute only
after function 1 is done right so let me
tell you a shortcut for that guys it's
not callback functions but it's kind of
same thing it will do the same thing as
the Callback functions but it is a
different concept so what we have to do
is we have to cut this function 2 from
here and we have to call this function
inside here inside the set timeout
method so we'll paste it here and we
have to call function 2 inside the set
timeout method save it and now if we
wait for three seconds and here you can
see we have both the functions function
1 and 2 execute it on time so both the
functions are executed after three
seconds
and this is not callback functions but
this is a shortcut for that what
happened here is
when function 1 is being executed the
system came to know that the function 2
is called inside the set timeout method
so what will happen is it will first
execute the set timeout method and then
it will execute the function 2. so what
we did just now is not callback
functions but the functioning of a
callback function is also the same this
is the same thing we'll do with callback
functions but the syntax will be
different now by the definition of the
Callback function that we came across
earlier it states that a callback
function is a function that is passed to
another function as an argument so keep
your focus on this word argument and
that particular function will be
executed later that function which we
passed as argument will be executed
later
so here in this definition later means
once the system is done with the first
function or we can say the primary
function
it is now free to perform function 2 or
the secondary function or the Callback
function we can say
so we have kept it on hold till now so
let's take an example of that as well
what we'll do is we'll create a function
and we'll pass an argument inside this
function
the value will be provided while calling
the function so let's do one thing first
let's comment this code
and we'll write a new code here so we'll
create a function let's say a function
is function person and we'll pass an
argument here so let's say the argument
is friend fine
next up we'll work on the body of this
function what we'll do is we'll again
use
console.log and will print something so
let's say We'll
write here my
my friend's name is and then we'll use
the plus operator with the
value of friend
who will write your friend
and with this we are done with our
function person next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
function
person
2 and we don't have to pass any argument
here so inside the body of this function
we'll again use console.lock and we'll
write here
my name is
caution fine
so
next up what we have to do is we have to
call these functions right so we'll
write here person
and inside this we have to pass the
value so let's say the value here is
simply good that's fine next up we'll
call person two
and we'll save this program so on saving
this program you can see we have the
output as my friend's name is simply
code so if you want me to zoom it you
can see here now here it says my
friend's name is simply code and the
second function says my name is kaushal
right so this program is working totally
fine this is a basic program wherein we
created two function and now what we
want to do is we want the function
person to
will get executed after function person
so for that we have to pass function 2
as an argument in the function person
so we'll change the code
we'll pass this function person 2 as an
argument so we'll write here
percent two we don't have to use
brackets here so because we are passing
it as an argument now
we did it we passed this function as an
argument the next step is to tell the
function person about it right we have
to pass another argument in the function
so
we have to tell this first function that
we also have another function which will
get executed after this particular
function
so we will write here
we can use any name we can use another
name for that or we can use the same
name as our function person two so we'll
write here person two
and then what we have to do is we have
to call this person to function after
this
right now we are done with this code now
we are done with a callback function
here in this case this function person 2
is known as the Callback function
so save it now
and
okay what we have to do is we have to
remove this line from here so save it
now here you can see we have the output
totally correct we have the output as my
friend's name is simply code and my name
is kaushal
now we are done with almost everything
we are done with the Callback functions
but you might not see any change in the
output right to witness the change what
we have to do is we have to use the set
timeout method again because we want
this function to execute only after
function person so what we have to do is
we have to write here
inside function person we will write
here set timeout and
then we have to write a function
and then
inside the body will do the same we'll
cut these two brackets from here and
we'll paste them here and inside here we
have to write the time so let's say the
time is 3000 fine
now what we did is we use the set
timeout method with function person and
inside the body it will print my
friend's name is and the friend's name
is simply good and it will be executed
after three seconds right so let's save
it and we'll count for three one two and
three so here is the code you can see
here the output says my friend's name is
simply code and my name is kaushal so
this is working totally fine so this is
how the concept of callback functions in
JavaScript the word promise seems a bit
familiar we make promises regularly
right if I say I promise you that will
cover everything on promises in this
video now this promise that I made can
only have two possible outcomes either
the promise will be fulfilled or
resolved or we can say the promise can
be failed or rejected the promise will
be resolved if we'll cover everything on
promises in this video but if I left out
some topic or there is any sub topic
within promises which we forgot to cover
in this video that will be a failed
promise or we can say a rejected one now
there's another term in between these
terms that is pending pending is the
time in which the system works on the
promise
so just remember these terms as you may
hear them during an interview
so let's move on talking about the
proper definition of promises we can say
that A promise is an object which will
produce value sometimes it either gives
us a value or an error with the proper
reason there is no specific definition
for promises in JavaScript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand a
promise in JavaScript
as we mentioned earlier that A promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to a
Javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write a
new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
Next Up This Promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet I
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function pass to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this object we'll write here
function
and now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promise right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
results and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how a promise will look like
you can change the name of these
arguments instead of resolve or reject
you can write here anything but we have
kept it simple for now so that it will
be easy to understand next up let's use
a simple condition here let's take the
example of driving a car fine
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
drive and we'll check if the user
learned how to drive a car if yes then
the promise is fulfilled otherwise the
promise is rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where Drive
and let's set the value of this drive as
true for now let's say the user learned
how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions we can
either call resolve or reject right so
we'll write a if and the condition will
be drive so if we left it with drive
here it will check for if Drive is
equals to True right so we will call the
function resolve if the condition holds
true and then we'll use the else
statement for else we'll write a else
and then we'll write here
reject fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable Drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false then the function reject
will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prom and then we'll use the dot operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or it is a method
actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here from dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here
when this method is called it means that
the promise is resolved we'll use a
callback function within this method so
we'll write here function and then we'll
use
the resolve function here so we will
write here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the body for resolve
so this is how the execution will look
like for promises and on filling the
promise there will be a statement
printed on the console so it will be
like we'll write here
console.log and we'll write here
something so let's say we are writing
here
resolve
and let's say
the user
knows how to Drive fine so we'll write
here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
I forgot to mention here is we have to
pass this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
console so let's say we are writing here
for True Value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to drive let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to drive
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had the then method for resolving the
promise similarly we have one more
method for the rejection part so for the
rejection part we have the catch method
so we have to change this method here
only after the then method so we'll come
here and we'll write dot catch and the
rest of the syntax will remain same so
we'll write here function and then we'll
call reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
Plus
the user
does not know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drive so
before that we'll have to pass an
argument here so we'll write here no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive
to check for the reject method we have
to set the value of variable drive as
false so let's change the value here
let's say we are using
false here now save it and you can see
here the output says no the user does
not know how to drive fine so this is
working totally fine now you guys might
be thinking that this program we just
did is so easy we could have done it
with if else conditional statements then
why are we using promises for this the
syntax is extended and we have to
remember a lot of terms and methods for
a promise right the good part is this
was just an example to make you
understand the syntax of promises in
JavaScript
next up we'll go through an example
wherein we'll discuss the dependency of
promises as well so let's move ahead and
in this example what we'll do is we'll
create three separate functions let's
suppose we want to learn promises in
JavaScript
but for that we must know about the
concept of functions and callback
functions in JavaScript then only we can
go through promises so what we'll do is
we'll create three functions in which
the current function will depend upon
the previous function if the user knows
about functions he can go through
callback functions and if the user knows
both functions and callback functions he
is good to go for promises so let me
take you through the code guys
so here's the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and Promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic and if the user is done
with functions in JavaScript then he can
move on to callback functions and then
to promises so we have three different
promises for each function right so each
function here like the first function
returns a promise right similarly all
the three functions are returning a
promise here we are directly resolving
it we don't need to wait for the user to
learn functions completely otherwise we
can use here the reject function as well
for now we are just resolving it which
means that the user learned functions in
JavaScript already the same goes for
callback functions and Promises as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only but the syntax will be
different so let me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here so functions is our first
function and on resolving we call the
function callback with the result and we
did the same thing again for a callback
on resolving the Callback function it
will call the promises function and
finally it will print this good to go
message on the console with the previous
messages written by the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in JavaScript now
let's save this program and we'll check
the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says good to go and then it
says learned functions learned callback
functions good to go for promises in
JavaScript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to Nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in JavaScript
actually work now we have been using
functions in almost every video since we
came across this topic whether it be Dom
manipulation or using an event in
JavaScript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of Arrow function is
just a change in the syntax of declaring
and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in JavaScript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all so we know these
Concepts already so let's write the code
here so we'll go to our Javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
a function let's say the function name
is
Funk one
and then this function have two
parameters A and B
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it go back to
the browser go to inspect and then we'll
go to a console and we'll write here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
25 so the output we are expecting is 40
and the output is correct we have the
output test 40 you can see here we have
the output as 40. and so this function
is working totally fine next up we'll
create another function first and then
we'll move to the arrow function syntax
so for the second function we'll write
here function let's say the function
name is function
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then let's say this
function prints
welcome
to Simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we'll call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well so let's save it
and check the output here you can see we
have the output as welcome to Simply
code in our console
so this is how we were using functions
till now the simple Syntax for functions
right so let's move on to the concept of
Arrow functions now this function over
here has two parameters right this
function has parameters A and B
and what we'll do is we'll change the
syntax of this function and the new
syntax will be more simple once you get
used to it so let's write the newer
syntax just below the previous one we
don't need the function keyword with
arrow functions so all we have to do is
we have to take a variable so let's do
it first so let's say we have a variable
where everyone fine so this is our
variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named errone and this will be
the function name so Arrow 1 will be the
function name as well right when we use
the function keyword in traditional
syntax of functions it automatically
creates a variable with the function
name here we have to declare the
variable by herself next up we have two
parameters here A and B as you can see
here we have a and b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write parameters so let's say
the parameters are A and B for this
function as well so these are the
parameters we have to write them within
parenthesis
now we'll use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and then we have to write this
so This Is The Arrow Mark which makes
this whole statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function so the body of function will
remain same so we'll copy the body from
here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function Arrow one here is the
same as function function and the output
will be the same
this Arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
Arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function up one line if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one line right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is we'll save this program and we'll
go to a console so let's do one thing
we'll call func one first and the
parameters let's say are 5 and 15. and
then we'll call the arrow function with
the same parameters so we'll write a
arrow 5 comma 50.
now we have the output s20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function function so let
me comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll comment this and now
we are good to
so we have function func2 here now what
we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
so we'll write here
say we are writing here where
Arrow 2
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have the arrow
operator so the body will remain the
same we'll copy the body from this
function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parenthesis here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so for this we
have to write here
Arrow 2 and we are good to save it and
the output we are expecting is
welcome to Simply code twice because we
are calling Funk 2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to Simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
Arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to Simply
code and welcome to Simply learn let me
Zoom it for you if it's not visible so
here you can see the first output for
func 2 it says welcome to Simply code
and for Arrow 2 it says welcome to
Simply learn
that's working fine now before we wrap
up this video let me tell you another
benefit of using Arrow functions so we
already discussed that we don't need to
use the return keyword if we are writing
a one line of function similarly if we
have a single parameter we don't need
any parenthesis we'll create another
function here so let's say we are
writing here where
Arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name fine then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console.log
and then we'll write here hey there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so now we are good to go this
function here will give us the output as
hey there and then whatever name will
pass while calling the function so let's
check it let's call this function as
well so let's say we are writing here
Arrow 3 and the name let's say will be
kosher
save it and here you can see it says hey
there kaushal for Arrow function three
so this is also working fine
and I hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in JavaScript it's
not essential to use Arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
the arrow function will help you with
that if you guys remember when we came
across callback functions in JavaScript
we use the function there that we said
will call the function after 2 seconds
or 3 seconds you might have guessed that
we are talking about the set timeout
method so this set timeout method is
actually a predefined function in
JavaScript that does some task after a
particular interval of time if we say we
want a function to be called after 5
Seconds when the user presses a button
so we'll use this set timeout method and
the function will be called after 5
Seconds of the user pressing the button
so it will be more clear to you guys
when we go through the programming part
so let's move on to the programming part
directly and we'll create a simple
button first and then on clicking that
button a pop-up will appear on the
screen with a message after some time so
we'll create a button first
so for that
will write here in HTML file we'll use
the button tag again we'll write here
button and let's say the button name is
Click me
fine save it and here we have the button
on a browser
so we have created a button here this
was simple next up we want this button
to call a function on clicking so what
we'll do next is we'll use the on click
method within this button tag and then
we'll Define the function in Javascript
file so let's do it we'll write here
on click and we want this button to call
a function let's say the function name
is start
so what will happen is the function
start will be called on clicking this
button so let's move on to a Javascript
file and we'll declare some functions
here so we'll create a function here
that will print some message on a pop-up
not the start function but a different
one so we'll write here where message
and then we'll use the Syntax for Arrow
functions so we will write here
alert and inside this field right here
welcome to
simply code so this is a message
save it we have created an arrow
function here just to remind you guys of
the Syntax for Arrow functions so this
function will print this message with
the pop-up we can check it we have to go
to our console
and we'll write here
message and call this function so here
we have a pop-up with message welcome to
Simply good so this function is working
totally fine the real work Starts Now
what we'll do next is we'll Define the
function start with the set timeout
method for that we'll write here
function
start
and then inside the body of this start
function we'll call the set timeout
method and we'll pass two arguments here
so the first one is
the function name and the other one is
the time interval
so this is how we basically use the set
timeout method in JavaScript this is the
syntax so let's check the output now and
then we'll see another Syntax for the
same program so save it
and we'll go to the browser click on
this button and the pop-up will appear
after two seconds so here's the pop-up
with the message welcome to Simply code
so this is working fine
now this syntax here is for the
understanding purpose the following
syntax we'll go through will let you
know another concept of anonymous
functions in JavaScript so for the newer
syntax we'll write here
will comment this piece of code
and we'll write here
function and the function name is start
then inside the body of this function
we'll use the set timeout method
and we'll write here
function this function is an anonymous
function
then we have the body of this function
and the time
so here we have written 2000 and inside
the body we'll write here alert
and let's say the message it will print
is
welcome back
if you see this function here you can
see that we have used the function
keyword instead of passing another
function this concept Here is known as
Anonymous functions in JavaScript
basically an anonymous function is a
function without a name we often use
this function as arguments to other
function and this syntax will call the
start function after two seconds
so this function here will work as the
previous one these two functions are the
same
it will also print the same message
after two seconds it will print welcome
back after two seconds save it and click
on the button you can see here we have
the pop-up on the screen after two
seconds so this function is working fine
the syntax are different but the working
is same
now let's go through another method the
next method is used to stop the timer in
between
so we'll use the first function we
created here for this purpose we'll
comment this piece of code and we'll use
this syntax only
now the next method we are going to
discuss about is the clear timeout
method
let's say we want to call this function
after 5 seconds and suddenly in between
we realize that we don't want to call
this function so what we want to do is
we want to stop this function before it
executes so the clear timeout method
comes into picture and this clear
timeout method works with a variable so
let's create another button for that
first and then we'll declare a variable
as well so let's say we want a button
here and this button will
call a function on clicking so let's say
the function name will be stop
and the button name will also be stop so
save it
and here you can see we have two buttons
one is the click me and the other one is
stop
next up we'll move back to our
JavaScript file
and we discussed earlier that this clear
timeout method works with a variable
so what we'll do next is we'll create a
variable and we'll assign the initial
value to that variable as 0.
let's say the variable name is ID and
the initial value is 0. now why we
assign the value as 0 to this ID
variable because
we want to update the value of ID
variable with the value provided by this
set timeout method so we'll assign the
value of the set timeout method to this
ID variable so we'll write here ID is
equals to set timeout
and the rest will remain the same now
next up we'll Define another function to
stop all this from happening so for that
we'll write here
yeah
function and the function name is top
and then inside the body of this
function
will
use the method clear timeout
and this method takes a variable as an
argument so we'll pass ID here
and we are done with it
so this function will stop the set
timeout method before execution let's
check it out save it and what we'll do
is we'll press the stop button in
between the two seconds
after the function start will be called
so let's change the timing here from 2
seconds to 5 Seconds
so we'll write here
save it now
and we'll first check if the function
start is working fine or not so press
the click me button and we have to wait
for five seconds
and then the pop-up will appear on the
screen with the message welcome to
Simply good so this function is working
totally fine now the next task is to
press the stop button in between those
five seconds let's do it
click on this click me button and in
between these five seconds click the
stop Button as well
so here you can see the message is not
printing anymore on clicking the stop
button so this function is also working
fine because we stopped the process in
between before the function start
executes
right
next up we have another method in the
timing functions that is the set
interval method as the name suggests
this method is used to call the function
repeatedly after a specific interval of
time
like the set timeout method this set
interval method also takes two
parameters first is the name of the
function and the other one is the time
interval so we'll change this program
only and instead of this set timeout
here
will write
set interval
fine so we are good to go now the only
change we did here is to use the set
interval method instead of the set
timeout method now what will happen is
on clicking this click me button the
function message will be called
repeatedly after 5 Seconds
let's check it out first save it and
click here on this button so we have to
wait for five seconds and then a pop-up
will appear
so here you can see we have the pop-up
here now after pressing OK we'll wait
for five seconds again and we have the
pop-up again so what's happening here is
we are getting the pop-up constantly
after five seconds right so this is also
working fine and on clicking the stop
button
this function will also stop so we have
clicked on this stop button and we are
not getting the pop-up anymore
so that's how the timing functions in
JavaScript Works a sync await works with
promises in JavaScript
if you are not clear with Promises by
now I recommend you to watch the
previous video on promises in this
playlist and it will be easier for you
guys to understand async await in
JavaScript now async of it is just a
syntactical sugar wrapped around
promises in JavaScript basically it
makes it easier to work with promises in
JavaScript we already know that using
promises might be a bit tricky or we can
say more prolonged sometimes because we
have to create so many functions and
Promises in JavaScript
so before we move on to async await let
me take you guys through this code which
has promises in it and then we'll see
how to use async await in JavaScript so
here is a code for promises in
JavaScript
here in this code we have two functions
make order and process order the make
order function returns a promise and it
will resolve it if the user enters black
coffee otherwise it will reject it on
any other type of coffee
then we have another function here for
processing the order and it will always
resolve so this function is quite simple
and it will add some extra information
to the order so here is the code for
extra information it will print this on
Console so let's move ahead and we'll
look at how we call these functions
using promises and then we'll change the
same code using a sync await let me do
it guys first and then I'll explain it
to you so here's the code now what we
did here is we call the make order
function
and will pass here black coffee as an
argument to make it successful then we
have used the dot then because we are
using promises here and then we have the
order that will be returned by a promise
so which in this case is a string that
says here is your coffee this is the
string if I show you so this is the
string it will return and then we have
written here console.log order has been
received it will be printed on the
console
and then we have called the process
order function and we are going to
process the order that we received and
the reason we are returning this is
because so you can see here we are
returning this process order function
the reason behind it is because we are
using promises here then we have changed
the event here so we have used the dot
then operator again we are going to
receive the response from the process
order above in this case we have taken
it as processed order and we have logged
whatever response we will get here the
next thing we did here is to use the
catch block
to catch any type of error we get for
example if the user says he wants the
latte not black coffee then it will give
an error and it will say that we serve
black coffee only so this is the code
for error so that's all and we are
calling these functions so if we save
this program
let's say we are saving it and if we go
back to our console
so here you can see the output says
making request for a black coffee and
then it says order has been processed
then it says processing order and then
at last it says extra information plus
here is your coffee have a nice day
that's how we wanted it to be right now
if the user says he wants a latte in
place of black coffee so let's check it
out and what we'll do is we'll pass the
argument here as latte instead of black
coffee
so save it now here you can see it says
making request for latte so firstly it
made a request for latte and then it
returned the error the error says sorry
we serve black coffee only so it's
working totally fine and this is how
promises actually work in JavaScript all
the different codes here are executed
and it is waiting for the previous code
to execute before moving on to the next
one
so that's what we exactly wanted here
now if you look at all this code here
which is obviously not too much
confusing but we have to use more dot
than here right we have to go through a
lot of nesting here and it could be done
easily with a sink of weight in
JavaScript and one more issue with
promises is if we want to use the
parameter inside this first dot then so
if we want to use a parameter here what
we have to do is we have to first create
a variable and we have to assign
something to that variable which is not
an easy task right but with async and a
weight we can do it more efficiently and
we don't have to worry about all the dot
thens and all so now we'll do the same
program with async end of it and we'll
do it here only below this program
we'll write this piece of code with the
help of async of it and we'll see how
easy it is to use async and await in
JavaScript so let me comment this first
guys now the first thing we need to keep
in mind with async and await is we need
a function to use these terms for
example let's create a simple function
here first so we'll write your function
let's say the function name is function
and then we have the body of the
solution so this is the basic function
here and we'll put all our asynchronous
code inside here in this function
but we need to tell JavaScript that this
function will work asynchronously for
that we have to write a keyword here
before function so what we'll do is
we'll write here
async and this is the syntax now
JavaScript will know that this function
is an asynchronous function and it will
handle this function accordingly now
inside of this function what we'll do is
we'll call a different methods here
so we'll call the make order method here
and then we'll call the process order
method as well so let's do it first
let's call the make order method first
so we'll write here
make order and we'll pass the argument
here so the argument will be let's say
black coffee
fine
now we have called the function make
order here all we have to do is we have
to write a weight in front of this
function which will make the code wait
until this make order function executes
then only the next part will be executed
so we'll write here
a weight and this make order function
now will return the resolve section of
the first promise we made so we'll store
this inside a variable so we'll write
here let's create a variable here we'll
write where
order
fine
because we have all this code inside of
an asynchronous function what will
happen is as soon as JavaScript finds
that a weight keyword so as soon as
JavaScript find this await keyword
it will leave this function and start
doing other works inside of this program
remember it will leave this whole
function it's not something like the set
timeout method it is different from that
as soon as the make order function is
done executing it will come back to this
function and Returns the result into
this order variable
next up what we'll do is we'll write
here
console
.log
and what we want to log here is order as
we received
now
if we look at the promises example
previously and compare these two codes
so if you can see here we are done with
this part so this is what it looks like
while working with async await in
JavaScript
now we'll see that we have received the
order with pretty easy syntax right next
up what we have to do is we have to
process this order this means that we
have to write the code for the second
then we used in the promises example
right the syntax will remain the same
for that we'll write here where
processed order
is equals to
a weight we'll use the await keyword
again
and then we'll write here
process order
fine
and then we'll pass the argument as
order so we are passing this variable as
an argument to this process order
function
in the next line we'll write here
console.log
and we'll copy this this line is the
same so we'll copy it from here will
paste it
fine now we have used the variable
processed order to process the order and
then we know that as soon as the
processing is done we want it to log it
in here
so we are done with this and all we need
to do now is called a synchronous
function and we are good to go so let's
call this function first for that we'll
write here
Funk one
and now save this program
so here you can see it says process
order is not defined it's okay we have
to remove this e here now save this and
here you can see we have the exact same
output as we had in the promises example
and with this we can say the sink of it
are working totally fine now the
question arising in your mind may be
that we didn't do anything for the catch
block here right what if the user enters
latte in place of black coffee so let's
try to do it once so what we'll do is
we'll write here
latte and save it so you can see the
first function is working fine it says
making request for a latte and then it
says
sorry we serve black coffee only so this
is a error and caught error in promises
so we have to do something about this
error right now the async and awaiting
JavaScript actually has two blocks one
for resolving and the other one for
error or reject
so we can say like the then and catch in
promises we have try and catch in a sink
of it so what we have to do here is we
have to put all this piece of code
inside the try block
so let's do it first what we'll do here
is we'll write here
try so what we are doing is we are
asking the computer to try this piece of
code if this is fine or not
and then we have another block catch
fine
so we'll write the code for rejection
here inside the sketch block what we'll
do is we'll write here catch and we'll
pass a argument here so we'll write a
error
and then we'll log this error on a
console so we'll write a console.log
hello
so we have passed the parameter here and
the moment it will find any error it
will leave the try block and moves on to
the catch block and the output will be
an error so save it and you can see it
here
on the console it says sorry Vsauce
black coffee only so this is how we can
use a sync await in JavaScript it's not
necessary to use with over promises but
the syntax is relatively clean and easy
to understand right as you can see
all we have to keep in mind while using
async await is we have to use a function
and wrap up all the data inside it so
keep this thing in mind that we have to
use a function always and we have to
wrap up all this data inside a single
function with the help of try and catch
block try and catch block are pretty
easy to use right we'll go through try
and catch Block in the next video as
well and we'll go through error only
another important thing I want to
mention here before we end up this video
is guys it may happen that you might
don't use these topics quite frequently
while working on the front end of a
website but if you get to answer these
questions during an interview and these
topics are pretty crucial if you are
learning JavaScript
so whether it be a sink of weight or
promises or callback functions you need
all of them in JavaScript so please go
through these topics carefully errors
are something that we get at times while
working on a program generally there are
different types of Errors present in
almost every programming language errors
like syntax error runtime errors and
logical errors so syntax errors are
those errors a user can't control we
have to correct the Syntax for that
that's the only option with syntax
errors for example let's say we have a
function that will print something on
the console on calling so let's create a
function here
we'll go to a Javascript file and we'll
create a function here so let's say the
function name is f
fine
and this function will
print something
on the console
so let's say it prints this is
Function One Fine
now this is a function that will print
this string on the console but let's say
we forgot to put the closing bracket of
this function by mistake or let's say
the closing part was deleted and we are
not aware of it so this part was deleted
or we forgot to put it there
and what we'll do is we'll call this
function we try to call this function
let's call it first
we'll call function1 save it and
go to the console so
here in console you can see that it
returns an error here it says syntax
error unexpected end of input and the
best part is we can't do anything for it
except for we can put that closing
bracket in its place again so if we put
this closing bracket here again
now it will work fine save it and here
you can see we have the output as this
is function1
so these type of Errors when occur in a
program are known as syntax errors
another type of error that occurs in a
program is runtime error runtime errors
are those errors through which the
system comes across during the execution
of a program for example let's say if we
have another function here so let's add
another function here we'll write here
function F2
and the body
will print something on the console
again so we'll copy this from here and
instead of function one we'll write a
function 2.
save it and we haven't called this
function yet so let's imagine a scenario
that you created a function F2 and later
somewhere in the program you realize
that you created a function and you need
to call that function but you are not
sure of the name of that function so
let's say you called another function
but the function name was wrong so let's
say instead of function 2 we called
another function F4 let's call this
let's try to do it save it and here you
can see our first function is working
fine but when the system reaches
function F2 it encountered an error here
although there is nothing wrong with the
syntax we are trying to call a function
that does not exist so these type of
errors are known as reference error in a
program we can fix these type of error
with the help of try catch and throw
block we'll see it later these are the
different types of errors that might
occur in a program but sometimes there
are situations in which we want to print
an error to the user it might be for the
data entered by the user or for the data
we are getting from the server basically
we are talking about custom errors that
we create ourselves to make the flow of
program more smooth
we came across the try and catch Block
in the previous video wherein we used
these keywords with the async await in
JavaScript
so there we saw how these blocks were
working to print an error when the user
asks for something other than black
coffee if you haven't watched that video
yet please go through it you can find it
in this playlist
so let's do one thing here and we'll
create a small prototype of the same
program wherein we will have a function
that will print a string on the console
so let me comment this out guys now
we'll create another function here so
let's say we are writing here
function
make order
fine so this is the function we created
in the last video as well so let's say
inside the body of this function we'll
write something on the console
we will write a console.log and
in right here here is your black coffee
enjoy your
day fine now we will go through the
syntax of try and catch block first
and we'll see why we use these try and
catch blocks in a program so before we
move on to the try and catch block Let
Me Clear one thing guys it's not only
the try and catch blocks we use for
these purposes we have another Block in
JavaScript that is always independent of
these two blocks and doesn't need any
condition to run so the inclusion of the
finally Block in error handling depends
upon the user you can either add it or
leave it there will be no effect on the
program
so now let's move ahead and we'll go
through the syntax of try and catch
first and then we'll move on to the
finally block because finally block is
different from try and catch so let's go
through the try and catch first so we'll
write here
try and press
so we'll write here try and you can see
this is the syntax of try and catch
block the catch contains an argument
with it and it will catch the error
returned by the try block so let's write
the code here and then we'll go through
it we want to run this function inside
the try block and if the function exists
the try block will execute it otherwise
a customized error will be thrown to the
user so we'll call this function inside
the try block
so we'll write a make
order
and we have called this function
now if the function exists the try block
will execute it there will be no problem
in that we are asking the computer to
try executing this line and if this line
does not exist show the user the error
we want to show not the one set by
default so the customized error will
write inside the catch block
and inside the catch block we'll write
here
console.log
and let's say it says
sorry
so this is the error we want to show the
error says sorry an error occurred in
your program
now let's execute this once and then
we'll see it again thoroughly so
this code will not show an error save it
and it will execute the function make
order and the output will be here's your
black coffee enjoy your day
right
but if we execute here another function
that does not even exist like we did for
the runtime errors so if we write here
let's say another function so let's say
the other function name is
process order fine so this function does
not exist in the entire program now the
system will go inside the try block and
it will execute the make order function
first the make order function will be
executed without any problem but the
moment it will come across the function
process order it will find it out that
no such function exists in the program
that's when it will move to the next
block and it will throw an error to the
user so save this program and you can
see here it says here is your black
coffee enjoy your day first and then it
says sorry an error occurred in your
program so this is how you can show an
error to the user a customized error we
can say if we call this process order
function outside of the try block the
scenario will change
error will be different so let me show
you guys what we'll do is we'll cut this
process order from here and we'll call
this process order function outside of
the try and catch block
now we have called this process order
function here and we know this function
does not exist in the program so let's
save it and here you can see it says
uncode reference error process order is
not defined so this is a runtime error
here now this is the default error you
get in JavaScript this is the default
way in which you can get an error in
Java
so there are certain things we can do
with errors in JavaScript which are
let's say if you want to print the error
as well in the console so we just have
to write here console.log
editor
and one more thing we have to do is we
have to move this process order function
from here
back again to its original position
so save it now and here you can see we
have a reference error now this
statement will print the whole error in
the form of text and the user will know
the type of error as well
apart from that we can also print only
the message or the name of them so for
that we have to write here
console.log
error Dot name for the name of error and
console.log error Dot
message for the error message so save it
and here you can see
we have reference error and as the name
of error and the message is process
order is not defined so this part of the
error is the message and this part is
the name now we are left with the
finally block only we have already
discussed that the finally block is
independent of the two blocks and it
will be executed anyway if present in a
program
so the Syntax for finally block goes
like this
what we'll do is we'll remove
these three statements from a program
and we'll write here
finally
and inside the finally let's say we want
to print something
on the
console so let's say we'll write here
this block
will
execute
no matter what now this finally block
will be executed anyhow save it and here
you can see we have the output as this
block will execute no matter what
let's do one thing let's take this
process order function from here and
we'll paste it here save it now and here
you can see now none of the three blocks
is executing right so what we have to do
is we have to put it back in its place
one more thing we will discuss before
wrapping up this video is the throw
keyword in JavaScript with this keyword
we can throw an error anywhere in the
program the message will be customizable
and the type will be uncaught error
fine let's see an example of this type
of error handling with the help of basic
if else statement
so let's say we have a condition here in
which we have a variable so let me
comment this piece of code as well first
now let's say we have a condition here
in which we have a variable a and the
value of a is let's say 9. the condition
we have to check here is if a is less
than 10 then an error should be thrown
otherwise the system should print
something
right so let's move on to the
programming part and you will understand
it so what we'll do is we'll declare a
variable e and the value of variable a
will be 9.
now the if statement will have a
condition that if a is less than 10
through an error so what we have to do
is we have to write here through new
error
right
and the message will be let's say this
is a
customizable error
fine
this is the message and we have to
mention the else statement here as well
so inside the SLC statement we'll write
here
control Dot Lock
working fine let's say
so
the if else block does not matter that
much in this case the only thing I want
you guys to see here is the throw
keyword save this program here and we
have the value as 9.
and what we wanted to throw an error if
the value is less than 10 save it and
here you can see
we have a familiar representation of
this error different from the try catch
block the message is customizable and it
says this is a customizable error so
this is how we can throw an error in the
program wherever we want to have you
guys ever heard about validation or
pattern matching in JavaScript we come
across these terms when we hear about
passwords mostly right so we say that we
can use the if else statement to match
if the user's password matches with the
one we already have for that we write if
password is equal to is equals to some
sort of string or characters
and then we see if the password matches
will let the user enter otherwise the
entry will be denied so we are
discussing all that because regular
expressions are objects used to perform
pattern matching or if we want to search
for something in a string or even if we
want to replace something from a string
we can do it all with regular
expressions
so we'll go through the Syntax for
regular expressions and some more
important things about regular
expressions in JavaScript so regular
expressions are present in almost every
programming language it's not limited to
JavaScript only and the concept Remains
the Same everywhere the syntax May
differ a bit between different languages
but the logic behind them will always be
the same the name might be a little bit
confusing but the reality is entirely
different they are pretty easy to use
and if you understand the basics clearly
you will face no problem while working
on Advanced topics so let's go through
the regular Expressions before we move
on to validations using regular
expressions in JavaScript so let's
understand the concept entirely so that
it will be easy for you guys in further
videos so consider a scenario where we
have a string and we want to find a
particular word in that string or we can
say we are in a static website I hope
you guys are aware of the term static
where we have the search option to find
some word in the entire HTML document we
have to write the word in the search box
and it will return us the location of
that word in the HTML file or in the
website right what we'll do now is we'll
use a word and we'll find that word in a
string we'll make some changes to that
word with the help of several functions
used along with regular expressions in
JavaScript so the Syntax for regular
Expressions goes like this will move to
a Javascript file and we'll take a
variable here so let's say the variable
is where Rejects
and we use two forward slashes for it
generally we use the double slash for
comments but it will be recognized as a
regular expression in JavaScript if we
write something inside these double
slashes so let's say we are writing
something here let's say we write here
hello now this word hello is present
inside the variable regex and this word
needs to be searched in a string so
let's use a string as well so for that
we'll write here where let's say the
string name is str1 let's say we are
writing here welcome
to a
YouTube channel
full stop
say hello
if
you are new here
fine so let's say this is the string we
have
now this string contains the word hello
in it all we have to keep in mind is to
add the main keyword in the string for
now
moving ahead what we want to do is we
want to find this word in the string
right we want to find this hello world
industry
so next up we'll go through certain
essential functions which we use with
regular expressions and we'll see the
functioning of these essential functions
the first function is the exact function
so let me write here guys this is the
first function exec function
now this function returns an array if
the word is present in this tree
otherwise it will return null if the
word is not present in the string the
syntax is pretty straightforward all we
have to do is to use the exact function
with the variable that contains the
regular expression now in this case the
word rejects contains the regular
expression we have to use it with the
function and the string name will be
passed as a parameter to this function
so let's write the syntax here and it
will be easy for you guys so let's
comment it out
and we'll write here let's say we are
taking another variable where output
we'll write here the variable name
dot function name we'll write a exec and
the string will be passed as a parameter
fine
so this is the syntax now this output
variable over here will have an array
and the array will return the index
number of the word hello industry
fine so let's print this array on the
console and we'll write here
console.log
output fine
save it and open the console so we will
move to a browser and we'll open console
here
see here we have an array and if we
click on this array we can see that we
have the word hello at index 36 so if we
count from here and the counting should
start from 0 because error index always
starts from zero so at index 36 we can
find that hello is over here fine so it
will return the index of this particular
word
now
if we write here something else other
than hello let's say we are writing here
2. save it now and you can see here we
have two present at index eight so if we
count from here we can see that 2 is
present at index 8. so this is working
totally fine now another scenario is if
we write here 2 with a capital T save it
now and you can see here the output is
null
because regular expressions in
JavaScript are case sensitive case
sensitive means it differentiates
between the capital letters and small
letters fine
but the good part is we can make them in
case sensitive as well so all we have to
do is we have to use a modifier a
modifier is actually used to make
modifications in the search so what we
have to do is we have to write here in
the beginning we have to write a single
letter and in this case we'll write here
I because this modifier will tell the
system that there will be no problem
with the case sensitivity of the word
now it will work fine and if we save
this program
we can see we have the output as index
8. now if we change this string and
we'll write here something other than
this so we'll write here h e llo but the
three letters of this word are capital
letters
so save it now and you can see we have
the output as index 36 so this is
working fine now one last situation is
if we write here more than one hello in
a single string so if we write here
hello and welcome to our YouTube channel
now there are two hello words present in
a single string save it and you can see
we have the word hello at index 0. so it
will return the first hello world in the
string now if we want to get access of
the second hello and for if we write
here this piece of code again what we
are expecting is we are expecting it to
give us the index of second hello as
well but it will not happen save it and
you can see it will give the index of
first hello twice you can see here we
have index as 0 in both Diaries right so
it will not work
now the solution to this problem is
modifiers again what we have to do is we
have to use another modifier here now we
have to write here the letter G and save
it now this is returning null because we
have the string wrong here so we have to
write here hello because we have removed
the in case sensitive modifier save it
now and you can see we have both the
hello words with indexes as 0 and 46
respectively So This Global modifier
tells the system that the word is now
global and if you find the word once and
the user tries the exact function again
then the second time you should return
the index value of the second word
so this is how it actually works now the
following function we are going to
discuss is a pretty simple one the test
function now this function returns
either true or false nothing else this
function checks for a particular word
that if the word exists in a string then
it will return true otherwise false
it will not return the index value or
some sort of other things it deals with
the Boolean value only that is true or
false so that's it for the function
let's see how this function work
actually so what we'll do is we'll
mention here this test function
and will
comment this piece of code
so that there will be no confusion will
comment it out
now we'll go through the syntax of this
test function the syntax is pretty easy
we'll use the output variable again and
we'll write here
variable name dot function name and the
string name will be passed as a
parameter
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write a console.log and will print this
on a
console fine so this is the Syntax for
test function save it and here you can
see in the console that for the word
hello it returns true if we change this
word here to something else like if we
read right here High instead of hello
save it and you can see the output is
changed to false because high is not
there inside a string right because high
does not exist according to this history
so this is how the test function
actually work now one more thing I want
to mention here about the test function
is if we write here some part of a word
not the whole word but some part so
let's say if we write here e l l now
this is the part of hello world now what
if we save this you can see the output
here is true that's because the test
function checks for every letter and if
it finds these three letters in any word
it will return true in that case as well
fine next up we have another function to
use with the regular expressions in
JavaScript now the next function's name
is match function
I'll write it here
first I'll comment these two statements
and then I'll write here the name of
this function so the name is match
now this match function returns an array
of results otherwise null the Syntax for
this function is exactly opposite from
the previous functions because we'll
pass the regular expression as a
parameter to this function now and the
function will be used along with this
tree
so it is completely opposite to the
syntax we used for the previous two
functions so we'll write here for this
we'll use the output variable again
we'll write here where output
and instead of regex we'll use it with
this string so we'll write here str1 dot
match and the variable name will be
passed as a parameter fine
so this is how the Syntax for match
function looks like it's exactly
opposite to the syntax we used for
previous two functions the next line
will remain the same we'll write a
console.log and will print
output on a screen fine now we have to
do one more thing here what's that is we
have to remove this modifier from here
and we have to write here hello so save
it and you can see we have an array over
here now what if we want to find both
the words in a string if we have if we
want to check if there's more than one
word with the similar name so what we
have to do is we have to write here G
and if you save it now you can see the
output is completely changed and now we
have an array with two similar words
what if we add another hello here so
let's say we have another hello here
save it and you can see here the array
size is increased to 3 now now we are
left with one more method and the method
we are going to discuss now is pretty
important because we'll use this method
in future as well so the last method is
the replace method which is used to
replace something from a string we can
either replace the first matching word
or all the matching words from a string
if we are using the global modifier then
all the words will be replaced otherwise
the first matching word will be replaced
so the syntax for this method goes like
this what we have to do is so let's
comment it out first and we'll go
through the syntax of final method so
the final method is
replace method
fine
so the syntax goes like this we'll use
the output variable again
and we'll write here
str1 dot replace because we want to
replace something in that particular
string the first parameter will be the
variable name we'll write here regex
comma and then we'll pass the word we
want to change so hello will be changed
with let's say in this case hi fine now
check over here that if we are using any
modifiers so we are using Global
modifier here now if we print this on a
console if we write a console.log and we
are writing here output
if we save it now we'll get to know that
all the Hello words in the string are
replaced with the word hi save it and
you can see over here that hi and
welcome to a YouTube channel say hi if
you are new here and then we have a hi
you can see that all the Hello words are
replaced with the word hi now if we
remove This Global modifier from here
and if we save it now you can see only
the first hello world is replaced the
other hello words are here and there
will be no change in them because we are
not using the global modifier now in the
previous video where we came across
regular expressions in JavaScript we saw
different predefined functions that we
use for finding a particular expression
present inside a string right like the
predefined functions we also have some
JavaScript characters that make the
searching part easy
so these characters are used within the
expressions and help us in different
ways for example let's consider a
scenario where we have a regular
expression and we want to find a
particular word within the string
but we don't remember the whole world
let's say we forgot the word with time
and now we remember only a part of that
rule so let's do the same side by side
and what we'll do is we'll go to our
Javascript file and we'll take three
variables we'll write here let regex is
equals to
then we'll write here let str1 is equals
to
and then finally we'll write
where output is equals to
fine now here we have three variables
the variable regex will store a regular
expression within it we haven't returned
the word yet next up we have a variable
str1 to store the string and the
variable output to store the output
returned by a function the function
we'll use will be any one of the ones we
used in the previous video so let's do
it here the word let's say the word will
be
welcome fine
you can take any word you want now
moving on to the string let's write the
string as well we'll write here Welcome
to our YouTube channel and then we'll
write another welcome here
fine
we'll discuss the reason why we wrote
welcome twice now if you guys remember
from the previous video where we have
used the test function to check the
availability of a word present in a
string or not we'll use the same
function again so we'll write here
variable name Dot
function name so the function name is
test and then we'll pass the string name
as a parameter so we'll write here str1
that's fine
and finally what we'll do is we'll
print this on our console so we'll write
a console.log
output fine now we already know the
output for this piece of code right the
output will be true that's obvious
because we have the word welcome present
in our string not once but twice the
output will remain true if we remove the
first welcome from this string let's do
it here let's save the program first and
then we'll move to the console
and you can see here the output says
true for the word welcome present in the
string str1 that's true right and now if
we remove this welcome word from here
and if we save it you can see the output
Still Remains true because we have
another welcome word present in the
string right
so this is how the test function
actually works we will put the welcome
word here again we already know the
functioning of this test function the
main point of discussion here is the
meta characters
So Meta characters are characters with
special meanings
like the dot character if we write this
regular expression like we can remove
any one character from this word and put
a dot in its place let's do it we'll
remove a random character and write dot
here so let's say we are removing
L fine and instead of L we are putting a
DOT here
now the dot character here will replace
this character and the system will not
through any error it will still find the
word we can also use exact function here
to check the index number of the word so
what we'll do is we'll take another
variable and we'll do the same we'll
write here regex Dot
exec
and then we'll pass the string name as
parameters
fine
we will copy this console.log from here
and we'll paste it here
the variable name is op
save it and here you can see we have the
output as true for the test function and
for the exact function it Returns the
index number 0 of the word in the string
now the system automatically puts a l in
place of the dot character similarly if
you want to do the same thing for more
than one character we have another meta
character for that it's not that we
can't use this dot operator but we can
use it for a limited time like we can
use it for a single character but if we
want to put more than one character and
we don't know the number of the
characters so then we have another meta
character for that the meta character is
asterisk now this asterisk allows us to
put multiple characters within a
particular expression for example if we
write here
let's remove all this and we'll put star
or asterisk in place of all the
characters in between so save it and you
can see the output returns true for
test function and for the exact function
the index is 0. now if we write here
something like that
and we don't know what it is but let's
assume it so if we save it now you can
still see the output returns true for
this as well because now we can put any
number of characters in between W and E
the only thing that matters is the first
and the last character of the word
welcome
now the next character we'll be looking
at does not work the same way as these
characters the carrot character works
upon a whole string let's go through the
syntax and what we'll do is
we'll remove this unwanted piece of code
and then we'll come here we'll write
here
welcome again
and now we'll put this carrot character
now the carrot character is this
character so what this character returns
is this character returns true only if
the whole string starts with the word
welcome the second welcome word does not
even exist for this meta character if we
save this program now it will return
true because welcome is present at the
start of this string right so save it
and you can see the output is true
now if we remove this welcome from here
and if we save this program now we know
that we have another welcome present in
the string but this character does not
work that way and it will return false
because the string starts with 2 now
right
save it and here you can see the output
is false for test function and for exact
function the output is null it will not
return any index number of the second
welcome or some sort of thing so this is
how the carrot character works in
JavaScript
the next meta character does the same
thing but for the end of the string the
symbol is dollar and it checks for the
end part of this string this meta
character is placed at the end of a
regular expression and it checks if the
string ends with characters present in
the expression the syntax goes like this
what we'll do is we'll remove this
carrot character and we'll put a dollar
sign you now this statement now will
check if the string ends with the word
welcome or not in this case the last
word of the string is back right not
welcome so the output will be false save
it
save it and you can see here the output
is false null suppose we write here back
in place of welcome now what we'll do is
we'll write here
back in place of welcome and if we save
this program now the output will change
to true because back is the last word
present in a string right so this
character checks for the end of the
string save it and you can see the
output is changed to true and the index
number is 32. find the exact function
will return the index number of the word
back the last meta character we will
discuss in this video is the optional
meta character the question mark symbol
represents this meta character and the
functioning be like any character before
this symbol is treated as optional this
means that it doesn't matter if the
character is present in the string or
not for example if we write here let's
say
will right here welcome again because
welcome has more characters than back
and we'll write here welcome as well
fine
now let's make some changes in this
particular regex expression so what
we'll do is we'll put a question mark
here and let's say we'll put another
question mark here fine now if we remove
c and e from the string or any one of
them then also the function will work
fine and the output will be 2. let's do
it and what we'll do is we'll make some
changes in this particular string and we
are going to remove some characters from
this string so we have two welcome words
here and what we'll do is we'll remove C
from this one and we have two optional
characters right both c and e are
optional but for now we are removing C
only so the string looks like this we
have the word Vellum it doesn't mean
anything but for understanding purposes
we have done it so save it and you can
see the output remains true for vellum
now what if we put any other word in
place of this character
let's say we are writing here B
fine
the output will change we have to put an
OS because o is not an optional
character
now the output
will change
as we were discussing if we save this
program you can see it is true for now
but it is saying true because of this
welcome now if we remove this welcome
from here and if we save it now you can
see the output is changed to null
yes these characters are optional but we
can't put any character in place of them
we have two options only either we can
put C in its place or we can leave it so
there's no other option with the
optional characters so these are the few
meta characters present in regular
Expressions which helps in validation a
lot we came across meta characters in
regex in the previous video where we saw
how to check the availability of a
particular word or expression within a
string we know about functions as well
so today we will combine all these
things to some extent and we'll see how
basic validation actually works in
JavaScript
we'll see an example wherein we'll go
through the character sets and ranges
and check for some specific type of
validation in this video
now the topic character sets and ranges
itself is a pretty explanatory topic and
we can get an idea of what's coming just
by going through the words characters in
layman term refers to alphabets and
numbers right we see a character on a
daily basis and we know a lot about them
now if I write here a we can say that
this is a character in JavaScript now we
can use one single character or a group
of characters at a time with regular
expressions in JavaScript we have a
particular Syntax for it we'll go
through the syntax first and the syntax
is like we have to use square brackets
and we have to write characters in
between these brackets or inside these
brackets
here we have three characters a b and c
what we can do is we can give
instructions to the system to use any
one of them in a regular expression so
let's take a small example of how this
actually works with regular expressions
and what we'll do is we'll do the same
thing we have been doing till now we'll
search a word within a string we'll
check that if a word exists within a
string or not so we'll do it like we'll
take a variable regex that will contain
the regular expression so this is the
Syntax for regular expression and this
is our regular expression which says d e
f so in actual this is not a word but
assume it as a word for now and what we
have to do is we have to include
character sets with this regular
expression right so we'll write here
inside square brackets ABC
now the next thing is we will Define the
string let's say the string name is tr1
and the string says
this
string contains adef so d e f or we can
say adef is what matters the most for
now so anything else you can write on
the string the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the test
function to check if this particular
regular expression is available in the
string or not so we'll write here regex
DOT test and inside this will pass the
string as a parameter
now the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log and we'll print
this on our console fine
we are done with it so what we are doing
here is we want to search the string for
a word which contains the letter d e f
compulsory but before def we can have a
character that character can either be a
b or c no other character will be taken
in front of Def because we have defined
a character set as well right and that
character set contains only three
characters a b and c so here you can see
we have adef present in the string and
we have a along with def so what we are
expecting is this test function should
return true right so save it and check
for the output in the console so we will
go to our console
and here you can see the output says
true because we have a def only
now if we write here anything else like
if we replace this a with the character
R save it and you can see the output is
false because R is not present inside
this character set now what if we write
here something like
let's say we are writing here
kaushal def now this will check for this
letter only for this L only other
letters don't actually matters in this
case in the case of character sets the
only character that matters is the
character right before the regular
expression so if we save it you can see
the output is changed to false and if we
write here let's say
kaushal adef save it and you can see the
output is true because it checks for
this character only fine
talking about ranges let's say we want
to add any character in the string
between a to z now we have two options
to do so first one is we can write a b c
till z here like we'll write here d e f
g h i and so on and so forth till that
but this task is a little bit lengthy
right and we have to spend a lot of time
in that process so the alternate to this
process is to define a range of
characters
to define a range of characters it's
quite an easy task all you have to do is
write a hyphen Z so this is how you can
define a range of characters now this
range will consist every character from
a till z a and z will also be included
keep this thing in mind if we write here
causal DF again so we have seen in in
the previous example that it returned
false for this right save it now and you
can see the output is still true that's
because now we have a range from a till
z if we write here 5 now now it will
return false because 5 does not lies in
between this range in between A to Z so
it will return true for any character
between a till z fine
now let's say we want to exclude some
particular characters from this range
like we don't want the user to include
def again no character from d e or F so
the Syntax for that is also pretty easy
we have to use the carrot operator and
we have to write here but we don't want
to include so let's say in this case we
don't want to include d e f fine so if
we write here d d e f now and save it
you can see
it will return false because we have
included ddef and if we write a adef
save it and you can see the output is
true now we can't include characters d e
and f in front of this regular
expression because we have defined this
character set to not include these
characters in the regular expression
so these are characters and ranges in
regular Expressions so the next thing
we'll be doing is we'll be going through
a basic validation example and we'll see
how actually basic validation Works in
JavaScript what we'll do is we'll create
a small HTML form that will take the
employee ID from the user and it will
check if the employee belongs to the
organization or not so let's say the
employee ID of the organization has some
unique characters present in it and the
character remains there in each employee
ID
the idea is simple we'll take the ID
from the user and we'll use if else
control statement to check if it belongs
to the organization or not so let's move
on to the HTML file and we'll create a
placeholder and a button so let's do it
we'll write here
form and inside this form tag let input
ID is equals to
Eid
and
placeholder is equals to
employee ID
and type is equals to
text fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to include a button as well
button and we are going to call a
function on clicking so we'll use the on
click event so we'll write your own
click and let's say the function name is
employee
and the button name is let's say submit
save it and you can see over the browser
that we have a placeholder along with
the button so let me give a space here
save it now and you can see we have a
placeholder and a button so that's all
what we have to do in HTML part now the
rest of the thing we'll be doing in the
Javascript file so let's move to a
Javascript file
and comment this piece of code first
now what we want is we want to call a
function employee on clicking the submit
button fine so what we'll do is we'll
Define a function employee
and inside the body of this function the
first thing we will be doing is we'll be
taking
the user's ID right so we need a
variable for that so let's say the
variable is
and we'll write here
document Dot
get element by ID the ID is
Eid
Dot value fine now this amp ID variable
will hold the value entered by the user
right so like if we write here something
like d two three eight six so let's say
this is the ID this will be stored the
value for this ID will be stored inside
this mpid variable fine
now we'll use the regular expression to
check for some special characters so we
will write here
inside the function we'll write here
where
check is equals to
inside the regular expression we'll
write something so let's say we want to
start the employee ID for the
development team with the alphabets D
and D
and each ID will have a similar numeric
code like 253 which represents the code
for a particular team fine so we'll
right here inside the character sets we
want d e to be there before a similar
numeric code right so
253 is the numeric code and we want to
include either D or e
before that right
and after 253 let's say we have a range
of numbers that each employee ID has a
unique two digit number the ID should
look like
either d 2 5 3
1 1 or either
e
6 1
something like that right
now so for that what we have to do is we
have to include here another range and
this range will be from 11 oh sorry this
range will be from 10 till 99. fine
this looks a bit complex now but if you
try to do it by yourself believe me guys
you'll find it out that this is an easy
task but a little lengthy we can see now
the next part is we have to validate the
ID entered for that we have to use the
if Health control statement along with
the test function
so we have to write here
if check DOT test and inside this we'll
write
amp ID because amp ID is the variable
which is holding the value entered by
the user right so if it's true then it
will return
an alert box with the message that says
valid
employee ID fine else
it will
return a message in the pop-up which
will say
invalid
ID fine so this if else statement will
check the value returned by the test
function if the value returned is true
it will return a message valid employee
ID otherwise the else statement will run
and the user will get a pop-up with the
message invalid email ID fine
let's check the output and in the
browser here we'll write the employee ID
in the
given placeholder so let's say the
employee ID is d
two five three
one nine
submit it and you can see it says valid
employee ID we can do it for some more
like if we write here e
submit it and you can see it still says
valid employee ID now what if we want to
include any character between this range
and the unique number right so let's try
to do it we'll write it
d253 K 89 fine so let's say this is the
ID we want to enter submit it and you
can see it says invalid employee ID fine
now one more thing we want to do here is
like if we write here
d253
okay eight nine in this case it will
return false or invalid employee ID why
because we haven't included any modifier
here and it will differentiate between
uppercase and lowercase character so to
overcome this problem what we can do is
we can include the in case sensitive
modifier and we are clearly good to now
if we write here d25398
and save it if we write here now d
two five three nine eight
submit it and you can see here the
output says valid employee ID
so this is how we can use validation
along with regular expressions in the
last video we came across character sets
and ranges we saw how we could use them
with regular expressions and we also saw
how to validate a user's input with the
help of character sets and ranges along
with regular Expressions now in this
video we'll look at the shorthand
character classes present within regular
expressions and we'll see how they are
helpful in JavaScript
if you guys remember the regular
expression we used became a bit
confusing and lengthy because we have
used so many ranges and character sets
all in one right a character class can
be used to overcome this particular
problem and we have several character
classes present in JavaScript so today
we will go through them in this
particular video now the syntax is not
too much complicated all we have to do
is to write a single character with a
backslash and we are good too for
example if we go to a Javascript file
and if we write here
backslash D now if we write this
character before any regular expression
in JavaScript it means that we have
added a character class to a regular
expression this backslash D is a
character class used for finding a digit
within a string let's go through an
example for this character class
and we'll do the same thing we'll take a
string and try to find a regular
expression within that string so what
we'll do is
will write here
where
regex is equals to and here we'll write
a regular expression first we'll take up
a string and use some functions to check
the output so let's do it here what
we'll do is we'll take another variable
let's say the variable name is str1 and
the strings is users
phone number is
nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero now let's say this is the
string we are using for today's program
the next thing we'll do is we'll use the
exact function to find the regular
expression within the string so we have
already gone through this exact function
in JavaScript today we'll use that
function only now we'll write here where
output is equals to
regex dot exec and inside this will pass
a string as a parameter the next thing
we will do is we'll write here console
Dot Lock
and we'll print this output on a console
now we are good to go so we are done
with it and the next thing we want to do
is to find a particular pattern along
with the number present before that
pattern in the string so let's suppose
if we write here inside these slashes if
we write here let's say three to one now
this statement here ask the computer to
find a pattern three to one in this
string
save it
and go to the console so we'll move to
our browser and we'll press Ctrl shift
plus I and here you can see we have a
console here and here we have an array
as well so here you can see it says
let me Zoom it out a bit here you can
see it says
three to one is present at index 28.
now the system finds out that this
particular string or this particular
regular expression is present here in
the string add index number 28 obviously
the indexes will start from 0 and the
moment it will find this three to one
regular expression it will show the
index number in an array in a console
now if we add backslash D here let's say
we are adding here backslash D in front
of this expression and check the output
here save it you will notice that we
have a number present here right before
that expression right we have 4 3 2 1
here instead of just three to one the
output here gives us the number four
this means that this backslash D
represents this number 4 in this string
now what if we put an alphabet before
this expression now let's do it what
we'll do is we'll write here a and let
us say we are adding only a single
alphabet here let's say we are adding a
before 3 to 1. now the expected output
is A3 to 1 but the moment we'll save it
you can see it says null that's because
this particular character class works
for digits only if it finds anything
other than a numeric digit it will
return an error or it will return null
in that case now if you want to find all
the numbers before this pattern then we
have to add a plus operator in the
regular expression all we have to do is
we have to write here plus and we are
good to now it will return everything
until it finds a space or any character
other than a digit now let's suppose if
you are writing here a after 987
now this particular statement will
return all the numbers till 6. the
moment it will encounter a here it will
return all the numbers after a it will
stop at a and it will not go further now
save it and you can see it says 654321
that's because this backslash D works
for digits only now if we write here
nothing like we have a number
9876543210 save it and it will return
the whole number nine eight seven six
five four three two one not zero because
we haven't included any number here
now if we write here again backslash D
after this as well save it and here you
can see we have the output as 0 as well
we have the whole number here fine so
this is how this backslash D actually
works in JavaScript so this is a
character class
now the next thing is what if we want to
find a non-digit character before a
particular pattern
if we write here
before three to one let's say we are
writing here a and we want the system to
return the non-digit character before 3
to 1. in that case we use capital D
instead of small D always remember guys
every shorthand character class in regex
have an inverse that does precisely the
opposite of that particular class like
if we have small D here that works for
digits only we also have an inverse
which is denoted by backslash capital D
and it is exactly opposite of this small
D here now if we write here
capital D in place of small D what will
happen is it will return the character
here it will return true for everything
other than a digit now if we remove this
small D from here and save it
here you can see it says null because we
haven't included the backslash sign here
save it
and here you can see it says a321 it
will return true for anything except for
a digit even if we put a symbol over
here then also it will return the output
s true for example if we write here
let's say we are including dollar sign
here let's say we are including two
dollar sign here save it and it will
return two dollar signs that's because
we are using the plus operator here
obviously let's include as many signs as
we can
save it and here you can see we have all
the symbols present over here on our
output so this is how capital D
character class works or we can say
inverse character class of small D this
is how it works
now the next class we'll be going
through is the Wordly character denoted
by the letter W small W and is used in
place of any character that can be an
alphabet a number or an unders cosine we
can use this character over D if we are
unsure about the character present
before the pattern for example if we
write here
let's say backslash w
ER
now here we have used the ber pattern
which is present at the end of number
right here ber is present at the end of
number now this statement will return M
only because we are not using any plus
operator here if we use any plus
operator then it will return the whole
number because it will return everything
until it encounters a space or something
like that so for now we are not using
any plus operators who will be writing
here this only now here it will return M
because it can take up a number an
alphabet or an underscore sign it will
return false if it finds any space or
something other than these three these
three means a number an alphabet or an
underscore sign fine
now save it and you can see on the
console that the output says mper let me
Zoom it a bit so here you can see the
output says mber right present at index
14.
it will return null if we put a space
before the pattern like if we write here
a new m space ber save it you can see it
says null for this now we can use the
plus operator as well here for this
particular character class now what will
happen is it will return every character
present before the pattern until it
encounters a space or something like a
symbol or any sort of thing so let's try
it what we'll do is we'll write here w
plus ber and we'll remove this space
from here
save it and here you can see it says
number what if we remove this space from
you remove it save it and here you can
see it says phone number it will return
every character before the pattern until
it finds any space or any other let's
say symbol so let's say we are including
here dollar percentage and carrot sign
save it and here you can see it says an
e number so it's returning it from here
because it will not return true for any
of the symbols here save it and here you
can see we have the output as phone
number again so that's working totally
fine
like the inverse character class for
digits we have the inverse character
class for this also and it returns true
for everything other than an alphabet
number or any underscore sign now if we
write here
instead of small W let's say we are
writing here capital w
and let's do something with this string
as well so let's put a space here again
and we are good to go we are not doing
anything more than that so it will
return null because before ber we have M
here right if we remove this m with a
sign let's say if you are removing this
with a dollar sign or with an empty one
like we are writing here space nothing
then it will return the index number and
the pattern
so let's do it save it and here you can
see it says dollar then it says ber and
index number is 14. you can count the
index number so 0 for U and then
similarly one for S two for E3 for r
four four S up to 14 for dollar so
dollar is present at index 14. it will
return the index number here now the
plus operator also works for this
inverse character class as well right
here plus ber and we can insert as many
characters or as many symbols as we want
so like here we have inserted so many
symbols this doesn't mean anything but
we are inserting them for example
purposes or for practical purpose so
save it and here you can see we have all
the symbols present over here in a array
and the index number is still 14. if we
remove these n and U from here now save
it the index number will change to 11.
that's quite easy
now
the next class we have is the simplest
of all this class works for white spaces
only it means that it will return true
or give us the index number of the
expression from the string only if a
white space exists before the pattern
it is denoted by small s and works for
spaces only now if we write here
let's say
backslash s
okay we have made a mistake we'll write
a backslashes and we'll write here phone
so this is the pattern and this is the
character class backslash s is the
character class now what we'll do is
we'll remove it from here and we'll
write the string as this again we'll
write a user's phone number is this and
this
now for this regular expression it will
return the index number of this space
the space is present at index 5. 0 for U
1 for S 2 for e 3 for R 4 for S and this
space is present at index number five so
it will return index as 5 for this
particular space now don't get confused
guys for this index number as 5 the
index number is for the space present in
the screen before the pattern phone
right now if we try to do the same for
users as well let's suppose if we write
here
users it will return null in this case
because there's no space present before
users in the string right save it and
here you can see the output says null in
this case
fine
now we can also use the plus operator
here for more than one spaces present in
the string it will return all the spaces
until it finds a character or something
other than the species like if it finds
any symbol or any character then only it
will return false otherwise for spaces
it will return true so if we write here
too many spaces if we put too many
spaces before the word phone or let's
say we are changing this word to
phone
save it and here you can see we have all
the spaces here it's denoted by a single
space but the index numbers is changed
to 19. now we have so many spaces
present here before the
pattern phone or before the word phone
so this is how we can use
space character class in JavaScript
now we have also the inverse class for
this character class as well it returns
true for everything other than empty
spaces if we write here
let's say we are removing this and let's
say we are right okay and let's say we
are
writing here users
and we are
giving so many spaces here before the
word uses now it will return null in
this case because there are spaces
present in front of the word users
if we include a character or something
in front of this world then only the
output will change and return the index
number along with the string so save it
first and here you can see
okay we have used the smallest in place
of smallest we'll write here capital S
save it and you can see here the output
says null for capital S because this
capital S will return true for
everything other than spaces only now if
we put here any symbol let's say we have
these symbols here
save it and here you can see now we have
a hash symbol present before the word
users that's because we have used
capital S only now if we use a plus
operator save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present in a array
we have the index number as 11 we have
dollar percentage carrot and hash
present over here right so this is how
the inverse of character spaces in
JavaScript actually work so these are
the character classes we have in
JavaScript if you guys see we have two
text boxes over here one is for the
username and the other one is for the
password creating such text boxes in
HTML is quite an easy task we have to
use the input tag which we discussed a
few sessions back and we are using some
more properties here so you can see we
have type as text for username and for
password the type is password
so before we move on to validation with
JavaScript let me tell you guys that we
can do certain things with HTML as well
like if we want that none of the two
text boxes over here remains blank we
can write here inside these input tags
so if we write here
required
save it and now if you try to click on
the submit button you can see it says
please fill out this field it will not
allow the user to submit the form until
there is any value present for the name
so if we write here any random name and
submit it now you can see the form is
getting refreshed that's because we have
used the form tag over here now if we
try to submit without writing anything
we'll get the pop-up as please fill out
this field and we can do the same for
password as well like if we write here
required and save it now if you write
any name over here for the username and
if you leave this password field blank
submit it you can see it says please
fill out this field for password as well
so HTML can let you do all this stuff
but when it comes to actual validation
like if you want the user to enter only
if the name or password matches the one
present in the backend or maybe we can
say in the server we have to use
something more than HTML now the case
with JavaScript is a bit different if we
talk about validation in JavaScript we
can use JavaScript for client-side
verification the scenario here will be
the one we'll discuss in today's video
what we'll do today is we'll create a
basic sign up form with three text boxes
one is for the username the other one is
for the password and will add one more
box for each half of the work is already
done and we have to add one more box now
for the age so age is just a number
right so we can add a text box over here
what we have to do is we have to write
here before this submit button we'll
write a input
type is equals to number
and we'll provide it the ID as well so
let's say the ID is each we'll use the
ID attribute later and inside this
placeholder we'll write here each
save it and here you can see we have
three text boxes over here inside the H
we can't write any
character or alphabet because we have
defined the type as number for this so
we can write numbers here only now the
next part is to link this page to
another web page such that if the
credentials are correct the user will
enter the home page of a website for
that we have to use the action attribute
in HTML now the question here is when do
we want the user to enter the home page
only if the credentials are correct
right we have to use the action
attribute with the form tag so you can
see over here we have already mentioned
the form tag now what we'll do is we'll
write here action and what we want is we
wanted to redirect the user to another
page or another web page the home page
of our website after checking the
credentials and if the credentials are
correct the user will move on to the
home page so we have already a file
named homepage.html
so we'll write here homepage.html and
save it now on clicking the submit
button okay we have to fill something
for name and for password as well so
we'll write random values over here
submit it and you can see we have been
redirected to another page and this is
the home page of our website however it
doesn't look like a home page still we
can assume it right so now we know what
should be done if the user has correct
credentials to enter the home page we
are almost done with the HTML part we'll
make some more changes to this file
later the next thing we have to do is to
validate the credentials entered by the
user right for validation purposes we'll
use the if else control statements in a
Javascript file we'll create a function
in a Javascript file and call that
function when the user clicks the submit
button but there is a difference will
not call the function on clicking the
submit button instead we'll call the
function on submission of the form so
instead of writing here on click and
then calling that function what we'll do
is we'll write here inside the form tag
we'll write on submit so this is an
event and on submit what will happen is
it will call a function named validate
we'll create this validate function in
our Javascript file now so you can see
here we have already used the ID
attribute with all the input tags in
order to get the values entered by the
user so let's move on to the Javascript
file and what we'll do here is we'll
first declare a function named validate
so we'll write here function
and the function name is
validate
and then we have the body of this
function
now we'll take three variables to get
all the values entered by the user
because we need to check for all the
values right so we need to check if the
user's name and password match the one
we want and the user should be aged
above 13 to enter a website
for all these we need the values entered
by the user so we'll use the get element
by ID method to get all the values now
for that we'll take three variables so
let's say the first variable is U name
it will hold the value entered in the
username text box let me go to the form
again and here you can see we have three
text boxes username password H so we'll
take three variables for username we'll
write here document Dot get element by
ID and the ID is you name let me confirm
it once so you can see here the ID for
username is Union
for password it is pass and for each
it's each so we'll write here Dot value
the next thing we'll do is we'll create
another variable for password we'll
write here again document Dot
get element by ID and the ID is pass
will again write here dot value
and the third variable will be where
each
it will hold the edge of the user
so we'll again write a document dot get
element by ID and the ID for ages each
we'll again use the dot value property
now we are done with the values we have
three variables holding all the values
entered by the user next up we'll use
these values to validate the data
entered by the user now the first
condition we can have here is that we
don't want the user to leave any of the
text boxes empty right
if we click on this submit button you
can see it says please fill out this
field now we can do it with the help of
HTML as well but for now we are using
JavaScript so we will remove this
required keywords
so that we can do it with JavaScript
only
save it
and submit it now you can see it is
redirecting us to the home page of our
website so it's working totally fine now
what we'll do is we'll write a condition
if the user leaves any of these fields
empty so we'll write if
U name is equals to is equals to blank
or
pass is equals to is equals to blank
okay pass is equals to is equals to
blank or h
is equals to is equals to
blank
now what will happen is it will give the
user a pop-up with the message let's say
the message is
missing
credentials why
save it
and if we leave any of these fields
empty now a pop-up will appear with the
message missing credentials so the first
condition is done but there's a loophole
in this condition so let's check it out
first we'll leave username and password
empty submitted you can see it says
missing credentials right now the next
thing is if we write here let's say a
random name and password as well but we
are leaving this age text box empty
submit it it still says missing
credentials because we haven't entered
the age and it's working totally fine
now there's a loophole in this condition
the exciting part is it will work fine
if the user enters more than one space
in all the fields like
if you are giving here spaces for more
than once and similarly for password as
well submit it and you can see it says
missing credentials because we haven't
filled each so let's
do one thing we'll
write some spaces for username and
password and for each we'll say the age
is 4 submit it and you can see we have
no error over here now to overcome this
problem we have a predefined JavaScript
method that treats all the spaces the
same no matter the number of spaces
whether it be one or more than one it
will treat all the same we have to
include the trim method within the if
else statement so what we'll do is we'll
write here dot trim
for username and similarly for password
as well we'll write here trim
and for age as well let's say
dot trim
and save it now move back to our signup
form and if we try to give more than one
spaces here
and let's say the age is four submit it
you can see it says missing credentials
for more than one species as well so
this is working totally fine now the
following condition will be for
validating the name let's say the
required name is kaushal or anything
else
the required password is let's say one
two three four five and the age should
be more than 30. then only the user can
enter the website so for that we have to
use the else if statement and what we'll
do is we'll write here
else if and inside this will give our
conditions so let's say the conditions
are you name
is equals to is equals to caution
and
pause is equals to is equals to one two
three four five
and
age
should be
greater than or is equals to
13. then
it will give the user a pop-up and which
states that will write here alert
will write here
sign up successfully
fine
save it
now the user can enter the website with
these credentials only otherwise a
pop-up will appear
so let's give the else condition as well
what we'll do is we'll write here else
and we'll use another alert inside this
will write
ROM ID and
password
fine
now we have all the conditions here save
it and now we'll check for different
inputs so let's move it to a form and
what we'll do is we'll write the
username is let's say Ravi
and the password is let's say any random
numbers and age is let's say six submit
it and you can see it says wrong ID and
password now what we'll do is we'll give
it the correct credentials we'll write
here
caution and the password will be one two
three four five
and the age is let's say 21 fine the H
should be greater than or equals to 13
so submit it and you can see it says
sign up successful
now we have different conditions over
here like if we write here any random
name and if we write here any random
password now it will return wrong ID and
password but if we write here correct ID
and password and
correct username as well let's say we
are writing here kaushal and let's say
the age will change to
11. submit it and you can see it still
says wrong ID and password we can add
one more condition over here like we'll
write here else if age is less than 12
it will give an alert that you are
underaged or some sort of that so we'll
write here else if
each
is less than 30
an alert
which states under aged fine
save it
and what we'll do is we'll move back to
our form and we'll write a causal
password is one two three four five and
age is let's say
11. submit it and you can see it says
under East now so it is working totally
fine now one thing that seems a bit
irritating as well is it redirects us to
the home page every time right it
doesn't matter if the credentials are
correct or not it redirects to overcome
this issue we have to make some minor
changes in the HTML file and include the
return keyword in a if else conditional
statements so let's go back to our HTML
file and what we'll do is we'll write
here inside the form tag now we have on
submit over here so what we'll do is
we'll write return
before validate so save it and we'll
move back to a JavaScript file
now this return keyword will let the
form perform any action only if the
value returned by the function validate
is true otherwise it will not allow the
form tag
to perform any action the action here is
redirecting the user to the home page
right so let's do it here we know that
the function should return true only if
all the credentials are valid so we'll
write here
for all other
conditions we'll write
return
false
fine for this one we'll write
return true because this is the
condition when all the credentials are
correct and for all other conditions
we'll write return
false similarly for else as well we'll
write here
return false
now save it and we'll move back to sign
up form
save the HTML file as well once
and what we'll do is we'll write a
causal password is one two three and age
is let's say 4 submit it you can see it
says underaged click on OK and now it is
not redirecting us to the home page
right now if the credentials are correct
what we'll do is we'll write here the
password is one two three four five and
the age is let's say
submit it now you can see it says sign
up successful click on OK and you can
see we are in the home page it is
working totally fine
so if all the credentials are valid then
it is redirecting us to the home page
exactly what we wanted so these are the
basics of validation in JavaScript
obviously we can't validate a form with
JavaScript in the real world because we
don't have to deal with one user only we
need the backend to do all the
validation and all but simple validation
can be done with the help of JavaScript
we did it just now
we have many things to do with
validation in JavaScript like adding
some more conditions or using regular
Expressions to validate forms in
JavaScript using regular expressions for
validation in JavaScript is what we
already saw in the previous videos
you can see we have an image slider over
here the images present inside this box
keep on changing we can also click on
these radio buttons to go over a
specific image if we click on this last
radio button you can see we are moving
to that particular image now suppose you
go through the home page of any website
like Amazon or Flipkart you will notice
that these websites contain such image
sliders at the top for different type of
sales and offers going on right that
looks quite nice so we'll do something
interesting in today's video we'll go
over some specific animations like
fading of an image on several events
we'll see how easy it is to make those
style changes in JavaScript which we
can't do with CSS or HTML we are
particularly talking about style changes
during events so talking about style
changes we have done it in the past
using CSS and HTML and JavaScript of
course so guys we generally say that
JavaScript is you used to make a web
page more interactive right to make a
web page more interactive or engaging we
have to do something nice to it so
adding fade in and Fade Out animations
to a picture makes the web page more
engaging to the user so what we'll do
today is we'll take an image and use
specific JavaScript properties to make
changes in that image let's move on to
the vs code and you will understand it
much better
now let's add an image to the web page
first so we have a picture on a computer
and we'll add it so what we'll do is
we'll write here IMG SRC Source will be
HTML dot PNG and the next thing will be
using the alt attribute we'll write here
let's say JavaScript so we can take any
random image we are doing this for
experimental purpose only so what we'll
do next is we'll close this IMG tag
we'll save it and here you can see we
have an image over here we'll reduce the
size
and so this is the perfect size I guess
now what we'll do next is we'll use the
ID attribute as well because we need to
access this particular image so let's
say the ID is IMG fine now here we have
an image and we have two possibilities
to perform those animations either we
can add two buttons and add
functionality to them or we can use the
on Mouse over and on Mouse out events so
we'll use two buttons for now and then
we'll use the on Mouse over and on Mouse
out events to do the same task
now let's add two buttons here what
we'll do is we'll write here input
type is equals to button
and then we'll write here value value
will be let's say
fade in for first button and we'll use
the on click event fine so we'll write
here on click and we'll call a function
on clicking this particular button so
this will be a function name fade in now
we'll do similar thing again
we'll copy paste it and we'll change
certain values here we'll write a fade
out and we'll call a different function
so we'll write here fade out fine
now save it and you can see we have two
buttons over here fade in and Fade Out
so nothing is happening on clicking over
these buttons we can change the size of
this image using CSS right so we'll use
CSS here only we'll write here
class is equals to let's say size
and
we'll use the style tag here
we'll write here Dot
size and inside this will
right width is equals to
50 pixels let's say
and the height will be
50 pixels as well fine save it and you
can see the images
pretty small right now so what we'll do
is we'll write here 250 instead of 50.
save it now and you can see it's working
fine I guess
the size is decent let's change it to
300.
fine
so we have to keep these things in mind
like what size we want for our image and
we can use CSS for that right that's
quite easy what we did is we defined the
class we use the class attribute here
inside the IMG tag and we have defined
it using the style tag over here we are
not using any separate CSS file for that
so save it and you can see we have a
image over here with decent size and
then we have two buttons fade in and
Fade Out now the next task for us is to
add functionality to these buttons we'll
move on to the Javascript file and
create our functions there so this is
our Javascript file we will create a
function here let's say the function
name is fading so this is the first
function and then we have the body of
this function now the next thing is to
use this style property to fade this
image let's talk about it in detail we
need to access this image right so we'll
use the document.getelement by ID method
to access the image we have already used
the ID attribute in the HTML file so
what we'll do here is we'll write here
document dot get element by ID
and the ID is
IMG fine now we have to use the style
property the style property is used to
add styling to any particular element or
event with the help of JavaScript we can
do it with CSS but we want to add
styling as a functionality right this
means that we want to style our element
or image by clicking a button for that
we have to use the style property here
in our Javascript file so we'll write
Here style now the next and the last
thing is fading the image now we have a
term named opacity in programming
opacity refers to the fact of being
opaque in programming if the value of
opacity is 1 then we can't see through
the image like making an image
transparent and if the value is 0 we can
see through that image or we can say
that the image will totally disappear if
the value is zero so let's try it out
here
and you will understand it so what we'll
do is we'll write Here style dot opacity
is equals to
zero now save it and click on this fade
in button click on this fade in button
and you can see the image disappears by
clicking the fade in bit now we'll add
functionality to this Fade Out button as
well for that what we have to do is we
have to create another function here so
the function name will be
Fade Out
and then we have the body of this
function the working will remain the
same we'll again use the
document.getelement by ID method
we'll again use the IMG as ID we'll
write here dot style Dot
opacity now what we want is we want to
bring back our image right so we'll
write here one now here the values are 0
and 1 respectively for fade in and Fade
Out functions let's check the output
here save it
click on this fade in button and you can
see the image totally disappears and on
clicking the Fade Out button you can see
the image is here again now to actually
make the image a slight feed
let's say we don't want the image to be
disappeared completely what we want is a
slight feed in our image now what we
have to do is we have to choose a value
between 0 and 1 like for zero it totally
disappears right if we write here 0.5
save it now and click on fade in you can
see the image Fades slightly so this is
how we can use the fade in and Fade Out
animations in JavaScript and it will be
totally fine if we write here 0.1 as
well save it and if you click on this
fade in button you can see we have this
image over here still but we can say
it's almost transparent or disappearing
you can see it's over here maybe it's
visible or maybe not but if you write
here 0.3 or something like that and now
click on this fade in button you can see
we can see this image but the image is
faded right so this is how we can use
the fade in and Fade Out animations in
JavaScript now we can do the same thing
using on Mouse over and on Mouse out
events in JavaScript we have to make
some more minor changes in our HTML file
only instead of using these buttons
we'll use the on Mouse over and on Mouse
out events inside the IMG tag so what
we'll do is let's do it as well
we'll move to our HTML file and we'll
comment these two lines so we are done
with it now the next thing we'll do is
we'll use the on Mouse over and on Mouse
out event right so we'll write here on
Mouse over first
and we'll call the fade in function on
taking the mouse cursor over the image
and the second event will be on Mouse
out
so we'll write here on Mouse out and
we'll call the Fade Out function fine on
taking the mouse cursor away from the
image save it and you can see we don't
have any buttons over here now now on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
you can see the image Fades a bit and on
taking the mouse cursor away from the
image you can see we have the original
image here so this is how we can make
feed in and Fade Out animations work in
JavaScript
you might hear that browsers do not
support this method of using fade in and
Fade Out animations in JavaScript in my
case I have checked with three four
different browsers like Microsoft Edge
Firefox Chrome and Internet Explorer so
it is working totally fine I want you
guys to check if it is working or not
with the browsers you have on your
computer if not then do let us know in
the comments and we'll figure it out
make sure that you have the latest
version of whichever browser you are
using the fade in and Fade Out effect in
JavaScript was easy to use all we have
to do is to use the style property with
opacity in between 0 and 1. quite a
simple task right now in this video
we'll see another animation effect in
which we'll change the size of an image
by hovering over that we see such
animations in many e-commerce websites
where if we take the mouse cursor over
any product the size increases so let's
do it here it's a simple task we'll add
an image to a HTML file first so we'll
write here
IMG and the source will be we have an
image named as
coffee dot PNG in a system and then we
have the ID attribute the ID will be
let's say IMG and then we'll use the alt
attribute here we'll write here
coffee let's assume that this is a
product of any e-commerce website and we
want to increase the size of this
product on hovering over that so the
next thing we'll be doing here is we'll
be defining the width so let's say the
width will be 200 pixel for this
particular image and then we'll use
certain events here so we'll use the on
Mouse over so on taking the master
server we want to increase the size of
this image right and on taking the mouse
cursor away we want to decrease the size
right
so we have used these two functions
we'll Define these functions in a
Javascript file so we are done with this
IMG tag save it and you can see we have
an image over here in a browser so we
are done with it we have the default
size of this image as 200 pixels we can
change it here we can make it 300 or 400
or any size we want so you can see the
image size change if we write here 300
instead of 200 so for now we'll be using
200 that's fine I guess
so what we want is we want to increase
the size of this image by taking the
mouse cursor over it right and the size
will be back to normal if we take the
cursor away from the image so for that
we have to Define these two functions
increase and decrease so let's define
them in a Javascript file what we'll do
is we'll first write here function and
we'll Define function increase
then we have the body of this function
and we'll write here
document dot get element by ID the ID is
IMG
and we'll write here dots tile Dot
width is equals to we can't write here
400 pixels simply it will throw an error
you can see a red line over here so what
we have to do is we have to write this
inside single inverted commas right save
it and on taking the mouse cursor over
the image you can see the image size
increases but it's not getting back to
its original size because we haven't
declared the decrease function yet let's
declare the decrease function as well so
what we'll do is we'll again use the
same logic we'll write here function
decrease
and inside the body we'll write document
dot get element by ID
we'll write here IMG
dot style dot width
is equals to the width let's say will be
default so the width will be 200 pixels
we'll write here 200 pixels
and the decrease function will make the
picture get back to its original size
that is 200 pixels so save it and you
can see here on the browser that the
image is zooming in and out on specific
Mouse events
that is one of the most easiest tasks to
do in JavaScript all we had to do is we
had to Define two functions a function
increase and the other one for
decreasing the size so the function
increase will increase the size by 200
pixels and the function decrease will
get the image back to its original form
fine
now there is an older method of changing
the size of an image using the set
interval method HTML5 documents no
longer support this method so suppose
that we want the size of the image to
grow gradually like after every 10
milliseconds the size should increase up
to a certain level all we have to do is
to use the set interval method we are
all aware of this concept in JavaScript
so let's take a look at the HTML part so
here's the HTML part which is the same
as we used for the previous program not
even a single change here you can see we
have the image sources coffee.png then
we have the ID as IMG one then we have
used two mouse over events one to
increase the size and the other one to
decrease the size and then we have the
width has hundred we have changed the
width here the initial width will be 100
and we'll notice that the initial image
size is smaller than the one we used in
the previous program now the Javascript
file will look different let's move
there first so here is the JavaScript
part and we have three variables here
with addition and interval ID now the
initial value of width is the same as
that of image which is 100 and then we
have the variable addition which will be
responsible for the increment of the
size as we want the size to be increment
by 2 pixels after every 10 milliseconds
right the following variable is interval
ID which we'll need later on while using
the set interval method now we have two
functions over here the increase
function and the decrease function so
these are the two functions we have in a
Javascript file inside the increase
function we have used the set interval
method you can see here we have the set
interval method and we have called the
zoom in function after every 10
milliseconds so it will call the zoom in
functions again and again after 10
milliseconds so if we want to make it
one second we have to write here 1000
right we are already aware of this
concept so we are using milliseconds for
now now if we remove this clear interval
method from here
then the zoom in and zoom out effect
will not work correctly in between we'll
try it later so same as the case for
decrease function as well and it will
call the zoom out function after every
10 milliseconds right so we have to
Define these two functions as well so
here are the functions zoom in and zoom
out so let's take a look at the zoom in
function first the zoom in function is
actually responsible for the increment
in the size of the image if the width is
less than 200 let's suppose the initial
width is 100 Which is less than 200
right then what will happen is the value
of width will be increased by width plus
addition it will be increased by 2 so it
will check if the width is less than 100
the value will be 102 then 104 6 8 10 up
to 200 and then the value will be
assigned to the style property to
increase the size so this statement is
we are using for a long time now so what
we are doing is we are assigning the
value of this width to this style
property and then we have used the
console.log to check the increase in
width now the else statement will stop
the set interval function and the
increment in image size will be stopped
as soon as it reaches the 200 Mark for
the value of width s 200 the set
interval function will stop
same as the case for zoom out function
which will decrease the size of the
image until the size reaches 0.
the size will be reduced by 2 after
every 10 milliseconds the logic Remains
the Same what we are doing is we are
using here minus instead of plus and we
are checking if the value of width is
greater than 100 fine so let's check the
output of this program save it and we'll
open this file with live server we'll
click on live server
now here we are on the browser and take
the mouse cursor over the image oh it's
not working the reason behind it is this
method is not supported by the current
version of HTML to make this program
work we have to put our browser in Quark
mode
now for that we have to do a simple task
we have to go to a HTML file and we have
to remove this particular statement we
have to remove this doctype as HTML
remove it now this Quark mode is used to
make older websites compatible with the
browser if your program doesn't work
sometimes do check this out by removing
doctype from your HTML file sometimes it
happens that a particular method or a
particular type of program doesn't
supports in your browser so do check
this method out try running your program
in Quark mode and maybe it will work
so let's check the output now see on
taking the mouse cursor over here the
image size increases gradually and on
taking the mouse cursor away the size
decreases it looks nice right
now imagine you are working on an
e-commerce website and you want to make
your website more interactive then you
can put this effect over products and it
will look nicer right
so we have already mentioned it that
what if we remove this clear interval
method so we'll move to a Javascript
file and we'll see what if we remove
this particular clear interval method
from it so we'll remove these clear
interval methods we'll remove this one
and
this one
save it now and you can see there is
something wrong on taking the mouse
cursor over this image so you can see
the image is shaking slightly right now
this is because the clear interval
method does not stop the set interval
method on calling the increase and
decrease function every time
so this is how we can make our web pages
more beautiful and interactive in
JavaScript before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss what a
Wordle game is the Wordle is a popular
five letter word guessing game that has
become popular in the last couple of
months the game was actually designed by
a software engineer as a gift for his
partner but with time the game gained
popularity and now everyone on social
media is talking about this game
the rules for this game are simple the
game tells you if the letters you picked
are in the world and if they are in the
right place as well if the letter is in
the right spot it shows up green and the
correct letter in the wrong spot shows
up yellow a letter that isn't present in
the word at all shows up green color so
let's go through the game once and you
guys will understand it much better
here we are in the browser you can see
we have blocks over here and the
keyboard present beneath them we have
six rows over here and each row contains
five columns for each letter of the word
let's ask a simple we have only one
correct word if we write something on
the first row the system will check for
all the letters if a letter is present
at the correct place then the color of
that particular letter will change to
Green for example if we write here River
and press enter key you can see all the
words or all the letters of this word
change to Green this means that none of
these letters are present in the world
so let's try another word we'll write
here
Apple
press the enter key and you can see a is
correct but present at the wrong spot
let's try some more now
we'll write here let's say
Tokyo fine click on enter and you can
see o is also correct and the last word
is O now we have two letters of those we
have a and o o is present at the last
and a is present in the world so let's
think of any word which is like this
the word coming in my mind right now is
let's try mango over here so we'll write
here
mango
click on enter and you can see mango is
the correct word for this worldly fine
we can get any random word from the word
list we have in a JavaScript part so
we'll discuss about it later on so I
hope you guys got what this game is so
let's move again to the programming part
now so here we are in the HTML part
now the task is to create this whole
game again from scratch so here we are
in the vs code and we'll start writing
the code for the scene
now we'll create the layout of this
webpage using HTML first so let's say
what we are doing here is we are writing
here inside the body
we are writing here H1
let's say the ID is
ID is H1 title fine title is the ID for
this and now what we'll do is we'll
use an underline text so we'll write
something over here we'll write here
verdel
using
JavaScript fine save the program and
this is our actual program
save it now open it with live server
once again
and you can see we have this heading
over here which says Wordle using
JavaScript which is underlined as well
now let's write the code again so what
we are going to do here is we are going
to use a break text now the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
take a div
so this div is going to be for the board
so we are going to create the board of
this game later on in the CSS part will
keep this div empty here
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have to use another brake tag and
then we have to print the answer as well
right so we'll write here br
now we'll write here H1 so inside H1 the
ID is going to be let's say answer
and then inside this H1 we'll keep this
empty fine we are done with the HTML
part will manage the rest in the CSS in
the JavaScript Parts as well so let's
move on to the CSS part now but before
that let's save this program and you can
see nothing is changing over here in the
browser so let's move on to the CSS part
now here we are in the CSS file what
we'll do is we'll write here
body now we'll first style the body tag
of a whole web page so we'll write your
font family
so font family is going to be
Gill sense and then we'll write here
we'll send Ms empty sorry and then we'll
write here
calibri and then we have
this over here so we'll write here
trebuchet MS
and then we have sensory forward so here
we are done with this
and it's showing some error over here so
what we have to do is we have to put
this inside single inverted commas as
well now let's zoom out the vs code and
here you can see something is wrong over
here
so the wrong thing is we have to put the
sensitive inside single inverted commas
and calibery like this so we are done
with the font family next thing we are
going to do here is we are going to
write a text align at the center
then we have background color so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
the linear gradient over here so we'll
write here
linear gradient now inside this we have
to pass the degree or the angle we can
say so we'll write here degree as 120
then we have specific colors so we'll
write here double 3 B
7ce fine so this is one of those colors
then we'll write here
50 and then we have another color so
we'll write here hash
218 EDC so we'll write here 218 ed6 and
this is the second color we'll write
here 50 again
now save the program move back to the
browser and we'll see if this is working
fine so this is working fine as of now
we'll check back at it later
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have
to style the HR tag as well so we'll
write here width as
500 pixels for this HR Tech save the
program move back to the browser
and you can see nothing has changed over
here
so the next thing we have to mention
whoever here is the title tag so we have
the IDS title for our title so we'll
write a title now inside this we'll
write the font size font size is going
to be 36 pixel for the title then we
have found weight so we'll write a font
weight as
volt then we have letter spacing so
we'll write here lattice spacing as two
pixels for this save the program move
back to the browser and you can see
we have this heading over here which
says Wordle using JavaScript and
that's it so the next thing we are going
to do here is we are going to write the
code for board so we'll write here hash
board
and we'll write here
width of this board is going to be 350
pixels so we'll write here 350 then we
have the height as so we'll write here
the height as 420 pixels
and then we have merge so we'll write
here margin margin is going to be
0 and auto then we have margin top so
we'll write here margin top
K so we have to write a margin top and
margin top is going to be 3 pixels so
we'll write here three pixels
then we have the display as Flex
and then lastly we have the flex length
so we'll write your Flex wrap as wrap
now save the program and
here you can see some things are changed
over here now let's style other things
as well so the next thing we have to
change here is the type so tile is a
class over here
we'll go back to HTML and you can see we
have no class named tile over here so
we'll Define this class later on in the
JavaScript part
so we will write here tile now inside
here what we'll do is we'll style the
Box first
so we'll put a comment over here as box
then we'll write here border border is
going to be two pixels solid
and the RGB value of the Border color is
then for green we have 18 and for blue
we have
80. fine
so this is the Border color then we have
width so width is going to be 60 pixels
and then we have height as well so we'll
write here height height is going to be
60 pixels again
then we have margin so we'll write a
margin margin is going to be 2.5 pixels
let's say
now we'll style the text as well so
we'll
mention it over here will comment text
over here now we'll
Define the color so the color for text
is going to be black then we have the
font size font size is going to be 36
pixels
and after font size we have the font
width so we will write your font with
font weight is going to be
bold then we have display so we will
write here display as Flex
and then we have justify content at the
center and finally we have align items
at the center
so we'll write here align items at
Center
so here we are done with the styling of
the body title and board now we are left
with the keyboard the colors were
correct absent and present letters so
we'll write the code for it later on for
now let's move ahead to the JavaScript
part but before that let's save this
program once and we'll check so here you
can see nothing is changed as of now so
let's refresh it once and we'll see if
something is wrong or not so here you
can see nothing is wrong everything is
working totally fine let's go back to
the JavaScript part and we'll go through
the logic behind this whole game now
so here we are in the JavaScript part
we'll start writing the code over here
so here you can see we have the keyboard
already with us so this is going to be
our keyboard
now the next thing we are going to do
here is we are going to take a variable
as
height so the value of height is going
to be 6 initially so this is basically
the number of guesses we have in our
program so basically we have six number
of guesses that's why we are taking the
variable height S6 then we have the
variable width so width of each word is
going to be five letters so the width is
going to be 5 then we have a variable as
row and the initial value of rho is
going to be 0 that's because of the
current gases or we can say the current
attempt
then we have a variable called so we'll
use 0 for this variable as well so this
is the current letter for that attempt
now we'll take another variable over
here we'll take a variable
game over and the initial value of this
variable is going to be false fine
the game over variable is for game over
if the game is over then the value will
change to true here we have taken the
height variable as 6 and the words width
is 5 letters the current row will be 0
and the call variable is also set to 0.
the game over variable is initially set
to false that's it right so let's move
ahead and we'll create two lists now the
first one is going to be a list of words
and the second one will be a list of
guest words so if the user enters a word
then the guest word list will be checked
if the word is present in the list or
not if the entered word is not present
in the list then the system will return
that the word is not present so what
we'll do is we'll write here
where word list so we'll write here
where word list is equals to we are
going to take a list of words so let's
say we have some words over here we'll
write here Apple
and then we have
mango so
they are basically a lot of words
present inside this list may be more
than thousand two thousand or three
thousand words so for now it's just a
prototype of this whole vertical game so
we are going to take four or five
different types of words that's it the
next word we have is River
then we have hyped so we'll write here
hyped
and then we have
2q so we'll write here Tokyo let's say
we'll take another word over here so
let's say we have title over here
and we have
Ouija fine
so we have to write a hyped with a small
H and that's it this is our word list
now we are going to create another list
this time we are going to create the
guest list which will contain all the
words that can be guessed by the user so
inside the guest list we'll write here
Apple
and then mango
then we have
River hyped so we are basically going to
take all these words and we are going to
paste them over here now let's use some
more words so let's say we are
using here
carbo then we have let's say another
word over here
proxy fine so we have these words in the
guest list as well now the next thing we
have to do is the guest list will also
contain the words from the word list
right so what we'll do here is we'll
write here
cash list and guest list is going to be
guestlist dot concat so what we are
doing here is we are basically
performing concatenation so we'll write
here word list inside this and that's it
now it's time to pick up a random word
from the word list we have for that
we'll use traditional math.random method
so for that what we'll do is we'll write
here
where word
and we are going to take this variable
and we'll write here word list
then inside this what we are going to do
is we are going to write here math dot
floor
then we have
math Dot
random so this is a method basically
method.random so we have to put
parenthesis over here then we'll write
here asterisk word list Dot
length so we'll write your word list dot
length
and finally what we are going to do is
we are going to change the word to
uppercase so that's why we are writing
here two uppercase over here so this is
also a method
now that's it let's print this word and
what we'll do is we'll write a
console.log
we are going to print this word on a
console fine
so here we are done with the task of
picking up a random word from the list
of words now the next thing we have to
do is to work upon the body of this game
and then on the screen keyboard
now the next thing we have to do is to
walk upon the body of this game and on
screen keyboard we have on our web page
but before that let's save this program
once move back to the browser open
console and here you can see
again on refreshing the web page the
word is changing over here it's taking a
random word from the word list you can
see on refreshing we have River as of
now I'm not sure if you guys are able to
see it so let me Zoom it out a bit now
I've refresh this page and you can see
the word is changing over here we have a
list of words and a random word will be
picked at once so here you can see
now it's working totally fine so let's
move on and now we'll write the code for
the body and the on screen keyboard so
we'll write here window
dot on loot so we'll write your window
Dot onload
and on loading we are going to create a
function file so we are going to
initialize so we are going to write here
initialize
and we are going to call this initialize
function fine
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to create this function so we'll
write here
function
initialize
now what we have to do is we have to
create the game board now so for that we
are going to use the for Loop we are
going to write here for let
R is equals to 0 so the initial value of
R is going to be 0 R is
less than height so this is the
condition and we are going to
write a r plus plus fine
now inside the body of this for Loop we
have to take another for Loop we have to
take the for Loop for column as well so
we are going to write here for let's say
we have variable C and the initial value
is set to 0 and the condition is going
to be C less than the width so we'll
write here C less than width
and then we'll write here C plus plus
fine
now we have to write here again this
curly braces because we are going to
write inside this for Loop now so we'll
write here let
so tile is a class
we have in a CSS file so we have new
style over here we'll write here
document
Dot
create element so we are going to use
document.createelement over here and
then we are going to write here span
fine
now the next thing we have to write here
is the tile ID so we'll write it tile.id
is equals to r dot to string
fine so we have to write here r.2 string
is a method so then we have to write
here plus now inside double inverted
commas we have to put a dash over here
then we have to write here plus and we
have to
at the C value so first we'll convert
the value of C to string and then we'll
add it over here so we'll write a plus c
dot two string
so we'll write here C dot to string we
are going to call this method again and
that's
fine the next thing we have here is tile
Dot
class list then what we'll do is we'll
write over here add and we are going to
add the tile class over here so we are
going to write it tile
and the next thing we have to do is tile
Dot in a text so we have to write here
in a text
and we have to give the value as null
over here
fine the next thing we have to do is we
have to write here document dot get
element by ID then we have to get the
element of
basically we have to get the value of
board so what we are going to do is we
are going to pass your board and we are
going to pass a pen child over here so
we'll write a pen child and we are going
to append the values of board and time
so we'll write in time fine
that's it save the program move back to
the browser and you can see we have this
board over here so you can see the board
over here we are able to
see it so we have five columns you can
see one two three four five and six rows
away fine so it is working totally fine
till now
now let's create the keyboard as well so
we have to write here after this for
Loop so what we are going to do is we
are going to create a keyboard so let's
write a comment over here we'll write
here keyboard
and we'll start writing the code over
here so we are going to take a
variable over here so let's say the
variable name is keyboard and now what
we have to do is we have to write
the values present inside the keyboard
we already have those values over here
so
we'll copy these from here
and we are going to paste them over here
here fine
so let's do one thing let's write it
this way so we have the keyboard over
here we have all the keyboard
keys of the keyboard you can see we have
QWERTY uiop then we have the next line
and finally we have the enter key
zxcvb and MN backspace fine
so this is a symbol for backspace
basically you can download it from
Google as well
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to Define here for Loop we'll write
here for we are going to take a keyword
let I is equals to 0
then we have I less than
keyboard Dot
length and then we have I plus plus over
here fine so now inside this for Loop
what we are going to do is we are going
to take a variable so we will write here
where
current row so we'll write your where
current row is equals to
keyboard and what we are going to do is
we are going to pass here I inside this
then we have let
keyboard row
is equals
2 then we'll write your document
dot create element so we'll write a
document dot create element and we are
going to create a div tag over here fine
so we will write here div then we'll
write here keyboard
row
Dot
classlist dot add we are going to add
the keyboard row class over here so
we'll Define this class later in the CSS
file keep this thing in mind we'll write
here keyboard
row so we'll write a keyboard and then
we'll write a hyphen fine so this is
going to be a class we are going to
Define it later in the CSS part I keep
mentioning it again and again so that
you guys will remember what we have to
do later on so we'll take another for
Loop over here let's say we have a
variable named as J
well right here let's J is equals to 0
J less than
current row
dot length
and will pass G plus plus y fine
now we'll write inside the body of this
for loop again so we'll write here let
key tile so we'll write here let ketile
is another variable we have taken over
here so we are going to write a document
Dot
create element and then we'll create a
div tag over here so we'll write here
div
and then we'll write here let
key so key is another variable over here
so we'll write here current row and
we'll pass J inside it
so we'll write here key tile
dot inner text so we'll write a key tile
dot inner text
is equals 2 and we are going to pass the
value of key away fine then after this
we'll use the if else statement so we'll
write here if key
is equals to is equals
to enter so what will happen is
the ketile ID will change to enter so
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here inside this
key tile dot ID
is equals
to enter
and we have to use the else if statement
as well for other keys so we'll write
here as if
key is equals to is equals
to backspace so we have a symbol for
backspace here
so we'll copy it from here we'll paste
the symbol over here
and now inside the body of this else
statement we'll write key tile
dot ID is equals to
backspace fine so that is going to be
backspace then we have another else if
so we'll write here else if
we'll write here a and we'll put less
than equals to sine
and we'll write a key
will pass another condition so we'll
write here key is
less than equals to
Z
and what will happen is
the key tile ID
is going to be
key
Plus
right
and that's it we are going to add an
event listen over here to process the
key
so after this what will happen is we'll
put a semicolon over here first and
after the body of this health tag what
we have to do is we have to write a key
tile Dot
add event listener so we have to add an
event over here we'll
right here click
comma
process key fine so this is going to be
the event
and
now we have to write some more core over
here so we'll write here if
and we'll write here key is equals to is
equals to enter again
then what will happen is
key
tile the key tile Dot
class list so we are going to add a
class over here so we'll write here add
and we are going to rename the class as
let's say
and key
type fine so we'll create this class
later on in the CSS part again then
we'll write here else
and we are going to write here
key tile Dot classlist dot add and let's
say we have the class name is
key type fine
that's it then after this we have to
write here
keyboard row dot append child
so we have to write a keyboard row dot a
pen child now we are going to append the
key tile class over here so we'll write
a key tile
and after this we have to write here
document
dot body Dot
a pen child and we have to write here
keyboard fine
so that's it
now we'll do this letters entering task
from the system keyboard as well that's
basically the keyboard we have in our
system so for that what we are going to
do is we are going to write here
document dot add event listener so we
are going to add an event then we'll
write here
key up
key up is going to be the event then
we'll write here e inside this and
will create an arrow function over here
so this is going to be an anonymous
Arrow function
now inside the body of this function
what we'll do is we'll write here
process
input and we are going to pass e over
here fine
so this is basically the keyboard part
we have save the program move back to
the browser and we'll see you can see
the process key is not defined over here
is the error so we'll Define the process
key later
now what we'll do is we'll write the CSS
part for the keyboard and for that we'll
move back to the CSS file so here we are
in the CSS file and what we'll do is
we'll Define the classes over here so
the first class we have is
the keyboard row class so we'll write
here dot keyboard row now we'll write
over here width of the keyboard width is
going to be 400 pixels then we have
margin so we'll write here margin margin
is going to be 0 and Auto for this
keyboard then we have the display as
flex and finally we have the Flagstaff
Flex wrap is going to be wrap and that's
it for the keyboard row class then we
have the key tile class so we'll write
here key
tile
and now inside this what we are going to
do is we are going to mention the width
again width of the key tile is going to
be 36 pixel then the height we have of
this key time so
will write here height height is going
to be 40 pixels let's say then we have
margin so margin is going to be 1 pixel
again for the key tile
then we have the border border is going
to be 1 pixel solid in nature and the
RGB value is
12 comma 12 comma 12 which is blank so
then we have the Border radius border
radius is going to be 5 pixels again
and then we have to mention the font
family for the text so the font family
is going to be
this one and then we have Cambria Cochin
Georgia times Times New Roman and serif
away fine
now the next thing we have to mention
for the text is the font size so we are
going to write your font sizes 20 pixels
then we have
font weight font weight is going to be
bold then we have the display display is
going to be flex and finally we have to
justify content at the Center fine
then we have to align these items at the
center as well
and that's it now we have to write the
code for the enter key time so we'll
write here dot enter
key tile and inside here we have to
mention the width width is going to be
76 pixels for the enter key you have
seen the enter key is bigger in size
than other keys so we have to mention
the height height is going to be the
same as 40 pixels
then we have margin margin is going to
be one pixel again for this Enter key
and we have the
border as well border is going to be one
pixel
solid so we have to write your one pixel
solid and RGB value is
going to be 0 comma
0 comma zero
so we'll
remove this blue and green from here and
that's it the RGB value is black
basically then we'll write you about a
radius model radius is again going to be
5 pixel for the enter key as well now we
have to mention
for the text as well so the font size is
going to be 20 pixels then we have font
weight so font weight is going to be
bold and then we have display as Flex
finally we have
Justified content at the center and
we have to align items at the center is
fine
so we are done with the enter key tile
as well now what we'll do next is we'll
move back to the JavaScript part but
before that let's save this program
and we'll move back to the browser once
again you can see it says process key is
not defined we'll Define it later on
so for now let's move back to the
JavaScript part again
now what we have to do is we have to
create a function over here so we are
going to create the function process
input
before we move on to the process input
function what we'll do is we'll create
the process key function because we are
getting the error for this again and
again so we'll write here
function then we'll write your process
key
now inside the body of this function
what we have to do is we have to write a
e is equals to
code and then we'll write here
this Dot
ID fine so I guess it will work fine
then what we have to do is we have to
write a process input and we have to
pass e away fine we have to call the
process input function for me so save
this program move back to the browser
and you can see now we have the keyboard
over here
so you can see on clicking any key over
here it says process input is not
defined so let's define it as well first
and then we'll see if the keyboard is
working totally fine or not
so for the process input function we
have to write here
function
then we'll write here process input we
have to pass e as a parameter over here
and we'll write inside the function if
game over is true then return from here
fine
now we have
to write the e dot code over here so
we'll write here if
key a
is less than equals to e dot code
and then
e Dot code is
less than equals to
KZ
then what will happen well right here
inside the if block we'll write if
column is less than width
so we'll write here let
current type so we'll write here let
current tile is equals to
document dot get element by ID so we'll
write a get element by ID and ID is
going to be
rho Dot
to string
Plus
then we'll put a dash over here or we
can say a hyphen will add what will add
is we'll add
call Dot to string fine so we'll write
your call.2 string this is again a
method
so we have to write here this and we
have to write here row dot two string
fine so I guess this will work totally
fine now
now after this what we'll do is we'll
write here again if
so we'll write here
current tile
dot inner text
is equals 2 is equals to nothing
nand inside the body of this is if
statement we'll write
current time
dot inner code
or we can say in a text over here so we
have to write a currentile DOT inner
text equals to e Dot
code so we have to write here 3
then we have to change the value to
column plus is equals to 1. fine
so we have to mention the elsif
statement as well so we'll write here
after this
if statement we'll write here else if
e dot code
is equals to is equals to backspace now
we'll delete
the letter so we'll write here backspace
and inside the body of this else if
we'll write if
0 is less than call so we'll write here
0 less than call
and
call is less than equals to width
then what will happen is call minus is
equals to 1. so basically what we are
doing is we are deleting the letter so
we'll write here this
and after this else what we have to do
is we have to write here
inside the else if only we'll write let
current time so we have to write here
current tile is equals
to document Dot
get element by ID then we'll write here
row dot to string so we'll write here
row dot two string this is a method then
we'll write here the same thing again
and we have to write here
call Dot
two string fine
so this is a method again we are good
with it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to write a
currentile DOT inner text
is equals to null over here fine
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to write the code for Enter key as
well so we'll write here
after this we'll write here else if
e
dot code
is equals 2 is equals
to enter
and what we have to do is we have to
call the update function fine
so this is going to be a function we are
going to create the update function
after this function so don't worry about
it now what we'll do is we'll write here
if
game is not over so we'll write here not
game over
and then
rho is equals 2 is equals to height
and what will happen inside the body of
this if tag we have to write here
game over is equals to true
and we have to write here document
dot get element by ID and we have to get
the ID of the answer so we'll write your
answer
dot in a text
is equals to word so we are going to
print the word fine if the row is equals
to height and the gain is not over so
basically if we have all the blocks
filled we have all the rows filled and
if the last row is also filled then what
will happen is it will print the answer
in word so it will print the word as the
answer fine
so save it now move back to the browser
and we'll see
so you can see as of now this thing is
not working but we have no error away so
let's refresh it once and you can see
there is no error still
so I guess it will work fine after we'll
do the update function as well so let's
right over here what we are going to do
is we are going to create the update
function for rest of the things we'll
check the input given by the user here
only so what we'll do is we'll write
your function
update
and what we have to do is we have to
write here variable so let's say let
guess is equals to
null for now we are going to take a
variable guess and then what we'll do is
we'll write here
document dot get element by ID now what
we are going to do is we are going to
use the answer so we are going to write
a answer Dot
inner text
is equals to null for now
now what we have to do is we have to
string up the gases into our so
basically we what we have to do is we
have to take all the letters from a
particular row and we have to pile them
up in a word so what we'll do here is
we'll write here for
let's take a variable C is equals to 0
we'll write here C is less than
width so let's write here C is less than
width and C plus plus fine now what
we'll do is we'll write here let
current tile
is equals
to document dot get element by ID
and we have to write here again row Dot
to string
Plus
then we have to put a hyphen over here
then we have to put a plus and we'll
write here call Dot
two string fine
now the next thing we have to do here is
we have to take another variable so
we'll write here let letter
is equals to
current time Dot
in the text
so we'll write a currentile dot in a
text
and then what we have to do is we have
to add
this value to a gas variable so we'll
write here gas plus is equals to
letter fine
so we are done with this for Loop now
the next thing we have to do is we have
to update the value of guess and we have
to change the gas to lower case now so
we'll write here guess
Dot
two Lower Keys fine so we have to write
here two lower case
this is again a method so we have to put
parenthesis over here this is case
sensitive basically
then we'll put it on the console so
we'll write a console.log
and we'll write you guess
fine
now what we are going to do is we are
going to check if the gas is present in
the gas list or not fine
so for that what we are going to do is
we are going to write here
so let's put some space over here well
right here if not
guest list
dot includes
but guess if the gas list does not
include the guess so what will happen is
we'll write here
document Dot
get element by ID and we are going to
write here answer so instead of answer
what will be there is Dot
in a text
is equals to
not in the
word list or not in word list basically
over here we'll write not in word list
and that's it
fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write here return
we have to return this thing so that's
it we are done with
this guess part now the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to start
processing the guess we have so for that
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
correct the initial value of correct is
going to be 0
and let's say we have another variable
letter
count fine
so we are going to take
so basically what we are going to do is
we are going to keep a track of letter
frequency so that's why we are doing it
now what we have to do here is we have
to write here
for we are going to use another for Loop
so let's say we have a variable I with
initial value as 0
and then we have I is less than
word dot length
and we have I plus plus over here fine
so basically we are done with
the for Loop let's write inside the body
of this for Loop what we'll do is we'll
write letter
is equals to what
and then we have to check the world so
we'll write here I then we'll use if
let account
of
letter
and we'll write here inside the body of
this if statement
letter count
letter
plus is equals to 1. fine
now what we'll do is we'll write after
this else
now inside the body of else what we'll
do is we'll put the let account to 1. so
we'll write here letter count
now inside this we'll write letter
is equals to 1 fine
so basically what we have to do is we
have to write here
after this
console Dot lock and we have to put the
printer
let account fine
so till now we are done with this now
what we'll do is we'll check for the
first iteration we'll check for all the
correct ones first so what we'll do is
we'll write here after this
4 we are going to use another for Loop
for this so let's say we have a variable
C the initial value of C is set to 0
will check the width of C so we'll write
here C is less than width then what will
happen is
c will increase so we'll write here C
plus plus now inside the body will write
let
current tile is equals to document Dot
get element by ID now we are going to
write here the same thing again row dot
to string
we have a method as row dot two string
now we have to put a hyphen over here
then we have to put
call Dot
to string over here fine
now we have to take the letter variable
so we'll write here letter is equals to
current tile dot inner text so basically
it has the value of the current type
so we'll write here currentile dot in a
text
so is it in the correct position now we
are going to check it fine so we'll
write here if
word so what is the word C
is equals to is equals
to letter
then what will happen is
the current tile value so I will write
here current type Dot
class list dot add so basically we are
going to create a class for correct
which will change the background color
of that particular key end of that
particular
box or tie fine so we'll write here
correct so we are going to create this
class in the CSS part
now after this what we have to do is we
have to write here let key type key tile
is equals to document
dot get element by ID so we have to
write here
key
Plus
letter fine
then we have
Dot
class list
Dot remove so we have
to write here the present class
and then we have to write here key type
dot class list dot add the correct
clause so we'll write here
correct
fine so we are going to Define these two
classes in the CSS part
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to increase the value of correct by
1 so we'll write here correct plus is
equals to 1 fine then we have let
account and we are going to decrease the
value of let account Pi 1 so we'll write
here
minus is equals to 1. let's put some
space over here as well
so that it will look good to you guys
now we are done with the let account as
well so what we'll do next is
we are going to
right here after this particular if
statement so
right here we are going to write if
correct is equals to is equals to width
then what will happen is
game over will change to
true fine
this is another condition we have now
what we have to do next is we have to
write here
so basically what we are going to do is
we are going to print the console
or we can say we are going to print the
let account on the console so we'll
write here let account and site
console.log
and now what we'll do is we'll go again
and Mark which ones are present but in
the wrong position that means the yellow
color ones right so we'll write here
after this
console.log will write for we are going
to use another for Loop so we will write
here let
C is equals to 0 again
C is less than the width so we'll write
here C less than width then we'll
increase the value of C by 1. so we'll
write a C plus plus then we'll write
here let
current tile
is equals
to document dot get element by ID so we
are going to write here row Dot
to string
and then we have this hyphen over here
and we'll write here Plus
all Dot
to string fine
so we are going to take the values of
these and then after this what we are
going to do is we are going to set the
value of letter variable so we'll write
here let letter is equals to
what's present inside the current type
so we'll write here current tile Dot
in a text
and the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to skip the letter if it
has been marked correct so for that what
we have to do is we have to use the if
statement so we'll write here if
not current I Dot
class list
Dot
contains what it contains is the correct
class so we'll write here correct if it
contains correct what will happen is
we'll check if it is present in the
world we have to make sure that we don't
double count right so what we'll do is
we'll write here again inside this if
statement we'll take another if
statement and we'll write your word Dot
includes
now we have to write here
letter
and we have to mention it over here
after this we have to write here letter
count now what we have to do is we have
to write a letter
and we have to write here greater than 0
fine
now what will happen is we'll write here
current time current tile Dot
class list
dot add we have to add it to
present class so we'll write your
present fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write here let
etyl is equals to
document dot get element by ID what we
have to do is we have to write here key
Plus
letter fine
okay so we have to write here after this
what we have to do is we have to take
another if
fine so we'll write here if not
key type
Dot
class list
dot contains which class the correct
class so we'll write here correct
foreign
key type Dot class list dot add but we
have to add over here is the
present class fine
now what we'll do is we'll
deduct the value of let account by 1 so
we'll write here let account
and we have to pass letter inside here
and we'll write here minus is equals to
1. fine
now what we have to do is we have to
write the code for else as well so we'll
write here else
now what we'll write inside else is
current tile Dot
classlist dot add which class we have to
add now is the absent class fine so
we'll write here absent we are going to
describe this class or we are going to
Define this task in the CSS part later
on
so for now we have to write here absent
and we have to change the value of key
tile so we'll write here key tile is
equals to
document dot get element by ID we have
to write here again key Plus
letter fine so let's put a space over
here and that's it
what we have to do is we have to change
the key tile class as well so we'll
write here
key tile Dot
class list dot add which class we have
to add again is the absent class fine
we are almost done with the JavaScript
part as well what we have to do is we
have to start a new row for a new one so
we'll increase the value of row as
row plus plus equals to 1 start a new
row and we have to change the column
value to
0 again fine so basically we are done
with it so before we move on to the
final outcome let's do one thing let's
go through the CSS part once again and
we'll Define these three classes the
correct present and absent Clause fine
save the JavaScript part here save it
now and let's move back over here and
what we'll do is
well right after this tile class what
we'll do is we'll write over here
dot correct we are going to define the
correct class first so the correct class
the background color is going to be this
one hash
3 f c
and the value is 0 3 1 so the green
color basically the font color will
change to White so we'll write here
color as white and then we have border
color so border color will also change
to White fine
then we have the present class as well
so we'll write here present and inside
the present class the background color
will change and the value of background
color is Hash f
5 c e 2 3 fine so this is basically
yellow color so
the color and the background color will
remain the same so
okay so we have to write here border
color not background color so we'll
write your border color and again we are
going to define the Border color here
fine so we'll write border color
so border color is going to be white in
this case as well now we have to define
the absent class as well so we'll write
here absent
for the absent class the background
color will change to gray fine so we'll
write here
hash
C7
e fine
so this is the gray color we have the
color is going to be white
and then we have the border color fine
so the Border color is again going to be
white
that's it we are done with everything
now save the program save the JavaScript
part and the HTML part once again move
back to the browser and here you can see
we have a program
so if we click on the keyboard so it's
not working as of now
maybe we have some error over here so
let's check it out once again
will move to the JavaScript part
and if we can see here
Kita is fine so we have to write your
key tile like this
and let's check the other key tile as
well so everything else is fine save the
program now save the CSS part and the
HTML part as well move back to the
browser and I hope this will work now
so you can see it's working as of now
now we have written over quote you can
see it says not in word list we have
quote over here so the word we have is
title let's write
title over here and you can see the
second line is not working
so we have to get back to this and we
have
save it now move back to the browser
foreign
so the word we have here is hyped so
let's try to write okay we have to
remove this first that's why it was not
working so we have to write here another
word let's say we have a word mango
click on enter and you can see now it's
working fine now the word we have here
is hyped so we'll write here
hyped click enter and you can see we
have all greens over here you can see
the word count as well we have h y p e d
s one one one one one one
and we have all the words here in the
console so you have seen here the
program is working totally fine the task
is done here finally the time has come
when will Implement JavaScript to its
actual use as we mentioned before we'll
use some other Technologies in today's
video don't worry about it guys it's
just a bit of Json and we'll use some
predefined libraries for icons and
that's it rest will be done in HTML CSS
and JavaScript only we'll understand
each concept here in this video so get
ready for some exciting stuff coming
your way let's start this session by
taking an overview of our website
so let me Zoom it so this is the website
we are going to create in today's video
here you can see we have an HTML web
page with a navigation bar to take the
user to different sections of a website
I hope you already know that we have to
create several web pages for a single
website to make it a fully functional
website we have to create these Pages
separately in different HTML documents
and then we have to provide the links to
this particular home page for directing
the user to various locations of a
website
if you see here in the navigation bar
we have several options starting with
our company's logo so Comfort learning
is the company's logo here we have an
icon of the book to let the user know
that this website is for learning
so we'll see further in this video how
we can use these logos and all then we
have links for several other web pages
of our website that are not working
because we haven't added these web pages
till now the reason for this is we don't
want to make this project a long one we
want to finish it quickly and we want to
give you guys a basic idea of how to use
JavaScript and other Technologies to
create a fully functional website
next up we have a card button over here
on clicking it opens the cart with items
present inside it and the user can
either clear the whole cart or proceed
further to buy all the things they need
right following this card button we have
a background image over here with a card
present over the image
the card says find your favorite codes
here now you guys might have guessed
that this website is for buying courses
and the user can buy some courses here
which they want to study
this shop now button is completely
working and if we click on it it will
take us to the courses catalog where we
have several courses present to choose
from we have eight different courses
present here you can add as many courses
as you want or as many products as you
want
so we can add any of them to the cart on
taking the mouse cursor over any image
you can see it gives us an option to add
that particular product to the cart
right
if we click on this add to cart button
you can see it says in cart it means
that we can't add any specific course to
the cart more than once
we can later change the number of items
in the cart but we can add a course only
once from you let's add some courses to
the card and then we'll see if it's
working or not
so we'll add few courses we'll add this
one so it says this course is already
present in cart similarly this course is
also present and we can add this course
now we'll move to the cart we will click
on this card button and you can see we
have all the courses present over here
now if you notice here we have these
small arrows present right we can click
on these arrows to change the number of
items we can either increase the number
of items or we can decrease the number
of items as well then we have a remove
button over here and if we click on this
remove button you can see the course is
removed now we can remove any number of
courses we want and we can also increase
the number of products in our card
following it we have two options over
here either we can clear the whole cart
or we can proceed if we click on this
clear card button there will be no
course present in the card and the total
price will change to 0 in that case fine
so I hope you guys must have known the
task by now it's clear and seems
effortless right but these small things
take a lot of precise coding and
attention to work smoothly
so let me show you guys one more thing
before we move on to the coding part if
we reduce the size of a web page or we
can say if we remove the size of our
browser you can see the size of website
also changes if we make the browser
similar to a phone you can see we have
got a menu type of thing over here and
if we click on this we are getting the
options here we have home categories
pricing and about us right so these were
the options present in the navigation
bar we can get them inside a particular
menu using CSS we'll see how it actually
works
so a website is responsive right we'll
do it with the help of CSS so let's move
on to the programming part now
so here we are in the vs code we have
all the images already present inside
the images folder in our system so if
you want to see you can see here we have
all the images present over here and we
have four different files we have app.js
we have
index.html products.json to add products
and we have style.css to style all the
elements fine here we are in the HTML
file some of you guys may think that
HTML CSS and JavaScript were fine but
what's up with the Json thing we haven't
heard of it in the previous videos
so let me tell you guys Json stands for
JavaScript object notation just like we
create objects in JavaScript Json is
also used to create objects like name
value Pairs and later we can use these
objects to retrieve that data in a HTML
file in simple words to add an item to a
cart we need to store it somewhere to
get the data related to the object and
then we can add those items to our cart
so Json is used to transmit the data
between a server and a web application
we need to store our products somewhere
so that we can use them when added to
cart so you'll get to know more about it
while working on it basically so for now
if you know enough about JavaScript
objects then Json will be easy for you
guys because the syntax remains almost
similar in both the cases that is in
JavaScript and in Json
so let's start writing the code now here
we are in a HTML file and we have
already linked all the files over here
you can see here we have used font
awesome library for icons we'll use on
our website you have seen that book icon
we have used in our logo part and
several other icons like the cart icon
Etc so we'll include those predefined
icons in a HTML file using this
particular library to include this
specific Library you don't have to do
much of a task go to Google Search
cdnjs.com slash libraries
slash font awesome
go to Google and search for this and
then select version
4.7.0 under the version option copy the
third URL with min.css as extension and
paste it into your HTML file as simple
as that I'll let you know about the
classes we'll use while working on the
website now let's start with the
programming part
the first thing we have on our website
is the navigation bar right let me show
it to you again so here you can see we
have a navigation bar we'll first work
on this one only
so let's start writing the code so this
is the output of a current website so
what we'll do is
will minimize the browser and we'll
start writing the code here only
so what we'll do is we'll write here
nav
class is equals to nav bar
then inside this we'll write div
class is equals 2.
Burger
and inside this we'll write three div
tags fine we'll write here div class is
equals to layer 1.
we'll close this div we'll copy it from
here and we'll paste it again three
times
fine
we'll write here layer 2 and layer 3 is
class then after this particular div tag
We'll add another div tag with
class is logo
then inside this we'll use the span tag
we'll write here span class
is equals to logo
logo text and then we'll
write here
I will use the itag to make it a little
bit italic so we'll use the class as
far
far book fine
we'll write here
tile
is equals to margin
margin right we'll write a margin right
as
0.1 M then we'll write here
similarly we can close this fine
now we have added the book icon to our
website
then what we'll do is we'll write here
again span will use the span tag within
this span tag we'll write here
tile is equals to
color
and the color code is
hash
f095 D1
so these are the color codes for this
particular website
will use them we have written here F 0 9
d51
fine
then what we'll do is we'll write here
font size as
1.1 M and what we'll do next is we'll
write here
before the span tag closes we'll write
here
learning fine okay so what we did wrong
here is we forgot to mention Comfort
here
now we are done with the logo part next
up what we'll do is we'll write here div
class is equals to
menu bar we are working on the menu bar
for the hamburger menu so what we'll do
is we'll write here
UL so UL stands for unordered list we'll
write here class is
list
and inside this we'll use
litec so we'll write here
class is let's say list items
we'll
right here a href is equals to hash
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here who fine we'll copy this piece of
code
we'll paste it again
three or four times we have four
different options we have home we have
courses and then we have pricings
and finally we have about us fine so we
are done with menu as well next up what
we'll do is we'll write the code for
card now so we'll write here div
class is equals to cart
and inside this will write
I
class is equals to
far far shopping cart for 1X so here we
have used this special class to include
the card icon to a web page now next up
what we'll do is we'll write here
div
class is equals
two number of
items
and then we'll write here
pen
class is equals to let's say Nui
now what we'll do is we'll write here 0
inside this fine
I hope you guys understood what we did
till now we are working on the
navigation bar only we have created the
navigation bar so this is the code
firstly we have used a class navbar for
this particular navigation bar then we
have used the div tag for Burger menu we
have three different layers layer 1
layer 2 and layer 3. so this is actually
the icon of burger menu you can see here
if we reduce the size of our website so
we have defined this burger menu and
inside this we have four other options
which we defined later here inside the
menu bar
and we have four options right we have
home courses pricings and about us
so we are doing totally right
so till now we did some basic tasks here
right we have added all the navigation
bar elements and the next thing we have
to do is to style our navigation bar
according to the final website it's
pretty simple let's do one thing let's
save it once and check the output now
let's see if it's working so it's
totally working we have a book icon over
here we have comfort learning written
over here we have cart icon over here
and we have zero written over here fine
now we have to style those elements
accordingly to make it look like this so
we are making this navigation bar so
what we'll do is we'll move to our CSS
file and we'll start styling by doing
some default style changes to the entire
HTML document we'll write here
star
margin will be 0 the default margin will
be 0
padding will be 0
then we have
box sizing we'll write here border box
and font size will be
20 pixels for default fine
next up we'll write here
HTML will now style the HTML document
we'll write here
scroll behavior is smooth
and will
write here anchor tag we'll write here
text decoration and we'll write a text
decoration as none
and then we'll style the unordered list
we'll write a UL
will write here
list style as
none fine
basic styling is done let's do some more
for the navigation bar as well what
we'll do is we'll write here
dot navbar this is the first class we
have used in a HTML page
we'll write here display is
Flex
then we'll write here
justify content as
space between
align items is
Center
height as 10 VH so 10 VH refers to the
viewport height it will take 10 percent
of the total height of the screen
then we have
background color as hash
e c e c e c so a little bit of gray
grayish white we can say then next thing
we'll do is we'll style a logo we'll
write here logo and inside this will
write
padding so we will write here padding
left and the padding left will be 2m
next up we'll write here logo
text so this is the next class we'll
write here
font size is 1.5
m
now the next class we have to use is
the menu bar class so we'll write here
width is 45 percent
and
margin left is
8.5 M fine
I'll let you know what this m means in a
moment so first we'll do this styling
and all next up we'll write here dot
list
we'll access the list and we'll write
here inside this display is
Flex
and
justify content as space between
fine next up we have the list items so
we'll write here list items
and we'll of course write here a as well
we'll write here color and the color
will be let's say black
next up what we'll do is we'll write
here
font family is
sensorif font size is
0.9 m
so you must have noticed earlier that
the default font size was 20 pixels so
keep that in mind I'll let you know the
use of M in a moment next up we'll write
here
transition as 0.4 seconds
and we are good to go with it next up
we'll
write here list items
and we'll write here
oh fine then we'll write here
color is
black
on hovering the color of the list items
will change to Black
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here cart
ing right will be
2m and Position will be relative fine
we are done with the cart next up we'll
write here
cart
number
of items fine
we'll write here
display is
Flex
cursor is
pointer we are using repeat we are
styling two different classes here we
are styling the element with classes
card and the element with classes number
of items fine we'll write here justify
contents
to Center
align items to Center
will write here color is
White
Position will be absolute
and then we'll write here left
is 18 pixels and
write as okay sorry we'll write here
left as 18 pixels and top as
minus 7 pixels
next up we'll write
background
so the background color will be hash f
0 9
D 5 1.
so this will be a the background color
we'll Define the height and width as
well so height will be
20 pixels and the width will also be
20 pixels fine
the last thing we have to write here is
the Border radius
so keep one thing in mind guys while you
are styling all these elements do check
the website after every styling event
because this will let you know what this
particular event does or what this
particular styling property does to that
particular element so do it when you are
writing this code next up we'll write
here
DOT number of items space dot knowing so
now it was the class we have already
declared we'll write here font size as
0.7 m
the next class will be styling is the
shopping cart so we'll style this icon
as well we'll write here
font size as 1.5 m
the font size will be equal to around 30
pixels
then we'll write here
cursor is
pointer
then we'll write here
Burger will tell the menu as well we'll
write here height height will be 28
pixels
width
will be
32 pixels
and then we'll write here
display is none then we'll
style the layers as well we'll write
here dot layer 1 dot layer 2.
and Dot layer
3.
now inside this we'll write
background as
black
height S4 pixel
margin top is
4 pixel
width as
100 percent and we'll write here border
radius is 10 pixels
fine you have seen that hamburger menu
you have seen that icon we were styling
that till now now you might have noticed
here that we have used M here in the CSS
file so I'm talking about this
particular m
or we can say em as well
until now we were using rem or pixel to
define the size of anything while
studying but today we are using M
because M uses the font size for example
if the font size is 30 for the parent
class in this case the font size is 20
the default font size is 20. and the
padding is defined as 2m then the
padding will be 40 in that case it uses
the font size to determine the size of
the property that's why we are using M
and if you try it yourself you will get
to know better so just try using M and
you can also use rem or pixel in this
case but for now we'll use M so this
might be a little bit new for you guys
but try it and you will understand it
much better
now save the CSS file
move back to the browser and you can see
here that we have a navigation bar ready
right it's looking fine although the
icons are not visible the book icon and
the cart icon is not visible so let's go
back and see what's wrong in this
CSS file what we'll do is
we'll move to HTML file and we'll see if
something is wrong here or not so
nothing is wrong in this case the error
is because we are not connected to
Internet so if this error continues just
try to connect your laptop or your PC to
the internet and the icons thing will
work fine so you can see here we have
icons over here we have the book icon we
have the cart icon and what we have to
do is we have to increase the size of
this logo and text a little bit right so
here you can see the Comfort learning is
a little bit small when compared to this
particular website so what we'll do is
we'll move to a CSS file and we'll write
here instead of 1.5 Ram we'll write here
2m fine save it
and here you can see it's looking fine
now
actually it's equal
the difference is because of this scroll
bar we don't have this scroll bar in our
website until now so this is why it
looks a little bit different to you guys
it's working totally fine other than
that
so let's move on to the next part and
the next part of our website is the
background image with the card present
on it right so let's write the code for
this section as well what we'll do is
we'll move to a HTML file
and
right here we'll write
section
class is equals to section one
so we are using the section tag to
define a particular section in the web
page now we'll write here div
class is equals to Banner
and here we'll write inside H1 tag
find your
favorite
courses
or course here
foreign
products so the products file will be
using Json for this so leave it for now
we'll write here shop now so shop now is
actually not a button what we'll do is
we'll use a link and we'll Define it
later so let's
save it
and move to the browser
open this website and you can see here
it says find your favorite course here
and it says shop now it's not inside the
banner because we need to style this
particular section to make it look like
a website so let's do the styling part
as well
and then we'll talk about it
so we'll move to the CSS file now
and
here what we'll do
we'll write here Dot
section one
height
we'll use the calc function and we'll
write here
which minus
10 VH so what we are doing is we are
reducing the
navigation Bar's height we are reducing
10 viewport height from 100 viewport
height it means that from the whole
screen area it will reduce 10 VH and
give it to that particular image fine so
next up we'll write here
width as hundred percent we wanted to
cover the whole home page so that's why
we are using width as hundred percent
background
so we'll add the background image we'll
write a URL
and inside this will give the path of
our image
will write his images
back one dot PNG
and we'll write here
Center
cover fine
let's do some more things we'll write
here top
left is zero
Z index
as minus 1. fine
save it now move to the browser and see
if it's working so here we are we have
our image over here but this Banner is
not here till now we'll style it so you
can see the images over here and one
more thing guys we have two three images
over here inside a images folder I'll
let you see all of them so here are the
images
and this is the third one
okay so this is the third one so I was
not sure which one to use but if you
guys liked any of these images do let us
know in the comments below and we'll use
that particular image for now we'll use
my personal favorite image we'll use
backman.png save it now
and this is the image we are going to
use in this particular video so let me
know if you have any other preference or
if you know any other image we'll use
that as well then we'll write here
section
and we'll style the banner as well for
that we'll write here Banner
height
is going to be 170 pixels
width
is going to be
600 pixels
background
is going to be a little bit Krish
so we'll write here rgba
255 comma two double five comma two
double five comma
0.7 so this is the particular rgba value
and next up we'll write here
position as relative top is
50 percent
left as 50 of the image
we want the banner to be present at the
center of the image right so next up
we'll write here
transform
Translate
and inside it we'll write
minus 50 percent
to minus 50 percent
next up we'll write here display is
Flex
justify content as
space around
and
Flex direction is
column
text align
is
Center
and then we have align items is
font family is going to be
sensitive again
and we'll Define the Z index as well so
this index is going to be
8 in this case fine
next up we'll inside the H1 tag inside
the banner
so we'll write here Banner
H1 and inside this
will Define the font size is
2m
now
we need to define the
link for shop now so for that we'll
write here display is
Flex
justify content is
Center
padding is going to be
1M
page two point
five m
next up we'll write here
font size is
0.8 m
so this is the font size for the shop
now button which looks like a button but
it is actually a link so
what we'll do is we'll Define the color
of this button is white
and here the background color is going
to be
hash
f90 d51
let's use this color
and we'll write here transition all at
zero point
three second
now save it once move to the browser
and you can see it looks fine though the
only thing that is different here in
this website is the color of this link
right or is the color of the shop now
button so we can change the color here
the color is
sky blue so
let's try to do it so here you can see
the color seems a little bit different
now I don't know the actual value of
this color that's why I'm not sure about
it so what we'll do is
we'll make it a little
more bright
save it now
and you can see it looks same now so
this was the color we found that now we
have to change the color of this button
on hovering over it so what we'll do is
we'll write here
dot Banner a
over
so
the background we are going to change
we'll write here hash D4
76 e
1.
okay one e
the color codes are pretty hard to
remember so we are not using this
particular color so we'll change
it to a little bit blue
save it now move to the browser and you
can see it looks nice right
and the actual website it's a little bit
dull but in our website it looks nice
right it's a little bit dark than the
original color
so that's fine you can change the color
according to you
so you have seen that this part is also
done it looks nice right till now
the task we did was quite easy the next
thing we have to do is to add products
to our website which are the courses
We'll add those images to our website
using Json only so let's do the HTML
part first let's finish up the HTML part
and then we'll move on to the Json part
so we'll
move to the HTML file again and inside
this
now what we'll do is we'll Define the
section for
products so we'll write here
section
class is equals to
section 2
and ID is equals to
products fine we'll use both the class
and the ID attribute for this particular
section
we'll write here div
class is equals
to title
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here H1
and inside this we'll write courses we
offer
here we'll again add another div
and inside this will write class is
product
close this div tag
save it and there will be no difference
on the web page you can see here we have
some text present at the bottom which
says courses we offer nothing else let's
add those images now what we'll do is
we'll move to the Json file and we'll
add those images with some properties
and pictures so let's move on to the
Json file
so here is a Json file products dot Json
what we'll do is we'll create an object
here so we'll write here
items
and then we'll use square brackets now
one thing to notice while working on any
Json file is that Json doesn't let us
use single inverted commas or we have to
use double inverted commas for Json file
so if we write here items like this
foreign
so in Json file we have to use double
inverted comma or double quotes not
single quotes So now inside the items
what we'll do is we'll create the object
for first image so we'll write here says
and then we'll write here ID
so ID will be
1.
we have to use commas to separate the
properties so now we'll write here
fields
colon and inside this we have to use
title so the title for first course will
be
Python programming
Master course fine
now next thing we'll do is we'll write
here
the price
the price will be let's say one to three
point nine nine dollars
and then we'll write here
image
so inside this we'll Define
several properties for the particular
image we'll write
fields
and we'll use colon then again we'll use
curly braces we'll write here
file
colon then again we'll use curly braces
we'll write here
URL
so you can see it just says there's an
error so we have to remove this curly
braces from here and we have to put it
here now inside URL what we'll do is
will give
the name of a file so a file is stored
in images folder and the file name is
and the picture name is
python.png fine
so it is working fine now what we have
to do is we have to put a comma here to
again insert one more
image property so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it
for 8 times
then what we are going to do here now is
we are going to change the ID
the title of the course
so the second course is C plus plus
Master course
and the price for this is let's say
110.99 we have to change the path as
well this image is stored as
C plus plus dot PNG
for the third one we'll write here ID as
the title is going to be web development
for beginners
the price is let's say
99 because this is a course for
beginners and the file name is
instead of python we'll write here
web1.png
will do the same for all the elements
so next up we'll use ids4
and title is
Java programming
Master course fine
the price for this course is going to be
149.99 and the file name is
java.png
fine next up we'll write here ID is 5.
the title is going to be digital
marketing
full course
the price is going to be
109.99 dollars
and the name of image is
digital.png
then we have IDs 6 for another course
this course is going to be
advanced
web development and the price is going
to be comparatively High because this is
an advanced course so instead of python
we'll write here
web2 because this is the name of our
image then we have ID S7
and the file name is going to be data
structures and algorithms
full course
as you can decide by yourself so instead
of 123 we'll use 99.99 here and inside
this will write data.png this is a file
name
then we have the ID as 8 for the last
course
okay
the course name is
data science full course
the price is going to be 149
and image name is
data 2.
fine
so here you can see it says there is an
error remove this comma because we don't
have any other image remaining so we are
done with the Json file all of this may
sound a little bit tricky to you guys
but it is what it is and we have to keep
certain things in mind for that we can't
see these products in the browser until
we are done with the JavaScript part as
well so let's do the rest of the HTML
part first and then we'll see how this
works in JavaScript save it once go to
the browser
and here you can see we are not able to
see those products till now
so what we are going to do next is we
are going to move to a HTML file and
inside this we are going to do the
remaining of a HTML part so what we'll
do is we'll write here div
class is equal to cart
sidebar
now we are creating the structure for
our card sidebar it means that when we
use the hamburger menu or when we
decrease the size of a web page or web
browser the card will open at the site
so we are doing the coding for that
we'll write inside this div
class is equals to cart
and inside here we'll write
pen
class is equals to
close cut
now inside this we'll add an icon we'll
write a i
class is equals far far times
and we are done with it now next up what
we are going to do is we are going to
write the code inside of a cart we are
going to write here H2 it will say
your card
and inside this we'll write div
class is equals
to
card content next up will write here div
class is equals
to total
sum
and we are going to use dollars right so
we'll write here
H1
will write here
your total and
we'll use the dollar sign here
after this we'll write span class is
equals
to total
amount let's say we are going to change
the class name it will be total amount
we'll close this here and inside this
we'll write 0 because at the start there
will be no element or no product present
in the cart so the total price will be 0
at the initial point so that's why we
have written 0 here
now we are going to write here div
class is equals
to clear cut
and inside this we are going to create a
button
so the button class will be
BTN
clear card BTN so this is going to be a
class and here what we'll do is we'll
write here
clear card fine
we are going to do the same for proceed
button as well so we'll write here div
class is equals to
clear card we are going to use the same
class for both the buttons because I'll
let you know what why we are doing this
at the end of this project now we'll
write here
button
class is equals
to button
clear card
button
fine we'll write here
proceed
we are done with the card function now
what we are going to do is we are going
to write some code for the menu bar side
menu bar so we'll write here
div
class is equals to let's say
menu sidebar inside this we'll write div
class is equals to close menu
and we'll write here I
class is equals
to Far Far times
and we'll close this eye tag over here
next up we'll write here after this
class we'll write div
class is equals to menu let's say this
name is menu menu bar
and inside this will write here
an ordered list class will be
menu list
foreign
[Music]
class is equals to
menu list items and we'll write here a
hrefs
is equals to Hash we'll write your home
and we are good to go fine we'll do the
same for categories pricings and about
us so
we'll copy this
statement
we'll paste it for four times here we'll
write instead of Home categories
pricings and about us fine so we are
done with the whole HTML part now and we
are left with CSS and JavaScript only
let's do that as well let's move on to
the CSS part first and do the rest of
the styling except for the products
we'll do it for products at the last so
let's move on to the CSS file first and
what we'll do is
so that it will not create any confusion
we'll write here menu bar because we
have to write the code here between this
Banner style property and this menu bar
for the products section so that's why I
will start writing the code from here
and later we'll add our code here in
between
so we'll write here dot menu
sidebar display will be none
and then we'll write here Dot
cart
sidebar
background is going to be
hash
e-c-e-c-e-c so a little bit grayish
white we can say
well right here position as
fixed
right as 0
and top is 0.
so these are the properties we are
defining in a CSS part then we'll write
your width as 450 pixels and
height is
100 viewport height fine
we'll Define the Z index as well we'll
write here Z index
is 10
transition
is all at 0.3 seconds and the transition
will be linear fine
next up we'll write here
transform
and inside transform will write here
translate X fine so inside here we'll
write
100 percent
it will go along with the x-axis that's
why we have written it over here we'll
write here overflow
crawl
we are done with it next up we'll write
here dot cart
sidebar and will right here dot cart as
well so we'll Define padding here we'll
write here padding 0 in both
the cases
next up we have
dot cart and
close card right so we'll write here for
both of them we'll write here Dot card
space close card the font size is going
to be 1.3 m
padding is going to be 1M
foreign
we'll write here Dot
for times
inside this we'll write
margin top
as 0.5 m
and we'll write here cart H2
this text
align will be center for the heading of
a cart which is your card so we'll write
your width is
100 percent
margin bottom is going to be 1 m
and
what else we have to do we have to
include the font size as well so we'll
write a font
size is 1.1 M slightly bigger than the
default font size then we'll write here
font family let's use only one
fine
let's use vardana only
so we'll write your vardana and next up
we'll write here Dot
card product
space dot product
Dash image
space IMG now we are going to write here
something now we are going to write the
code for all the images present inside
the cart so that's why we are writing
here width
is 130 pixels
of that particular image the width is
going to be 130 pixels and the height is
going to be
90 pixel let's say
fine
we are done with this as well
next up we'll write here
dot cart
content fine
now we'll write here display is flex
direction is
column
and we have
justify content as space around
and align items at the center
we'll write your margin
left is 1 m
and
height is
80 pixels fine
we are done with this as well we'll
write here dot plus Dash minus
this is for increasing or decreasing the
product number in our Cuts those arrows
you must have remember which we have
seen in the website let me show you
again
so these are the arrows I'm talking
about let me add a product
now go to cart and these are the arrows
I'm talking about right now
so we are going to style those arrows as
well
so we'll write here
display is flex
and
transform
we are going to rotate them so we are
going to write here rotate
at
90 degree
that will look cool so we'll write here
color is
again
hash
f09d51 so this is the color code for a
particular color we'll write here font
size is 1.5 m
and we'll write here
cursor as pointer
next up we are going to do the styling
for total sum so we'll write here
total sum
text align at the center
and margin is
going to be 1M
0 0 point
5m and
0 again
so it's for top bottom left and right
everyone
so we'll write here next
clear card
text align at the center
and we'll write here clear card
button
now for the clear card button we'll
write here
background
so background color is going to be
again that same one
orange we can say or little bit of
orange as well and don't know the exact
name for that color but it doesn't
matter right we can
do anything we can use any color so the
font color is going to be white
the border is going to be one pixel
solid
and
white in color for the button right if
we go back to our website and you can
see here this is our button
so we are styling this particular button
now
let's go back here
and we'll write here
padding is
0.5 m
and 1.7 fine
cursor will be pointer
and of course transition is going to be
at 0.3 seconds and
linear fine
next up we'll write here
clear card
dot button
on hovering over it what we want is
we'll write here whoever
and we'll Define the property now so
we'll write here
border
okay
we'll write here border border is going
to be one
pixel thick solid in nature
end of
this color so we'll write here D4
761e
fine
honoring the color will change
obviously so we'll write here this and
now what we are going to do is we are
going to write here background is
transparent
and
color is black
fine
are done with this as well next up we'll
write here overlay for overlay the
height is going to be
100 viewport height
the position is going to be
fixed
the top is going to be 0 similarly the
left
will also be 0
we'll Define the Z index as well we'll
write as Z index as 9.
and width has
100 percent
the background color
is going to be
hash
F 3 8 5
1f
fine
so this is for overlay will write here
opacity
as zero point
three
and
transition
is all
0.3 seconds and
linear fine so what we are doing is we
are writing the code for this if we open
our cart you can see this particular
area or this particular field is a
little bit different from what it was it
is a little bit different in color and
opacity is also different the opacity is
0.3 here we can make it fully opaque as
well so for now we'll use 0.3 only
next up what we are going to do is we
are going to write the property
for none we'll write in none
display is none fine now what we are
going to do is we are going to write the
CSS part for tablets and for Mobile
screen so if you remember that if we
reduce the size of this Chrome browser
the size of our website also reduces and
it becomes like this so to achieve this
we have to write particular CSS code for
tablet and for phone we have to define
the max width and we have to do some
more things in there so what we'll do is
we'll write here
at the rate
media
screen and
Max width is going to be
768 pixels fine
now inside this we'll write dot logo
will change the logo
as well
right here padding left is
zero
and after this we are going to write
here dot cart heading right is 2m
after card will write your dot menu bar
so we are going to change all the
properties here almost all the
properties which we'll require so we'll
write a display as none the menu bar
will disappear we'll write here dot
Burger
and inside this we'll write
margin left the burger sign will come
into existence now
we'll write here 2m for the margin left
for display
will write your block
next up we have to do something for
Section 1 and for product section as
well so we'll write here Dot
section one and we'll write here Dot
Banner H1
so we'll write here font size is 1.5 m
and we'll write here Dot
Banner a we are going to change the size
of a
shop now button so we'll write here
font size is 0.6 m
and padding is 1 M end
2m
fine
we are done with this as well next up
we'll write here
dot section
two
dot title
and we'll write here H1
inside this we'll write font
size is
1.5 m
so we haven't defined the section 2 when
Title styling part yet we'll Define it
later but we'll write the code for that
as well now next up we'll write here
menu sidebar
display is going to be block
position is going to be
fixed
left is going to be zero top is going to
be 0 so we'll write here left is going
to be 0
and top will also be zero
then we have
width is
100 percent
height is
100 V Port height
and
Z index is
background is going to be
gray again so we'll write a ecec
then we'll write here
overflow is
hidden
and
transform
is
translate so we'll write here minus
hundred
percent
and
transition is again same we'll write a
0.3 s and
linear fine
next up we'll write here menu is menu
bar
and inside here we'll write
display is flex height is 80 percent
justify content at the center
and we are done so next up we'll write
here menu
list we'll change the style of menu list
as well
so we'll write here
height height is going to be
100 percent
then we'll write here display is flex we
are rewriting the code again and again
but each time we are doing it for
different class we are doing it for
different element
so keep these things in mind
and we'll write here Flex
Direction
is column
align items at the center
and just Define content
justify content as space around now it's
time to do it for menu sidebar for menu
sidebar
and for close menu both will use the
same styling properties
we will write here position
as absolute
right is going to be
30 pixels
font size is going to be
1.4 m
and after this we'll write
Dot
menu list
items
and we'll write here
color
is Hash
f09d51 the default color we are using
till now
and lastly we'll write here
dot menu Dash list
items space a on
Hoover will write here
color is
h
F 5 7 B 0 9.
fine so here's a mistake we have
placed colon here twice
we'll remove it
and now we are done with the tablet part
so we have to change the style of almost
all the elements we are done with the
tablet part next up we have to write the
same code for mobile part as well
and we'll write here at the rate media
green
so we'll write here and Max width
is going to be
480 pixels
now what we'll do is we'll write here a
strict font size
is going to be 16 pixel here we have
changed the font size for the whole
entire HTML document we have done it
because we have used m in place of Ram
or pixels in this case or in this video
so that's why we have changed the size
here because we want the screen to be
smaller in size right if we go back here
you can see
the font size is 16 by default and if we
do it you can see the font size changes
for each and every element right to
achieve this we have to use m in place
of pixel or Ram we can say now the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to write here Dot
section
Dot
Banner
and we'll write here
width as
280 pixels for both
and we'll write here height
as 100 pixels fine
you can see here the height of this
image is 100 pixel or we can say the
height of this Banner is 100 pixel and
the width is 280 pixels so this is why
we are changing the style of all these
elements because we want all these
elements to fit inside a smaller screen
that's why we have to change the height
or we have to change the width as well
now what we'll do is we'll write here
section
one dot
Banner
we'll write here H1
inside this we'll write font size
is
1.2 M display is going to be we don't
have to use display here I guess let's
leave it
so we are done with this next up we'll
write the code for Burger we'll write a
burger margin left is going to be 1 m
for mobile
for mobile the display is going to be
block
and the width is going to be
30 pixel fine
we'll do the same for cart sidebar
will right here
width
as hundred percent of the screen the
cart will take whole screen and will
write here at the last for product
so for product we'll write here
margin is zero display is flex
justify content at the center
align item set the center
and flex direction is going to be column
so we have covered almost every HTML
element in the CSS file we are done with
the styling for everything except
products we'll style them later let's
move on to the JavaScript part now and
see how we can fetch those products so
we cannot witness every style change
right now but we'll witness them while
covering the JavaScript part so let's
move on to the JavaScript part first and
we'll start with the card section and
the hamburger menu thing
so save it and if you want to witness
the changes we made you can go here and
you can see the cart is not opening
because we need to write the JavaScript
part for that and everything else
Remains the Same if we reduce the size
of our browser you can see we have a
menu over here we can increase the size
and we have
a image adjusting itself accordingly so
we can use it and it's quite responsive
as well
let's move on to the JavaScript part now
we'll open the JavaScript file and
first of all we'll access all HTML
elements with the query selector method
so we have several HTML elements right
here you can see we have several
elements present in our HTML file we are
going to access few of these elements so
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here
const
cart is equals to document
dot query selector
we are going to write here
navs piece dot cart
then we are going to do the same for a
long
time so what we are going to do is we
are going to copy paste this piece of
code again and again
for several times we are going to change
the name of variables so we'll write
here
card sidebar and instead of this will
write here
Dot cards sidebar
the next one will write here
Dot
close cut and here the variable name
will change to
close card
fine next up we'll take another variable
as
burger and here we'll change
the query
from nav Dot card to dot Burger fine
next up we have menu sidebar so we'll
write here menu sidebar and here what
we'll do is we'll write here
Dot
menu
sidebar
fine next up we have
close menu
and here we'll
write
close menu again after close menu we
have cart items total
so we'll write here cart
items
total and
we will use
noise
then we have total amount as well so
we'll write here total amount
and here we'll write card price total
we have to access a lot of elements so
then we'll write here cart
UI and
for this we'll access
card sidebar and cart so we will write
here dot cart
sidebar space card
fine
then we have the total sum so we'll
write here total sum
we'll put a dot over here
and here we'll write
total diff
then we have the clear button so we'll
write here clear
button and here we'll write
clear card button
then finally we have
variable name card content
to access everything present in the cart
so we'll write here Dot card
content
here we'll write
card content
so these are 12 variables and we have
accessed almost every element present in
a HTML file which we are going to need
further so I hope you guys understood
this we have used the query selector
method to access all the HTML elements
here in the JavaScript part now next up
we'll take two empty arrays
so we'll write here let
cart
is equals to an array
and we'll write here let buttons Dom and
it's again going to be an array
fine now we'll first create some events
to open and close the card for that
we'll write here
cart Dot
add event listener
will add a click event here
and we'll write here function
now inside this we'll write cart Dot
we'll write card sidebar
dot Style
Dot
transform is equals
to
translate zero percent fine so this is
we are changing the style of card
sidebar
next up we'll write here
const body overlay will take a variable
of named const body overlay we'll write
here document
Dot
create element
and we'll write here
div inside this fine
next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
body overlay
Dot
classlist dot add
and we'll write here
only
fine
we'll use the set timeout method so
we'll write here
set timeout
okay we have written here SST so we'll
write a set timeout
then we'll create an anonymous function
and inside here what we'll do is we'll
write
document dot query selector
and inside here we'll write body then
we'll write here append and will append
body overlay here so we'll write here
body overlay
fine and the time will pass here is
going to be 300 milliseconds
we are done with this function We'll add
another event so what we'll do is we'll
write here close
cart dot add event listener
now we are closing the card so we'll
write here
click then we'll
create a function
and we'll write here
card sidebar Dot
tile Dot
transform and again we'll translate it
to 100 percent
previously we did for zero percent and
now we'll translate it to 100 again so
we'll write here translate and we'll
pass hundred percent inside the brackets
here
next up we'll again use the body overlay
variable so we'll copy this from here
and we'll paste it here we'll of course
change the create element value so
instead of create element we'll write
here
document
dot query selector
and we'll write here
Dot
overlay fine
next up we'll write here document
Dot query selector
and we'll write here body
Dot
remove child will remove body overly
from here so we'll write here
body overlay fine
we are good to go save it now
and go to the browser
so here you can see on clicking the cart
a cart is working totally fine now we
are in this particular program so we are
in a website which we are creating right
now this is the original website this is
the final product so leave it and we are
going to work on our website only so
here you can see our cart is working
totally fine now we can open or close
our cart and we have two options over
here one is for clearing the entire card
and the other one is for proceeding
further next up we'll add some more
events for the hamburger menu now how to
open or close that menu and all so for
that we'll move to a Javascript file
again and we'll write here
Burger Dot
add event listener
and we'll add a click event we'll write
here click we'll write here
function
and then we'll write here
menu sidebar Dot
tile Dot transform and what we are going
to do is we are going to translate
again we are going to translate it to
zero percent
now the same thing we have to do for
this as well we'll write here Burger
dot add event listener
inside here Will
right click and then we'll write a
function
which will again do the same task it
will translate to minus hundred percent
we'll write here menu sidebar Dot
tile Dot
transform and we are again going to
translate it to
minus hundred percent now
fine
save it
and go to the browser
now
if we decrease the size of a web page or
if we decrease the size of a browser you
can see okay let me decrease it first so
you can see the hamburger menu over here
and on clicking it's not working right
now so let's inspect those elements once
and there's no error but
let me check if there's any mistake okay
so we have to write here
close menu
and now I guess it will work fine
we'll save it again and we'll move to
the browser
reduce the size click on this hamburger
menu and you can see it's working
totally fine now
right
so this part is also done now what we
have to do next is we have to create a
class to get those products from the
Json file so keep your eyes open now
guys we'll see how it actually works so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a class named
product
so this is a class
we'll write here a sink I hope you are
already aware of async and a weight so
we'll write here get product
and this is a function
we'll write here const
response is equals to await and while
awaiting it will fetch
products Dot
Json fine
then we'll create a variable we'll write
here const
data is equals to await
response dot Json
fine
next up we'll write
products is equals to
data dot items
and we'll write
products is equals
to
products
dot map function we are going to use so
we'll write here again item
and then we'll use Arrow function we'll
write the body of this function here
we'll write here
const inside this will pass
title and price of the product
and we'll write here item Dot
Fields fine
similarly we'll do the same for ID as
well inside curly braces we'll write ID
and we'll write here item dot sys
then we'll write here
const
image now we are fetching the image so
we'll write here
item Dot
Fields dot image Dot
fields
we are actually giving the path right if
you see here in the Json file you can
see inside items we have says Fields
then inside Fields we have title price
image and then inside image we have
Fields file and URL so we'll access each
of them now we'll write here after
fields dot file
dot URL
and
lastly we'll write here return
title
price
ID and
image fine
finally we'll write here after this
return
products
cool
now what we are doing here is we are
getting the details of all the products
and storing them inside separate objects
so we have all the objects present over
here all those images were actually
stored inside the local storage
and now we can fetch them from that
particular storage now we'll create
another class for the user interface of
the product so if you save it now and go
to the browser
you will see no difference over here
because it's not working as of now if
you go to inspect elements and console
you can see it says
length mismatch
it's because of the live server so
there's no error over here
now we'll create another class for the
user interface of the products we'll add
those products to the cart and we can
delete them from the cart we'll do
everything inside one single class so
let's do it
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here
class let's say the class name is UI
and we'll write here
display products and we'll write here
products
then we'll right here inside this let
result be a variable
and
will leave it empty over here
next line will use the for each Loop so
we'll write here products
Dot
for each
and inside this we'll
create an arrow function
so we'll write here
const
product div let's say is a variable and
then we'll write here
document Dot
create element
again we are going to create an element
so we'll write here div
and
after this what we are going to do is we
are going to write here product
div Dot
inner HTML
is equals to
now the main part starts so inside this
will write
div
class is equals
product card
and then we'll write
IMG
will add the image so here we'll write
mgsrc is equals to
dollar
product
Dot image we are going to fetch it and
instead of Alt
in place of alt we'll write
alt as
product
the next line will use the span tag
again we'll write here span class
is equals to
add to cart
and we'll then write here
data ID is equals to
product dot ID
May close this tag we'll close this
spend tag we can say in the next line
we'll use the I tag we'll write a i
class is equals to
foreign
card
Plus
for One X
now what we are doing is we are going to
show the number of items present in a
cart over the cart icon that's why we
are doing all this so here what we'll do
is we'll write style is equals to margin
Dash right
margin rate is going to be 0.1 m
and
font size is going to be
1M
fine
close this as well close the eye tag as
well
and in the next line
right here
add to cart
so the spend tag is finally we are going
to close it now this is a single tag
I have written it in such a way because
I don't want it to create any sort of
confusion for you guys so the spend tag
starts from here and go still here now
we are remaining with some more part of
it so in the next line what we are going
to do is we are going to write here div
class is equals
product name and here we'll write dollar
product dot title
and we are going to close this div tag
in the next line we are going to write
div again
class is going to be product pricing
and inside here we'll write
product Dot
price
and we are going to close this div tag
here
close
in the first div tag as well
and
Omega 2. in the next line what we are
going to do is we are going to write
here
const p is equals to
document Dot
query selector and inside this will
write
Dot
product we are going to access the
element with product test class or we
are going to access the product query
then we'll write here P dot append
equal to
product div what we are doing is any
item we are adding to cart is we are
going to append that item inside the
cart so that's what we are doing till
now now the next thing we are going to
do is we are going to write here a
function
get buttons
basically a Constructor we can say we'll
write here const
buttons
will write accounts buttons is equal to
document Dot
query selector
we have to write a query selector all
and then we are going to write here
inside this
dot add to
cart fine we have been through all these
query selector methods previously so I
don't think that this is going to create
any sort of problem for you guys
so let's move ahead and
we'll write here array Dot
from
will write here buttons
then we'll write here buttons
Dom is equals to buttons we are going
to pass the value of buttons to buttons
Norm then we'll write buttons Dot
for each
and inside here we'll write
button and we are going to create an
arrow function over here
here what we'll do is we'll write here
let ID is equals to
button
Dot
data set dot ID in the next line we'll
write let
in cart
is equals
cart Dot
find and we are going to pass item
to this function
so we are going to
write inside here
item and again an arrow function we'll
write here item dot ID
triple is equals
to ID
fine
we're going to check the condition here
if we write here if
in cart
then we'll write here
BTN Dot
inner HTML
is equals
to in cart so what we are doing is if we
have added the
product to cart already then the button
will change as we have seen earlier that
on adding the product once to the card
the button will change to incart from
add to cart so this is what we are doing
here
next up we'll write here
button dot disabled
is equals to true we are going to
disable that button once the product is
added to cart fine
next up we'll write here
button dot add event listener
and we are going to create an event
we'll write here click
and
let e here then we'll use the arrow
function
foreign
Target Dot
inner HTML is equals to
incart
then we'll write a e Dot
current Target dot nihtml okay we'll
write a e dot current Target Dot
tile Dot
color
is equals to White
e Dot
current Target Dot
style Dot
pointer events equals to none
and we are done with it next up we are
going to store the products in the cart
so for that what we are going to do is
we are going to write here let
cart item is equals to so we are going
to use a little bit of Json now
I'll write here
Dot
storage
get storage products
we'll write a ID
comma
amount
and the amount is going to be 1
will write here
card dot push
we are going to push the cart item to
the cart
so we will write here cart item
and then we'll write yes
storage we are going to store it inside
the cart so we'll write here storage dot
safeguard
and we'll pass cart over here
fine now we have to calculate the total
and we have to set the total items as
well so for that we'll write here
this Dot
set card values
we'll write here cart
and to display those cart item we have
to write here this dot add card item and
we have to add that cart item so we'll
write here
this Dot
add card items
item
and we'll
because cart item over here
fine we are done with the working of
cart as well next up what we are going
to do is we are going to change the
total value of cart we are going to
change the value of carton increasing or
decreasing the card products so first of
all we have to write here
set card values and we have to pass cart
over here we have to write here
let's say we have a variable
total so this is going to be a temporary
variable we'll write here time total is
equals to 0 and we'll take another
variable
for that we'll write here
item total
so item total is also going to be 0
now we'll map this card so for that
we'll write a card dot map
we'll write your item
we'll use Arrow function so for that
we'll write here
temp total
plus is equals to
item Dot
price
into
item Dot
amount
so this is how we are going to get the
total amount and then we'll write here
item basically we are swapping all of
that so we'll write here item totals
is equal to
item Dot
amount we have to add these two values
so we'll write here item total plus is
equals to item dot amount fine
now we'll write here
parse float
and we are going to change these values
just like percent we have parse float as
well so inside pass float we'll write
time total
Dot
to fixed
and we are going to fixed it until two
decimal units
fine next up we'll write here cart items
total Dot
inner HTML
is equals to
items total
and we'll write here cart
price total
dot inner HTML is equals to
parse float
we'll write here temp
total
note
2 fixed and will fix it up to two
decimal units fine
next up we'll write here add
card item
now we'll write here cart item
and inside this we'll write let
cart item
UI
is equals
two document Dot
create element
we'll write here div
we'll write here cart item
UI
Dot
inner HTML
is equals to we are again going to do
the same task
so we are going to use the backtick for
that so here we'll write
div
class
is equals to
card product
and we'll write here div
class is equals to product image right
here IMG SRC
is equal so we are going to fetch the
image again so we'll write here dollar
and inside this will write
cartitem Dot
image
and ALT will be
product in this case as well
next up we are going to close this div
tag
and we are going to start another div
tag here so we'll write here div
class is equals
card
product item
sorry card product content we can say
and then
we'll write here
in the next slide
div
class
is equals
to
card product name
will write here inside H3 tag
so inside H3 tag we'll write
dollar
cart item Dot title
and we are going to close this H1 tag
over here H3 tag sorry
H3 tag over here then we'll close this
div tag as well we are again going to
create another div tag this time we are
going to write the class
is
card product
price we are going to fetch the price
now
will right here
again
H3
so our price is in dollars so we'll use
dollars for now we can use rupees here
as well so we can write here
cart item Dot
price the price is going to be in
dollars then we'll
close this tag
and we are also going to close the div
tag here fine
in the next line
we are going to create the product
remove card
so we are going to create a div tag for
that and the class is going to be card
product remove data
ID is going to be cart ID so we'll write
here cart
item dot ID
and then we'll write here
href is equals
to hash
and style is going to be
color is going to be
red
and then we'll write here remove
I'm going to close the
anchor tag and then the
div tag fine
so we are done with this till now then
we are going to again close this
particular div tag we used previously
now what we are going to do is we are
going to change the number of products
so we are going to use here class
is equals to
plus minus
and here we'll write
inside the itech
class is equals to
for for angle
left
add amount
fine
this is going to be the class
and
the data ID is going to be
cart Item ID so we are going to write
here data ID is equals to
dollar
and inside this we'll write
cart Item ID
dot ID
and then we are going to
close this tag and we are going to close
the eye tag here fine
next up we are going to use this pen tag
again we are going to write here
pen
class is equals
to
number of items
and we'll close this tag here we'll
write dollar
foreign
Dot
amount
we are going to close this pen tag here
so we'll write here slash span
in the next line we are again going to
use
data ID
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here
dollar and we'll write here
cart item dot ID
we are going to close the itag again
and in the next line we are going to
close the div tag
and one more detail fine
now we are done with it
let me close this first and
next up we'll append this card content
to the cart item UI so we will write
here
card
content Dot
append and inside this will pass
cart item
UI
fine
so here you can see we are going to
close
close this so this is the closed one
and inside here we'll write
setup app
again a
Constructor we are going to write here
cart
is equals
to storage Dot
get card
we will write this
Dot
set card values
card here
and then we'll write card dot map
inside this will write item
and inside the body we'll write
this Dot
add cart item
item
fine I hope you guys are getting this
next up we'll write the cart logic here
we'll write a card logic
and we'll write here
clear button
dot add event listener
we are going to create an event again
we'll write here click
hello
comma a function
and inside this we'll write this Dot
clear cut we are going to call this
function over here
now we have
to write the logic for
remove button so we'll do it here
we'll write here
card content dot add event listener
foreign
event
and we'll write here
inside this if
event Dot
Target
Dot
classless
dot contains
chord
product remove
then we'll again create a variable let's
say the variable is let
okay we have made a mistake over here
we have to close this bracket here
and then we have to write here
thank you
let ID is equals
to event Dot
Target Dot
dataset dot ID
in the next line will write
this Dot
remove item and will pass ID here fine
in the next line we'll write here let
div is equals
to event
dot Target Dot
parent element
and we are going to use parent element
for quite some time now so we are going
to write here Dot
parent element again
for four times so we'll write here
parent element Dot
parent element so we have written it
four times here
in the next line we'll write here div
Dot
remove
child
and we'll write here event Dot
Target
Dot
will copy it from here
and we'll paste it here fine
now in the next line
we are going to close this bracket
and we are going to start writing here
else if
event Dot
Target
dot classlist dot
contains
add amount
then what we are going to do is we are
going to use the ID variable again we
are going to write here let ID is equal
to
event dot Target
Dot
dataset dot ID
let item is equals to
cart dot find
will pass item here and
we'll use the arrow function so we'll
write here item Dot
ID triple equals to ID
fine then we'll write here
item Dot
amount
plus plus so we are going to increase
the amount
of items then what we are going to do is
we are going to write a storage Dot
Save card and we are going to pass card
here
we'll write here this Dot
set card values
card
we will write a event Dot
Target
Dot
next element sibling dot inner HTML
is equals to item Dot
amount fine
now we are going to
use another elsewhere so we'll write
here else if
event Dot
Target Dot
classlist dot contents
reduce amount
so we are going to change the number of
products in our cart so for that what
we'll do is we'll write here
let ID is equals to
event dot data set
even Dot Target dot data set
dot ID fine
and item will be
let item is equals to
foreign
item
item dot ID
triple equals to ID
if we are again going to use an if
statement so we'll write here item Dot
amount
is greater than 1 if the number of items
is greater than 1
then
item Dot
amount
minus minus
and store it
inside the cart so we are going to write
here storage dot safeguard
and we'll pass card here
then we'll write here this Dot
set card values
and will again pass cart here
in the next line we'll write here
event Dot
Target
Dot
previous element sibling
dot inner HTML
is equals to item Dot
amount
and finally we'll write here else
and inside the else what we'll do is
we'll write here
this Dot
remove item
and we'll pass the ID we'll write here
let
div is equals
to event dot Target we are basically
targeting the events we are creating
conditions for certain different events
like when the user increases the number
of products and the user decreases the
number of products and if the user
removes the product from the card so we
are writing the code for that so we'll
write a event dot Target Dot
parent element
and we'll write here parent element
again for
four times
fine
we'll write here div Dot
remove child
and inside this we'll write even Dot
Target Dot
parent element for four times again
it will check each parent element
so
here we are done with it next up
we have to create two functions for add
amount and for reduce amount so what we
are going to do is we are going to
write here
add amount
and we'll write here
const
add button is equals to
document Dot query selector
all
inside this will pass DOT
add amount fine
we'll write here add button
Dot
for each
and we'll write here inside this
button dot add event listener
and we'll add an event over here we'll
write a click
comma event
will pass event here and then we'll
write here
like this
let ID
is equals to
event Dot
current Target Dot
data set
dot ID fine we'll write here
cart Dot
map
and we'll pass item over here we'll
write here again Arrow function and
inside this what we are going to do is
we are going to write here item Dot
amount plus plus
foreign
storage Dot
Safeguard we are going to pass cart here
we'll write here this Dot
set card values we are again going to
set the cart values and
will again use
amount UI a new variable and will
write here event Dot
current Target Dot
parent element
Dot children
fine so we are targeting the parent
element along with the children
so we'll write here
amount UI
dot in HTML is equals to item Dot
amount
so we have forgot to mention here
if
item dot ID
is equals to ID
then do it fine
now we are going
to do the same thing for reduce amount
as well so we'll write here
reduce amount
and inside this we'll write
const
reduce button is equals to document
Dot
query selector all
and we are going to pass here Dot
reduce amount
fine
we'll write here reduce
button Dot
for each
then we'll pass button over here and
we'll use the arrow function again
finally we'll write here button dot add
event listener
click
event
let ID
is equals to
event dot current
Target
dot data set
dot ID
fine
we'll write here card dot map will map
it to cart
and we'll write here item
then again we'll write here if
temp item dot ID
triple equals to ID
then we'll
right here item amount minus minus so
we'll write here item Dot amount minus
minus and if
item Dot
amount is greater than zero
then what it will do
it will
store it inside the
locals to read so we'll write a storage
dot save cart
and we'll write here cart
then we'll write this
Dot
set card values
card
const
UI
is equals
to event
Dot current Target dot parent element
dot children
amount UI dot inner HTML is equals to
item Dot
amount
fine
again we'll write here else
what will happen we'll write here event
Dot
current Target Dot
parent element so here instead of parent
element we'll write
remove child and will write here
event
dot current Target
Dot
parentelement Dot parent element fine
and the next line we'll write
this Dot
remove item and we'll pass ID here
we are done with this part as well next
up we have to clear the card so for that
we'll write here
clear card
will again do something for that we'll
write here let cart item is equals cart
dot map inside this will write item
implies item dot ID
card item dot we'll again use the for
each Loop here
we will write here this then we'll
provide ID here
and we'll write here
this Dot
remove item will pass the ID over here
then we'll write your const
card product will create a new variable
here we'll write here
document Dot
query selector all and we'll write here
Dot
card product
write your card product
Dot
for each
for each item what we are going to do is
we are going to create
an arrow function here and we are going
to write a if item is true if item is
there
then item dot parent element
Dot
remove child
will remove the item now we have to
remove the item so for that we'll write
here remove
item and will pass ID to that item
will write here
card will update the value of cart
escort dot filter
we'll write here item
and then we'll write here item dot ID
not equals
to ID this
Dot
set card values
and we'll update the card pin
similarly we'll again write here storage
Dot
save cart
and we'll pass card here
then we'll write here let
button is equals to this
Dot
get single button
will write here ID
and we'll change the button style we'll
write here button dot style Dot
pointer events
is equals to
unset
then we'll write your button Dot inner
HTML
is equals to
backtick
I class will be Far Far Card Plus
we are going to close the I tag here
and we'll write here
add to
cart
fine next up we'll write here
get single button will pass ID over here
and we'll write the code for here we'll
write here let
BTN
then we'll write here
buttons Dom Dot
for each
for each button
what it will do is
we'll check if
button Dot
dataset dot ID
is equals to ID
then
BTN equals to
button
fine
here we will return
button
now save it
save this program go to browser
and this is our website go to browser
and you can see nothing is visible till
now we have to write a little more code
to make everything visible here now we
have to store the data in local storage
so that on refreshing the web page we
don't lose the data so what we'll do is
we'll go back to a Javascript file and
we'll write here
class
storage
equals to
static save products will pass products
here
then we'll open curly braces and we'll
write here local storage
Dot
set item
and inside this will write
products Dot
comma
Json Dot
stringify
products
when we are parsing the product from our
Json file now next up we'll write here
static
get storage products
will pass the ID here
and we'll write here let
important
is equals to
Json
dot parts
local storage Dot
get item
and will pass
products here
fine in the next line we'll write
return
products Dot
find
we'll write a item
item dot ID is equals to ID
fine
next up we'll again write a static
Save card
now we are saving the products or in our
cart so we'll write here
local storage dot set item
inside here will pass
cart and here we'll write
Json
Dot
stringify and will pass
cart over here
stop will write here static
get card we are getting the items from
the cart we'll write here return
local storage Dot
get item
cart
you will write question mark will pass
the Json file here we'll write here Json
Dot
parse
local storage Dot
get item
from the
cart fine
here we have two
put a square bracket a pair of square
brackets
and lastly we have to write a few lines
of code so we'll write here document dot
add event listener
and we'll write here
Dom
content
loaded so we are adding
one more event to our JavaScript file
which is the Dom content loaded so we
have to write here Dom content loaded
and here we have to write
inside the function
const
products
is equals
to new product
and we'll write here
const UI is equals to
new UI
now we have to showcart from local
storage so we'll write here UI Dot
setup app
and we'll write here
products Dot
get product
dot then
and inside this we'll write
products
equal
employees
UI Dot display
products will write here
products
storage Dot
save products and will pass
products here as well fine we'll write
here dot then
we are using promises so
here we'll write
UI Dot
get buttons
and UI Dot
card logic fine
now the JavaScript part is done we have
used Json here to make a web page more
responsive towards several aspects apart
from that we have used Json for adding
products to our website as well now we
are left with one more task only
let's do it and then we'll see the final
outcome of this extended code
so we'll move to the CSS file and we'll
start starting the products part let's
try if it's working or not let's save
this piece of code and go to browser
click on shop now
and it's not working we can see
okay
it says it's failed to load the resource
refresh it and you can see now it's
working totally fine we have all our
product images over here we have all of
our products we can add them to cart and
we can use the cart as well so the last
thing we have to do is to use products
now
now we have to style those products so
for that we'll move to our CSS file so
here's a CSS file
and inside this we have to write here
so we have put a comment over there
when we were not here so we have to
style the products over here so for that
we'll write here
dot section 2 Dot
title
and
text align at the center
then we'll write here section 2
Dot
title
H1
the font size is going to be
1.8 m
the margin is going to be
1.3 M then we have to write the code for
products here so we'll write your dot
product
and inside this we'll write margin is
0.5 m
we have to write here margin
we'll write a 0.5 M and Auto
Max width
is going to be 1300 pixels
display is going to be grid
column
is going to be so here it is going to be
grid column Gap and it is going to be
2m
then we'll write here
grid row Gap
and grid row Gap is going to be 2m as
well
then we'll write here
grid
template
columns and we'll write here repeat we
are going to create a grid for our
products right so we'll write a Auto
fit
comma min max
we'll write here 350 pixels
and
one draw
fine next up we'll write here Dot
product
card and now we are going to write here
text align as Center
position as relative
foreign
of the grid is going to be 350 pixels
and the Overflow is going to be
hidden
next up we'll write here
product card image
we'll write here height
is
300 pixels
width
as 300 pixels
and
transition is
0.3 seconds linear
fine
surely we'll do the same for product
name and product pricing so we'll write
here
product
name
comma
product
pricing
margin for them is going to be 0.3 M
will write here Dot
product
pricing and the color of the product
pricing is going to be
the one we have been using till now so
we'll write here F 0
9d51
then we have
to write the code for add to cart button
so we'll write here add to cart
will write here
align items to the center
justify the content to the center
and color is going to be white
padding is going to be 0.2 M and
one name
fine height is going to be
30 pixels
background
is going to be
the same
F9
d51
position is going to be
absolute
right is going to be 0 transform it's
going to be
Translate
along the x-axis too
100 percent
bottom is
going to be 80
pixels
we have to put a comma here
bottom is going to be 80 pixels
transition is going to be 0.3 seconds
again in linear
cursor is going to be pointer fine
then we have to write few more lines so
we'll write a product card
we'll write your hover
and we'll add add to cart here
so we'll write here transform
translate X
zero percent
we'll write here
product card
on hovering over the image so we'll
write here Hoover
IMG